[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur
les chaînes parlementaires émission
spéciale LCP Public Sénat pour vous
faire vivre en direct de l'Élysée en
direct de la salle des fêtes du palais
du président de la République sa grande
conférence de presse que vous allez
pouvoir suivre dans une petite vingtaine
de minutes très précisément bonsoir
Thomas HUG bonsoir Miriama je suis ravi
de vous accueillir sur sur ce plateau
pare la bienvenue c'est un bonheur de
participer de d'animer cette cette
soirée spéciale avec vous on est donc
ensemble jusqu'à 23h30 évidemment pour
d'abord à partir de 20h15 écouter
inextino la conférence de presse de du
président de la la République et puis
pour analyser sa vision les annonces il
en aura sans doute peut-être sûrement on
verra bien les choix politiques du chef
de l'État et puis beaucoup de réactions
on sera en direct avec Tam tranui depuis
l'Élysée pendant cette soirée et puis
nous avons à nos côtés et on en est ravi
quatre invités pour saisir les les
enjeux de cette prise de parole
présidentielle bonsoir Pascal Perino
bonsoir ravi de vous avoir sur ce
plateau politologue professeur à
sciencesp Paris bonsoir martial foucco
bienvenue directeur du cvipof le centre
de recherche politique de sciences pour
Paris Émilie zapalski communicante et
fondatrice de l'agence Émilie conseil
bonsoir et Stéphane zumsteek bonsoir
directeur du département Opinion à
l'institut de sondage hipsos allez on
attaque alors on va commencer par la
forme avec la communicante que vous êtes
Émilie zapalski le choix de la grande
conférence de presse à l'Élysée pas
moins de 400 journalistes français
étrangers accrédités ça n'est pas une
première pour Emmanuel Macron mais cette
grand messe cathodique à 20h15 c'est le
le prime time comme on dit dans le
jargon télévisuel ça c'est plus inédit
oui c'est plus inédit il a fait le choix
de quelque chose qui va arroser en fait
énormément pendant 7h 1h 1h30 2h on sait
pas exactement combien de temps
ça voilà on sera là pour commenter mais
voilà c'est c'est l'idée vraiment
d'investir tout l'espace médiatique et
de parler au français à tous les
Français parce que là pour le coup c'est
ouvert énormément c'est une heure où il
y aura beaucoup plus de Français que ce
qu'on a vu auparavant quand il avait pu
faire des 1 ou des interventions
différentes donc c'est une volonté voilà
il y a une attente forte on sent que
Emmanuel Macron il y a une attente et il
y a une volonté de de de commencer à à
donner plus de concret à ce qu'il a dit
parce qu'il a donné rendez-vous avec la
nation on n' pas su ça peut être un un
rendez-vous avec la nation une
conférence de presse par l'intermédiaire
des journalistes compr d'après ce qu'on
comprend de la communication de l'Élysée
ça fait partie du grand rendez-vous il
le situe même dès les vœux d'Emmanuel
Macron le remaniement c'est la deuxè
séquence et là ça ferait partie d'une
trème séquence mais on a du mal à y voir
clair sur ce que c'est ce grand
rendez-vous et puis avoir du concret et
savoir exactement ce qui va être abordé
comme thématique dans cette conférence
de pre parce que effectivement ce ce ce
discours cette presque j'allais dire
cette construction du rendez-vous avec
la nation finalement ça avait été
annoncé je crois avec un journaliste du
Monde c'était au début du mois de
décembre et puis finalement là c'est
devenu quand on écoute les communiqués
enéisé il a eu d'abord les vœux puis la
nomination de Gabriel et la troisème
étape c'est ce soir la conférence de de
de pr
c'est l'un des défis des journalistes ce
soir pasal Perino sortir de des éléments
de langage ésé quoi quand on dit
conférence XXL notamment voilà oui oui
oui oui en effet comme toujours souvent
dans la communication macronienne il y a
un peu de flottement on est dans la
société liquide hein on a des processus
en effet qui se qui sont un peu
extensibles on sait pas très bien quand
a
commencé la nouvelle phase et quand elle
va se terminer mais on y est on y est et
et après les vux en effet il y a eu ce
changement de gouvernement avec un un
très profond choc dans l'opinion les
Français s'attendaient pas tout à fait à
ce qui s'est passé à la fois dans le
choix du Premier ministre et puis dans
la confection de la l'équipe
gouvernementale premier g resserré
autour de 15 ministres mais au fond les
Français et on le voit dans les enquêtes
d'opinion ils disent c'est plutôt pas
mal cette nomination d'atal mais on
s'attend pas à ce que ça change beaucoup
les choses donc ils attendent de
l'efficacité d'aurs là que Gabri réussi
son passage ils se disent à juste titre
là on s'est intéressé au moyen du
changement hein un gouvernement resserré
un nouveau Premier ministre et cetera
mais ce ces moyens du changement c'est
au service de quel objectif et là sur
l'objectif on n'a pas encore de réponse
il y a eu quelques éléments de langage
envoyés par le Premier ministre mais on
est dans la 5e et là le président va
nous le
rappeler chef deex justement de l'action
de l'action de l'action des résultats
des résultats des résultats vous le
reconnaissez c'est Gabriel Atal que je
cite est-ce que ça correspond aux
attentes des Français ou est-ce qu'ils
attendent au fond une orientation
politique une vision politique où va le
pays et qu'est-ce que je peux attendre
de ce chef de l'État je je je dirais que
c'est l'enjeu un des enjeux de la prise
de parole ce soir du président de la
République parce que un instant quand
même revenons sur cette séquence c'est
pas tout à fait dans la pratique des
institutions de la 5e République qu'un
président de la République s'exprime
quelques jours avant le discours attendu
de politique générale du Premier
ministre qu'il vient de nommer c'est pas
la première fois qu'Emmanuel MACR c'est
pas la première fois
il mais qu'est-ce que ça dit de l'exerci
du c'est un rappel effectivement de la
conception qui est celle d'Emmanuel
Macron à la fois du pouvoir exécutif et
je dirais du positionnement du Premier
ministre je pense que on a utilisé
beaucoup de formules des premier
ministres d'ancien Président je pense
pas que Emmanuel Macron réhabilitera la
notion de collaborateur ce sera une
autre probablement une autre posture
mais c'est quand même très important
pour Emmanuel Macron d'indiquer que le
cap ou la feuille de route c'est lui qui
la maîtrise et c'est lui qui la dicte
par ailleurs ça c'est très important
pour pour moi est-ce que ce j' dirais
l'an 2 du 2è quinquena avec ce choix de
changement de gouvernement est
simplement une question de de de casting
alors peut-être que c'est lié à une
lecture peut-être trop attentive ou une
lecture une surconsommation je dis ça en
plaisentant d'enquête d'opinion publique
où Emmanuel Macon a pu remarquer
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
membres du gouvernement poser difficulté
auprès des Français n'imprimit pas
suffisamment ça comme ça donc nouveau
gouvernement et est-ce que les Français
comme disait Pascal Perino à l'instant
est-ce que les Français ont ont des
attentes très particulières vis-à-vis
des priorités auxquelles Emmanuel Macron
pourra peut-être répondre ce soir j'ai
le sentiment très personnel mais c'est
commandême la troisème prise de parole
en un mois m-décembre les vœux et ce
soir ça ve dire pardoninromp votre avis
Stéphan sur le degré d'attente de la
part des Français parce que certes mir
l'a rappelé à juste titre il joue la
carte de du prime time de la première
partie de soirée est-ce que pour autant
la parole présidentielle est à ce point
attendue par nos compatriotes le
principal enjeu pour le président de la
République c'est de susciter autre chose
que de l'indifférence en fait c'est ça
c'est ça le principal risque parce que
quand on regarde à l'exception
aujourd'hui il laisse indifférent les
Français ils ne l'écoutent plus en tout
cas non alors en tout cas ces dernières
prise de parole ont laissait les
Français indifférents je pense au vœux
je pense à un certain nombre de je pense
à à sa prise de parole avant l'été sur
les 100 jours sur le rendez-vous d'une
initiative de grande ampleur
démocratique qui finalement a débouché
sur Saint- 1 et saint-n 2 on peut pas
dire que ça ait suscité un enthousiasme
fou dans l'opinion publique pour pour
les Français qui en ont entendu parler
fa plusieurs pour danser donc il man un
peu de participant c'est vra surtout
surtout la deuxème étape ce n'est pas ça
qu'attendaient les Français là alors il
y a ce risque d'indifférence qui rien ne
serait pire pour un président de la
République et surtout pour lui ça
contribuerait sans doute à démonétiser
sa parole dans les mois et dans les
années qui viennent après en terme
d'attente non les Français n'attendent
rien de particulier ce soir mais ils
vont malgré tout le regarder assez
massivement et s'ils veulent entendre
quelque chose ce sont des mesures
concrètes on en a tous parlé s s'il
n'est pas concret il sera pas audible
sur quel thème français l'attend
précisément on en parle à chaque fois
c'est le pouvoir d'achat enfin c'est
vous vous l'évoquiez tout à l'heure si
Gabriel Attal a surgi dans les codes de
popularité c'est qu'il a donné
l'impression ou fait la preuve queil
pouvait agir sur la vie quotidienne des
parents d'élèves ou des élèves et d'un
coup il a surgi dans dans dans les
baromètres de de popularité ce que les
Français veulent c'est du concret sur ce
qui les intéresse le plus évidemment le
pouvoir d'achat on parlait tout à
l'heure du système de santé ça peut être
pour d'autres la transition écologique
ça peut être pour d'autres le
durcissement des
lois en matière de politique migratoire
mais des mesures concrètes des
propositions concrètes et pas juste un
discours un petit peu éteré on va parler
des Jeux Olympiques et de la réouverture
de NotreDame en décembre voilà c'est
c'est ça SAF que la question du pouvoir
d'achat avec un niveau de dette de 3000
milliards
d'eurosiéation est pas super simple on
va tout de suite rejoindre Tam tranu qui
est qui est à l'Élysée pour qu'elle nous
explique en quelques mots Tam on vous
laisse la parole comment ça va se passer
cette conférence de presse alors entre
200 et 300 journalistes sont attendus ce
soir dans la salle des fêtes de l'Élysée
pour cette conférence de presse XXL un
exercice rare pour le président de la
République dernier exercice du genre
date de 2019 Emmanuel Macron cherchait
alors à sortir de la crise des gilets
jaunes alors ce soir en plus des
journalistes on attend aussi bien sûr le
gouvernement le Premier ministre Gabriel
hatal sera présent ainsi que ses 12
ministres et trois ministres délégués
mais bien sûr et bien on attend surtout
la prise de parole d'Emmanuel Macron
prévu à 20h15 précise le prés président
de la République doit détailler ce qu'il
a présenté comme son réarmement civique
et économique on attend des annonces
concrètes sur l'éducation la santé ou
encore le pouvoir d'achat ensuite et
bien cette conférence de presse doit se
diviser en trois parties une première
partie de questions en rebond aux
annonces du président de la République
ensuite les questions de vie publique et
de vie politique donc plus
particulièrement consacré au remanement
c'est là aussi que l'on attend les
questions sur la polémique qui touche la
nouvelle ministre de l'éducation
nationale Amélie oudea Castera enfin une
troè partie qui sera consacrée aux
questions international euh les
journalistes sont priés et bien de dire
euh dans quelle parti s'intègre la
question qu'ils souhaitent poser ils
sont priés aussi de faire cours pas de
relance pas de question à tiroir on nous
promet aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron fera
cours car l'objectif aussi c'est de ne
pas lasser les téléspectateurs que
l'Élysée espère nombreux euh ce soir
l'ensemble de l'exercice doit durer 2h
2h30 mais on connaît le chef de l'État
cela pourrait être plus long et la nuit
ou en tout cas la soirée s'annonce
longue merci beaucoup Tam tranui charge
au président de de tenir sa sa parole
alors Emmanuel Macron qui fait cours bon
euh demand on demande à voir donc on a
parlé des des attentes des Français sur
leur avenir il y a aussi les polémiques
à déminer Tam tranui on parlait à
l'instant à commencé par l'entrée
fracassante d'Amélie oua Castera au
ministère de l'Éducation après ses
propos sur les paquets d'heur non
remplacés à l'école publique pour
justifier la scolarisation de son fils
dans le privé des propos qui ont fait
bondir les syndicats qui l'ont même Hué
on va revoir les les images elle date de
ce matin des Hué devant l'école litré où
elle s'est rendue pour s'excuser
rencontrer l'enseignante de maternelle
qui avait enseigné à son fils il y a 15
ans vous le voyez
ACC vraiment frais c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire avant de tenter à nouveau
d'éteindre cette polémique lors des
questions au gouvernement à l'Assemblée
cet après-midi dans mes propos de
vendredi je me suis appuyée sur le
souvenir et le ressenti d'une expérience
d'il y a 15 ans où notre famille oui a
buté sur des problèmes d'organisation
comme nous avons pu nous en souvenir
avec l'enseignante de l'époque avec qui
j'ai échangé alors maintenant avançons
j'ai de j'ai j'ai de l'ambition pour
l'école je veux soutenir toute la
communauté éducative pour remettre
l'ascenseur sociale en marche voilà
c'était donc cet après-midi il est
évident que le Président de la
République n'échappera pas à la question
oua ctera Émilie zapalski ça s'appelle
une communication de crise est-ce que
c'est le lieu la salle des fêtes de
l'Élysée pour trancher sur un éventuel
départ ah je pense pas que ça sera de
cette façon qui pourrait trancher de
l'avenir de cette ministre mais en tout
cas évidemment il va être questionné
parce que ça ça n'a fait que continuer
et je pense que ça va continuer encore
longtemps parce qu'on est passé sur le
sujet de fond c'est-à-dire ces critiques
vis-à-vis deenseignement public donc
c'est comp avec une perspective 1er
février gr annon oui c'est c'est
compliqué puis là c'est catastrophique
quand même les images qu'on a vu ce
matin à l'école d'itrée et là qu'on voit
à l'Assemblée c'est catastrophique
d'entendre retourner dans le chaudron
justement non je pense que c'était une
erreur de communication dans les
décisions la communication de crise
après on choisit des scénarios et on s'y
tient mais je pense qu'il fallait passer
à autre chose et c'est terrible parce
qu'elle le dit elle-même il faut avancer
je veux avancer et elle y arrive pas
parce qu'elle est embourbée dans cette
histoire elle aurait dû essayer de s'en
tenir à sa situation personnelle encore
une fois les Français les Françaises ils
sont d'accord pour respecter les choix
qu'on fait école publique école privée
ça peut se questionner mais en tout cas
il le questionne pas trop donc elle
aurait pu s'en tenir là et ne pas
commencer à envisager cette thématique
c'est d'autant plus catastrophique parce
que on sait que c'est un domaine réservé
du président que Gabriel elle a dit
j'emmène avec moi l'éducation nationale
donc en gros ils veulent mettre l'accent
là-dessus et ça commence par là ça casse
un peu toute cette séquence qui était
plutôt réussie de la nomination de
Gabriel Atal de ses déplacements et là
tout d'un coup ça fait un peu flop
martial fou est-ce que ça remet pas
aussi d'une certaine façon en question
ce cette logique d'un gouvernement
resserré avec des super ministères c'est
un ministre qui s'occupe de tant de
thématiques
différentes jeunesse l'éducation
nationale mais vous savez dans dans
l'histoire des périmètres des
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a un
ministre de l'éducation de la jeunesse
et des sports ça même été très fréquent
a aussi la santé le trava là rajoute les
Jeux olympiques mais je crois que c'est
pas ça l'élément qui a pu mettre en
difficulté la ministre
a c'est c'est au fond et je ne suis pas
un spécialiste de communication
politique mais au fond le sujet du choix
des parents de choisir un établissement
public privé il est tout à fait libre et
je crois que c'est pas pas ça qui est
remis en cause alors oui un certain
nombre de d'organisations syndicales ont
pu profiter de la situation pour mettre
en difficulté une m de l'éducation
nationale qui à titre personnel a fait
un autre choix mais c'est pas ça qui est
reproet il me semble que là aujourd'hui
pour cette ministre c'est le fait à la
fois de ne pas paraître légitime pour un
certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales et d'avoir comme vous le
disiez ce périmètre très très large
est-ce que la situation aurait été
différente avec simplement un ministre
de l'éducation nationale et une
secrétaire d'État au sport la jeunesse
et aux Jeux Olympiques avec pour un seul
je dire un seul périmètre d'éducation
nationale des enfants dans le secteur
privé on aurait eu la même bien sû il a
la question du mensonge qui se pose
aussi je signale juste qu'on voit les
images de la conférence de la salle des
fêtes de l'Élysée ça se prépare les
journalistes ont pris leur place Tam
nous l'a expliqué tout à l'heure il faut
parfois un peu batailler pour être bien
pour être bien placé et si le timing est
répliqué et respecter pardon on voit
katal en train de s'installer le
président de la République va prendre la
parole dans dans dans quelques secondes
ou
minutes c'est évidemment je suis assez
d'accord avecid pas qui pas le lieu pour
trancher une telle décision mais
pourront-ils et là je le mets au au au
pluriel Emmanuel Macron et Gabriel hatal
faire l'économie de d'une décision
peut-être lourde concernant ce ministère
et concernant Amélie oua cterin
écoutez cette question des enfants dans
le secteur privé est posé maintenant de
manière rituelle à quelques ministres
que ce soit même monsieur papendiaille
vous lui avez dit mais vous pourquoi
vous avez vos enfants à l'École
alsacienne et cetera voilà et maintenant
on est obligé de s'excuser presque au
regard d'une certaine
doxacus vous qui êtes enseignant Pascal
Perino vous représentez on a deux
enseignants sur ce plateau vous diriez
c'est une maladresse ou c'est une faute
non non c'est une maladresse c'est
absolument pas une faute c'est une une
maladresse de sa part et dans
l'argumentation telle qu'elle l'a
présenté c'est une maladresse fait TR n
journalistes c'est des événements qui se
sont passé il y a 15 ans si je peux me
permettre je crois qu'on en fait un peu
trop je crois qu'on en fait un peu trop
sur quelque chose qui est qui est
relativement marginal selon moi et
d'autre part il y a tout même une
conception derrière tout ça qui consiste
à dire que seul ferait partie de l'école
de la République
l'école publique non l'école publique et
l'école privée sous contrat fait partie
de l'école de la République
réagir sur la salle la question de de de
qui paye qui peut se permettre ça c'est
une autre question je le mettrai à côté
parce qu'il y a quand même ça donc on
peut se dire bah oui mais c'est c'est
c'est des gens privilégiés qui peuvent
se permettre de choisir si ça se passe
pas bien mais il y a autre chose ce
qu'elle a dit elle a fortement critiqué
elle a dit je les mets dans dans le
privé comme ça ils sont tranquilles ils
sont en sécurité ils sont ils ont pas de
prof absent donc en gros tout ce que ne
ser prépare l'École publique et c'est là
où il y a des professeurs et notamment
cette école d'itrée qui s'est senti
quand même mise en cause en disant
pourquoi ma ministre de l'éducation qui
vient de débarquer est si dur alors que
elle elle et alors que globalement c'est
un un pouvoir qui est en place depuis 7
ans donc s'il sont pas rendu compte
qu'il y avait en effet ces
problématiques d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant de pénurie et d'absence
c'est un peu vous le voyez sur ces
images Emmanuel Macron va faire son
entrée dans la salle des fêtes
de l'Élysée on va suivre ça évidemment
en direct à noter que l'ensemble du
gouvernement est présent le nouveau
Premier ministre bien sûr Gabriel hatal
ça raconte aussi ces images une forme
d'exercice du pouvoir le chef de l'État
va donc prendre la parole une vingtaine
de minutes de propos liminire je vous
laisse suivre en direct son allocution
suivi des questions des journalistes
permettez-moi avant toute chose de vous
souhaiter à nouveau une belle et
heureuse année et de la souhaiter à
nouveau à nos compatriotes qui nous
suivent ce
soir je ne reviendrai pas dans mon
propos introductif sur ce que j'ai pu
évoquer des fiertés des grands événement
de l'année qui s'ouvre pour donc 2024
que j'ai déjà détaillé le 31 décembre
dernier ni sur les grands sujets de
politique international ou les sujets
les plus institutionnels nous pourrons y
revenir dans le cadre des questions qui
seront les vôtres mais après 6 ans et
demi d'action au service des
Français j'ai tenu à vous retrouver en
ce moment décisif pour dire au pays d'où
nous venons et où nous
allons alors d'où nous venons parce que
les dernières années nous avons
évidemment subi des crises pandémie
retour de la guerre j' reviendrai et
cetera mais nous avons collectivement
cherché à suivre une ligne claire
libérer les énergies protéger les
Français unir la
nation et nous pouvons compter sur des
forces se retrouver
force économique et sociale nous avons
créé plus de 2 millions d'emplois ouvert
plus de 300 usines réussi un chemin à la
fois de création d'activité et de
décarbonation de notre
économie force républicaines aussi de
l'état retrouvé de ceux qui les servent
nous avons massivement réinvesti dans
nos armées pour nos policiers nos
gendarmes pour notre justice mais aussi
pour notre école et notre santé pour ne
citer que quelques exemples ce qui fait
qu'au moment où je vous parle oui nous
sommes mieux arm qu'il y a 6 ans et
demi mais où allons-nous et nous le
vivons
tous au fond le monde d'hier est en
train de
s'effacer l'ordre international que nous
connaissions est
bousculé la guerre revient sur le sol
européen avec l'agression russe en
Ukraine il y a près de 2 ans maintenant
la guerre revient au proche- Orient avec
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas le 7
octobre dernier qui a plongé toute la
région dans la la guerre nous vivons
nous le savons aussi la crise du modèle
démocratique en France en Europe et dans
beaucoup d'autres pays la crise
climatique provoque des inquiétudes et
pousse à des transitions qui divisent
parfois nos pays mais on le voit partout
là aussi en Europe et l'irruption de
nouvelles technologies bouleverse
beaucoup de nos
repères pourtant au moment où notre pays
est à la fois menacé par les tensions du
monde et ces divisions de l'intérieur
que nous avons encore vécu ces der der
mois et sur lesqueles nous reviendrons
peut-être je suis convaincu que nous
avons tous les atouts pour
réussir convaincu que nous n'en avons
pas fini avec notre histoire de progrès
et que nos enfants vivront mieux demain
que nous ne vivons aujourd'hui et c'est
pour faire face à ces défis et à ce
moment très précis du mandat que m'ont
confié les Français que j'ai voulu
nommer un nouveau
gouvernement pourquoi ce gouvernement le
plus resserré et le plus jeune de
l'histoire de la 5e
République parce que cette époque de
crise que je décris rapidement suppose
avant tout audace action et
efficacité dans les mois dans les années
à venir se décidera le destin des
prochaines générations c'est tout
l'enjeu c'est tout notre
défi voilà pourquoi nous sommes là voilà
pourquoi démocrates écologistes
républicains se rassemble autour d'un
même projet pour agir au service des
Français et au fond avec une ligne
simple pour que la France reste la
France pour que la France demeure cette
nation du bon sens de résistance et des
lumières le Premier ministre aura
détaillé les jours qui viennent après un
travail avec les ministres de son
gouvernement force politique et tout
particulièrement sa majorité au
Parlement et et et les groupes aussi au
Sénat le calendrier de l'action qui est
la sienne et l'exposera lors de sa
déclaration de politique générale je
veux ici essayer de de dire le sens
profond de cette action rendre au fond
la France plus forte et plus juste c'est
ça le combat des prochaines années et
au-delà dans lequel nous devons conduire
la France pour les décennies qui
viennent la France sera plus forte dans
ce monde de bouleversement si nous
sommes d'abord plus unis
si nous réapprenons à partager des
valeurs une culture commune le sens du
respect dans les salles de classe dans
la rue dans les transport comme dans les
commerces c'est pourquoi comme je l'ai
indiqué le 31 décembre dernier lors de
mes vœux nous engagerons un réarmement
civique chaque génération de
français doit apprendre ce que la
République veut
dire une histoire des devoirs des droits
une langue un imaginaire le sens profond
du respect et de l'engagement et cela
dès
l'enfance en renforçant le soutien et
l'exigence vis-à-vis des parents en
reprenant aussi le contrôle de nos
écrans qui trop souvent enferment là où
il devrait libérer sur la base de
recommandations que font les experts que
j'ai réunis la semaine dernière nous
déterminerons le bon usage des écrans
pour nos enfants dans les familles à la
maison comme en classe parce qu'il en va
de l'avenir de sociétés et de nos
démocraties à l'école ensuite depuis
2017 nous avons entamé un choc des
savoirs le retour des fondamentaux
l'enseignement le dédoublement des
classes et nous allons le poursuivre
avec des maîtres mieux formés mieux
payer une rénovation des programmes des
évaluations en chaque niveau dès la
rentrée
2024 l'instruction civique sera refondée
son volume horaire sera doublé une heure
par semaine dès la 5e avec en appui les
grands textes fondateurs de la
nation mais l'école dans laquelle la
confiance aussi se déploie où on forge
pleinement et on exprime les talents de
chacun doit donner une place à la
culture et au
sport c'est pourquoi nous avons instauré
la demi-heure de sport quotidienne en
primaire et 2 heures supplémentaires par
semaine au
collège au-delà de cela l'éducation
artistique et culturelle que nous avons
déployé dans nos écoles depuis
maintenant un peu plus de 6 ans va se
renforcer comme pour la musique et les
arts plastiques je souhaite que le
théâtre devienne un passage obligé au
collège dès la rentrée
prochaine parce que cela donne confiance
cela apprend l'oralité le contact au
grand texte et parce que la France est
aussi une histoire un patrimoine qui se
transmet et qui unit l'histoire de l'art
retrouvera sa place à la rentrée
prochaine au au collège et au
lycée la tenue unique qui a donné lieu à
tant de débats ces derniers mois dans
notre
pays et qui efface les inégalités entre
les familles en même temps qu'elle crée
les conditions du respect sera
expérimenté dès cette année dans une
centaine
d'établissements tous
volontaires cette expérimentation sera
évaluée méthodiquement et sur la base
des résultats s'ils sont concluants nous
la généraliserons
6 nous instituerons dans chaque collège
et dans chaque lycée dès la fin de cette
année une cérémonie de remise des
diplômes rit républicain d'unité de
fierté et de
reconnaissance la famille et l'école au
fond pour faire des républicains en même
temps que pour transmettre des
savoirs mais avoir une France plus forte
c'est aussi assurer l'ordre l'ordre en
contrôlant mieux nos frontières
grâce au textes que nous avons pu voter
en France comme ceux que nous avons voté
au niveau européen et la poursuite aussi
de ce que nous avons renforcé ces
dernières années l'ordre en luttant
contre les incivilités grâce à un
doublement de la de la présence
policière dans nos rues c'est le cœur de
la stratégie annoncée il y a quelques
années à roubé par les emplois créés et
les réformes conduites l'ordre en
luttant contre la drogue qui ces
dernières années se déploie pas
simplement dans les grandes villes mais
dans des villes moyennes qui la
connaissait moins parfois même dans des
villages grâce à la multiplication des
opérations place netes frappant les
narcotrafiquant qui se conduiront en
toutes les catégories de ville et nous
allons accroître le rythme à partir de
la semaine prochaine 10 opérations de ce
type seront conduites chaque
semaine l'ordre en luttant aussi contre
l'islam radical en appliquant
méthodiquement la loi que nous avons
voté il y a maintenant un peu plus de 2
ans qui nous a permis de fermer des
associations des établissements qui ne
respectaient pas les règles de la
République qui nous a permettre de nous
a permis aussi de mettre fin depuis le
1er janvier au système des imames
détachés nous tiendrons cette ligne de
fermetare
républicaine la France sera plus forte
aussi si elle produit
davantage la pandémie a montré que pour
nombre de biens essentiels les
médicaments par exemple nous dépendions
trop souvent de l'étranger et les
solutions technologiques de demain
particulier pour la croissance verte ou
le numérique risque d'être produite dans
d'autres continents que le nôtre c'est
pourquoi nous devons accélérer dans le
réarmement académique scientifique
technologique industriel et agricole
déjà largement engagé grâce aux réformes
condu depuis 6 ans grâce au plan de
relance puis au programme France 2030 là
encore c'est un choix
d'indépendance ne plus compter sur les
autres puissances pour écrire notre
histoire produire l'intelligence dans
nos universités notre énergie dans nos
centrales nucléaires et nos
installations de renouvelables notre
alimentation dans nos fermes nos biens
de consommation décarbonés dans nos
usines en français et en européen et
c'est
possible nous avons déjà beaucoup fait
et nous ferons beaucoup plus d'abord
nous poursuivrons les investissements
commencés les réformes
engagées mais je souhaite que nous
puissions accélérer car le monde est en
train d'accélérer regardez la Chine ou
les États-Unis d'Amérique sur ces
technologies ils vont beaucoup plus vite
que nous européens et français pour cela
nous mettrons fin aux normes inutiles il
y a encore trop de complexité qui
décourage les entrepreneurs les
industriels les commerçants les
agriculteurs les artisans les maires
ceux qui font ces complexités bien
souvent protège des rentes des statuts
des situations établies et nous ne
pouvons plus nous le
permettre c'est pourquoi je demande au
gouvernement de supprimer des normes
réduire des délais faciliter encore les
embauches augmenter tous les seuils de
déclenchement
d'obligations c'est au fond la France du
bon sens plutôt que la France des
tracas vieille anciennes diront certains
je crois effectivement qu'en la matière
nous avons eu trop de tabou je pourquoi
je demande au gouvernement de porter un
acte 2 d'une loi pour la croissance
l'activité les opportunités économiques
pour permettre de libérer davantage
encore ceux qui font qui innovent qui
osent qui
travaillent produire plus innover
davantage aller plus vite ceci et cette
indépendance par le travail et la
production nous pourrons le faire aussi
parce que plus de Français travailleront
c'est le sens d'ailleurs de beaucoup de
réformes conduites l'année dernière même
quand elles étaient
impopulaires mais nous le savons tous
notre pays encore aujourd'hui manque de
travailleurs dans les fermes dans nos
restaurants chez nos artisans pour aider
les personnes âgées ou les personnes
handicapées chez eux c'est une
réalité et il risque de manquer demain
de travailleurs dans les métiers que
nous sommes en train de CL créer du
nucléaire jusqu'au numérique et à
beaucoup
d'autres pour mettre fin à cette
anomalie nous devons former davantage
selon les besoins de la nation nous
avons commencé ce travail avec la
réforme du lycée professionnel de de nos
universités cet effort nous l'accélérons
cette année et jusqu'à la rentrée
prochaine le gouvernement incitera aussi
à la création et la reprise d'un emploi
avec dès le printemps prochain un acte 2
de la réforme du marché du travail lancé
en 2017 c'est-à-dire des règles plus
sévères quand des offres d'emploi sont
refusées et un meilleur accompagnement
de nos chômeurs par la formation mais
aussi l'accompagnement à l'emploi sur
des choses très concrètes comme le
logement ou les transports ceci pour
atteindre le plein
emploi la France sera plus forte si elle
retrouve son indépendance financière
nous avons beaucoup dépensé pendant la
crise covid nous le savons tous et
j'assume ces dépenses parce qu'elles ont
surtout protégé nos capacités de
production et une reprise très rapide et
les chiffres sont là pour le montrer
mais retrouver notre indépendance
financière c'est d'abord et avant tout
créer plus de
richesse donner un chiffre très simple
si la France avait le taux d'activité le
taux d'emploi de l'Allemagne nous
n'aurions pas de problème de finances
publiqu et donc le cœur de la bataille
budgétaire c'est une bataille pour
l'activité et la création d'emploi et de
richesse et à côté de ça le gouvernement
aura aussi à bâtir une ambitieuse revue
des dépenses pendant ce semestre une
vraie réforme de l'État pour dégager
aussi de l'efficacité dans nos dépenses
publiques la France sera plus forte car
elle dépendra dépendra encore moins de
l'étranger pour son énergie grâce à
davantage de nucléaire et d'énergie
renouvelable le programme que nous
allons accélérer j'y reviendrai au mois
de juin et sera armé face aux aléas du
changement climatique nos compatriotes à
la Réunion dans le pas decalé mais il y
a quelques mois en Bretagne ou en
Normandie l'ont encore vécu on sait bien
que nous devons réduire nos fragilités
face aux tempêtes aux incendies aussi
aux canicules et aux sécheresses et ceci
avec un plan d'adaptation et de
résilience sur nos territoire bâti avec
nos mères nos élus locaux en métropole
comme dans nos oututres mes notre France
sera aussi plus forte par la relance de
sa
natalité nous étions jusqu'à récemment
un pays dont c'était la force sans doute
la singularité en Europe quand on se
comparait aux voisins et c'est moins
vrai depuis quelques années alors il y a
derrière cela des angoisses qui vont
avec la société peut-être des choix prix
Jadice sur certains sujets financiers il
appartiendra au gouvernement euh de
poursuivre ce travail mais je voudrais
insister sur deux points pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses après
l'allongement du congé paternité je
crois profondément que la mise en place
d'un nouveau congé de
naissance sera un élément utile dans une
une telle stratégie congé de naissance
qui viendra remplacer le congé parental
actuel d'abord il sera mieux rémunéré il
permettra aux deux parents d'être auprès
de leur enfant pendant 6 mois s'il le
souhaitent mais surtout il sera plus
court que le congé parental actuel qui
peut parfois aller jusqu'à 3 ans et qui
éloigne beaucoup de femmes du marché du
travail mais qui aussi crée beaucoup
d'angoisse parce qu'il est extrêmement
peu et mal rémunéré et donc créer des
situations parfois
impossibles la natalité baisse aussi
parce que l'infertilité
progresse et je parle là d'une forme de
tabou du siècle mais les Meur se
changent on fait des enfants de plus en
plus tard
l'infertilité masculine comme féminine a
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
et fait souffrir beaucoup de couples un
grand plan de lutte contre ce fléo sera
engagé pour permettre justement ce
réarmement démographique enfin la France
sera plus forte parce que l'Europe sera
plus puissante je n'ai jamais opposé ces
deux notions je les défends même comme
des
complémentarité nous avons beaucoup fait
ces dernières années pour une Europe de
la santé une Europe de la défense une
Europe des technologies et des grands
programmes avec des vrais résultats et
on pourra y revenir si vous le souhaitez
nous devons encore aller plus loin sur
ce sujet Les élections européennes
seront un rendez-vous et un moment de
vérité mais je crois profondément que
dans ce dérèglement que j'aiévoqué une
Europe plus puissante plus unie plus
souveraine est un élément de réponse
indispensable pour notre
pays la France sera plus
forte grâce à ses objectifs et
quelquesunes des actions que je viens
ici d'esquisser et c'est grâce à cela
qu'elle pourra aussi être plus
juste la première des injustices je l'ai
plusieurs reprises évoqué c'est et cela
reste malheureusement celle du
déterminisme social et
familial nous n'avons pas les mêmes
chances et je dois reconnaître avec
honnêteté qu'après 6 ans et demi à
l'endroit où les Français m'ont mis nous
avons amélioré des choses mais nous ne
les avons pas radicalement changé
c'est-à-dire que l'avenir des enfants de
la République reste encore par trop
déterminé par le nom de famille
l'endroit où l'on est né le milieu
auquel on appartient c'est la pire des
injustices l'inégalité de départ la
promesse républicaine c'est celle de
l'égalité des chances et au fond je veux
qu'on mette fin à cette France du ceci
n'est pas pour moi ou ceci n'est pas
pour toi de ces enfants qui continuent à
se dire que parce qu'ils viennent deel
de ce quartier qu'ils ont ce nom l'accès
à telle formation ou tel diplôme l'accès
à la culture ne leur est pas dû n'est
pas un droit pour eux ça existe c'est
une réalité et aussi longtemps que ça
existe ça vient éroder l'adhésion à la
promesse républicaine et tout ce que je
viens de vous dire sur l'ordre ne sera
pas possible tout ce que je viens de
vous dire sur la force sera aussi
affaibli euh vous retrouverez une forme
d'en même temps qui est familier mais
qui n'est pas une faiblesse qui est une
double radicalité qui n'est pas une
ambiguïté qui est une double ambition
car et c'est vrai depuis le début de
notre 3e république l'ordre va avec le
progrès l'autorité va avec
l'émancipation indissociable et donc oui
la réponse à ça c'est l'école l'école
l'école là aussi continuer le travail
commencé avec encore plus de
force au près des enfants les plus en
difficulté systématiser les devoir fait
au collège en particulier dans les
endroits les plus en difficulté c'est
indispensable travailler sur les
vacances et le temps scolaire Premier
ministre nager ministre de l'éducation
nationale avait commencé ce travail pour
décaler les examens parce que les
longues sont un élément d'injustice
sociale et commencer aussi dès la 5e
l'accompagnement à
l'orientation qui est un élément
absolument décisif d'une plus grande
égalité et c'est tout ce que nous allons
conduire au collège au lycée et au
premier cycle universitaire avec les
ministres qui sont maintenant en charge
de ces sujets c'est aussi ce travail que
je veux continuer par un meilleur accès
à la culture et qui sera au cœur du
mandat de la ministre faire en sorte que
d'où qu'on viennent des quartiers popul
urbain à notre ruralité on puisse avoir
accès à la
culture dès l'école et
après la deuxème injustice
fondamentale c'est que l'effort et le
mérite ne sont pas suffisamment reconnu
je crois dans cette France en effet du
travail et du mérite et si nous avons
déjà beaucoup fait pour que le travail P
mieux que l'inactivité on pourra y
revenir on a substantiellement fait et
nous sommes sans doute le pays d'Europe
où le pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
et les travailleurs les plus modestes à
le plus progressé ces 5 dernières années
malgré l'inflation ça n'est pas assez et
au fond il y a ce que j'appellerai une
France de l'angl mort c'est tous nos
compatriotes qui gagnent déjà trop pour
être aidé et pas assez pour bien vivre
c'est la France populaire la France des
classes moyennes la France qui dit quand
vous proposez quelque chose c'est jamais
pour
moi et pourtant c'est celle qui tient le
pays et donc au cœur du mandat du
gouvernement je souhaite qu'il y ait
justement un travail
ardent pour aller plus
loin pour reconnaître cela pour donner
plus de dynamique aux carrières pour
permettre de mieux gagner sa vie par le
travail avec l'adaptation de nos
dispositifs fiscaux et sociaux mais
aussi avec des négociations dans
certaines branches pour que la dynamique
salariale soit au rendez-vous des
efforts il en va de même pour nos
fonctionnaires pour lesquels le
principal critère d'avancement et de
rémunération elle devra être à côté de
l'ancienneté également le mérite tout
cas bien davantage qu'aujourd'hui ce
sera au cœur d'une réforme qui va
commencer dans les prochaines semaines
une France plus juste c'est aussi une
France qui sait accompagné les
transitions qui sont à l'œuvre je le
disais beaucoup des changements qui sont
en cours et on le voit partout en Europe
nourrissent de l'inquiétude parce que si
nous ny prenons pas garde et la France
l'a vécu avec la crise que nous avons
traversé ensemble des gilets jaunes ces
transitions sont injustes elles frappent
encore
plus ceux qui sont dans la difficulté
ceux qui ont déjà à peine les moyens de
vivre de leur travail qui sont souvent
dans les logements les moins bien isolés
qui par nécessité sont obligés de rouler
dans des véhicules individuels qui sont
parfois encore les plus polluants sagit
pas de stigmatiser C France au contraire
il faut l'aider à la transition c'est ça
l'écologie à la française c'est une
écologie de justice et de souveraineté
et donc nous allons accroître dans les
prochains moi d'abord l'accompagnement
de nos agriculteurs pour les aider
justement à améliorer leurs pratique
jamais en les laissant sans solution
simplification accompagnement et
investissement
accompagner les Français en investissant
dans les transports en commun en les
aidant par le bonus écologique mais
aussi le leasing social pour la voiture
à 100 € à changer de véhicule et à les
accompagner encore davantage et de
manière plus simple pour rénover leur
logement faire de la transition
écologique une transition juste la
France plus juste enfin c'est celle qui
accompagne chacun grâce à nos services
publics en la matière beaucoup de
Français ont le sentiment légitime de ne
pas en avoir pour leur argent si je pu
dire pas de médecin disponible lorsquils
sont malades pas d'agents au bout du fil
quand ils font une démarche des délet
trop longs dans les papiers d'identité
et parfois même le sentiment que ça
fonctionne surtout pour ceux qui ont des
passe
droit lors de mon premier quena nous
avons beaucoup fait sur ce sujet on a
réinvesti on a déconcentré beaucoup de
services publics on a recréé des
sous-préfectures c'était pas arrivé
depuis des décennies on a rouvert des
trésoreries sur le terrain on a rouvert
des brigades de gendarmerie on vient
encore d'enclencher un mouvement pour en
ouvrir
200 j'avais fait une promesse ici même à
la fin du grand débat que dans chaque
canton il y ait une maison France
service promesse tenue même dépassé 2700
maisons Fran service existe aujourd'hui
partout sur le terrain ce qui place
chacun d'entre nous à 20 minutes de
l'une d'entre elles qu'on habite un
quartier populaire en
ruralité dans les grandes villes mais
soyons lucid nous n'y sommes pas encore
parce qu'on est encore prisonnier sans
doute de trop de tabou de prê à penser
je demande donc au gouvernement de
sortir si je puis dire des codes et des
cases d'envisager des solutions plus
radicales pour mettre fin à ce qui
alimente ce sentiment de déclassement
solution radicale pour mettre fin au SC
des déserts médicaux en simplifiant les
règles venues d'en haut en permettant
d'adapter ces règles au terrain pour
permettre des coordinations plus simples
en dégageant du temps au médecin pour
mieux travailler entre médecine de ville
et hôpital avec aussi ce qu'on appelle
les professions paramédicales sera au
cœur du mandat de la ministre afin que
chaque médecin mais aussi paramédicau
puisse voir plus de patients mais aussi
en assumant sur le terrain de
régulariser
nombre de médecins étrangers qui
tiennent parfois à bout de bras nos
services de soins et que nous laissons
dans une précarité administrative qui
est complètement
inefficace solution radicale en taillant
enfin dans le vif des dépenses inutiles
des doublons administratifs du
millefeuille comme on l'appelle pour
permettre un service plus efficace
auprès des Français et des règles
beaucoup plus simples et rapides par les
simplifications que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure au fond nous devons avoir la
force l'énergie dans ce moment
d'envisager ce que nous n'envisagions
plusser ce que nous n'osions même plus
pensé de retrouver de
l'audace vous l'avez compris il s'agit
de faire preuve d'efficacité de briser
même certains tabou de ne pas avoir peur
de soulever certains mécontentements au
service des
Français c'est bien sûr au gouvernement
d'insuffler ce mouvement et je sais
qu'il ne ménagera ni son énergie ni son
talent mais chacun doit prendre sa
part l'état bien sûr doit être là pour
accompagner pour impulser jamais pour
entraver mais la force de mouvement
réside aussi en chacun de nous nous
avons besoin d'une France de
l'engagement et de la mobilisation
civile parce qu'être français c'est
d'avoir c'est avant tout avoir des
droits et des devoirs c'est porter une
certaine idée de notre nation de son
histoire de son ambition c'est pourquoi
je compte
aussi sur l'engagement et la
mobilisation de nos compatriotes en
hexagone et dans nos outres mers pour
prendre leur part de cette mobilisation
afin de rendre notre pays plus fort et
plus juste et de relever les défis du
temps vous l'avez compris je pense que
beaucoup de choses sont possibles et je
ne cède pas à l'esprit de
résignation que je vois quand même à
l'œuvre il y a beaucoup de choses qui
nous inquiètent légitimement parce que
beaucoup de changements sont en cours
parce qu'on a vécu tant de
crises mais je crois que si nous savons
travailler ardemment avec beaucoup de
bon sens d'efficacité sans doute moins
de lois mais plus d'actions concrètes
avec une détermination sans
faille nous aurons des résultats au
service à la fois du quotidien des
Français mais aussi pour préparer
l'avenir de la nation et cette France
plus forte et plus juste de l'audace de
l'efficacité de l'action c'est ce qui
est demandé à ce nouveau gouvernement ce
à quoi je m'emploirai maintenant je vais
répondre à toutes vos
questions bonsoir monsieur le Président
euh Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues euh Jean-Rémy baudau au nom de
de l'association La Presse
présidentielle on voulait juste rappeler
quelques petits points pour les
personnes qui nous regardent ou nous
écoutent rappelez que les journalistes
c'est une conférence de presse les
journalistes sont libres de poser toutes
les questions qu'ils souhaitent au chefs
de l'État aucune question n'est jamais
soumise en amont au chef de l'État c'est
toujours mieux de le dire toutefois dans
un souci de lisibilité l'Élisée aimerait
que cette conférence de presse soit
divisée en trois parties d'abord une un
premier chapitre national avec les
réformes les annonces qui viennent
d'être formulé puis une partie axée sur
l'actualité était plus strictement
politique et enfin les questions
internationales vous le voyez tous on
est très nombreux ce soir afin que la
parole puisse circuler auprès d'un
maximum de journalistes l'Association de
la presse présidentielle vous recommande
de vous encourage à ne formuler qu'une
seule question par prise de parole
question courte s'il vous plaît et de la
même manière monsieur le Président nous
savons pouvoir compter sur la concision
de vos
réponses RZ pas quand
même bonsoir monsieur le Président Basti
pour TF1 et LCI vous avez parlé à
l'instant des classes moyennes et
populaires et de leur pouvoir d'achat
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
comment vous comptez vous y prendre
comment vous demandez à votre
gouvernement de s'y prendre pour
augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat est-ce
que vous envisagez par exemple
d'augmenter le SMIC et quand allez-vous
rendre effective votre promesse de
baisser de 2 milliards d'euros les
impôts des Français et puis est-ce que
tout cela aura du sens si vous laissez
les français payent plus cher leur
électricité comme c'est prévu le mois
prochain je vous remercie
c'est un tout le pouvoir d'achat c'est
au fond la rencontre d'un coout de la
vie et de la rémunération d'un
travail la France a beaucoup protégé
face à l'inflation ces dernières années
l'inflation énergétique nous avons
dépensé 100 milliards d'euros pour
protéger nos compatriotes donc au moment
où les prix reviennent dans la norme il
est légitime qu'il y ait en effet des
augmentations le gouvernement il
reviendra parce que soyons clair quand
l'État protège c'est le contribuable
d'aujourd'hui ou de demain qui paye que
consommateur ne paye pas l'inflation
c'est un impôt de
l'extérieur alors oui il y aura cette
normalisation mais je le disais nous
avons beaucoup protégé maintenant pour
aider les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes d'abord nous allons
tout faire pour justement retrouver la
maîtrise de nos prix Les prix de
l'alimentation vont revenir dans des
zones qui sont beaucoup plus
raisonnables on vient de le voir avec la
fin des négociations commerciales qu'on
avait anticipé il faut qu'il y a un prix
juste pour que nos agriculteurs et nos
PME puissent vivre de leur travail mais
on sera très loin de l'inflation qu'on a
connu l'année dernière même l'année
d'avant et nous allons être vigilants
dans les prochains mois pour tenir des
prix qui permettent à chacun de vivre et
qui aident justement à ce que on
maîtrise véritablement les prix de
l'alimentaire sur l'énergie on rentre
dans une période de normalisation et une
partie des prix de l'énergie servent à
financer notre programme nucléaire et
notre renouvelable mais on a retrouvé de
la maîtrise et le gouvernement aura
apporté un texte qui grâce à ce qu'on a
négocié en Europe va nous permettre de
ne plus avoir la volatilité qu'on avait
connu pendant la crise liée à la guerre
en Ukraine c'est-à-dire qu'on retrouve
une énergie qu'on paye à nos cûts de
production et grâce au nucléaire et à ce
que nous sommes en train de développer
ça veut dire une énergie dont on tient
mieux les coûts et avec beaucoup plus de
visibilité dès cette année le
gouvernement aura à tout faire pour que
le travail paye mieux alors on a là
aussi beaucoup
fait quand je regarde ces 5 dernières
années le SMIC a augmenté de 20 % 20 %
les smicars ont gagné pouvoir d'achat un
travailleur qui est osmque à temps
complet a gagné depuis depuis 2017
9 % de pouvoir d'achat et aucun pays
européen où c'est arrivé parce qu'en
plus de ça on a mis les 100 € de prime
d'activité promesse de sortie du grand
débat parce qu'on a baissé l'impôt sur
le revenu de 5 milliards concentrés sur
les classes moyennes parce qu'on a
supprimé la taxe d'habitation faut
continuer ce travail sur plusieurs axes
d'abord c'est tout un chantier qu'on a
lancé pour que notre fiscalité nos
cotisations sociales permettent de mieux
accompagner d'abord qui reviennent au
travail mais aussi les Français qui sont
au SMIC et un peu au-dessus du SMIC
parce que sinon on a une trappe à bas
salaire dans notre pays c'est ça l'un
des problèmes qu'on a la deuxième chose
pour que branche par branche on ait des
dynamiques salariales par un partage de
la valeur ajoutée de la valeur crée qui
soit beaucoup plus juste et fort là
aussi on a commencé à le faire on a 9
million et demi de nos compatriotes qui
ont touché les fameuses primes et le
partage de la valeur ajoutée on va aller
plus loin et puis dès 2025 ça tout je
vous dis c'est sur 2024 et il y aura des
mesures de court terme que le premier
ministre aura à annoncé donc sur la
rémunération du travail il y aura un
travail avec les branches qui continuent
de payer sous le SMIC pour qu'elle
réembauche davantage et qu'elles
attirent plus de travailleurs qu'elles
améliorent les conditions de travail et
qu'ell permett d'avoir des dynamiques
salariales retrouvé et ça ça vaut pour
les métiers de la restauration les
métiers du soin beaucoup de métiers
d'ailleurs manuels est souvent difficile
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles il
continu à avoir du mal à recrué et on
aura entre autres dans notre trajectoire
financière 2 milliards de baisse
d'impôts sur nos compatriotes qui sont
dans ces catégories en 2025 et le
gouvernement reviendra sur le détail de
la mesure voilà les grands axes de la
stratégie bonsoir monsieur le Président
Guillaume darret pour France Télévision
vous venez de faire de nouvelles
annonces concernant notamment le secteur
de l'école vous évoquez la question de
l'éducation civique très concrètement
est-ce que vous êtes favorable par
exemple à ce que les élèves de primaire
apprennent obligatoirement la
Marseillaise comme chose pour seunir
avec la nation est-ce que la
généralisation de l'uniforme c'est
vraiment la priorité est-ce que la
priorité c'est pas plutôt qu'il y ait un
enseignant en face de chaque élève ce à
quoi vous vous étiez engagé
personnellement il y a quelques mois on
l'a vu c'est pas encore le cas partout
et on l'a vu aussi ces derniers jours ça
continue de faire débats et polémique au
sein même de votre gouvernement on
reviendra sans doute dans le moment plus
politique sur ce sujet je l'imagine mais
il y a pas de polémique dans le
gouvernement sur le fait qu'il doit
avoir un enseignant devant chaque élève
je vous rassure tout se tient tout se
tient c'est-à-dire que on a un énorme
travail à faire avec les
familles j'ai commencé par là mais on a
en effet à l'école et c'est ce qu'on a
commencé depuis
2017 aller au bout de ce choc des
savoirs l'école primaire avec laquelle
vous avez commencé c'est là où on
apprend à compter à écrire à lire aussi
à se comporter c'est là où on apprend
des valeurs je suis totalement favorable
à ce qu'on apprenne la Marseillaise au
primaire totalement c'est même
indispensable parce que c'est ce qui
nous unit c'est le fruit de notre
histoire à ce qu'ilit donc l'heure
sanctuarisée si je puis dire de dès la
5e d'instruction civique avec un
programme qui redéfinit et qui permet de
bien mieux connaître à la fois
l'histoire de notre nation notre
république de nos institutions et nos
grands textes parce que c'est ce qui
nous unit c'est ce qui nous permet
d'être ensemble en société ce qui fait
que je l'avais dit je me souviens très
bien à la fin du grand débat c'est ce
qui sépare c'est ce qui différencie
plutôt une nation d'une société une
société sont des individus libres qui
coopèrent qui s'organisent et cetera
nous sommes une société mais on est plus
que ça on a un supplément d'âme on a une
langue une histoire des choses
intemporelles qui nous lient et un
mystérieux projet commun qui fait que
face à l'adversité on se rassemble pour
affronter les événements c'est ça une
nation c'est a quelque chose de
spirituel qui nous dépasse et ça
s'apprend à travers cette histoire et
ces choses aussi symboliques il faut
retrouver aussi le sens du symbol que et
c'est pour ça que la Marseillaise en
fait partie j'y suis favorable la tenue
unique ça n'est pas innocent pas
innocent et d'abord parce que ça a été
un débat de société pendant des semaines
tout le monde en a parlé des semaines
que dis-je des mois je peux pas vous
dire ça sert à rien non et moi j'aime
bien la méthode que le gouvernement a
décidé d'employer qui est pragmatique ça
fait débat n'ayons pas des débats si je
peux dire
théorique n renvoyons pas dogme contre
dogme certitud contre certitude on
expérimente on évalue on est transparent
et on regarde c'est un débat il y a 100
établissements qui sont candidats on
leur permet dès cette année certains je
crois vont le faire dès la sortie des
vacances là d'hiver ils le mettent en
place tenue unique ou uniforme pour
l'expérimentation on va même accompagner
les familles ce sera pris en charge par
les collectivités locales et l'État et
on va mettre les meilleurs experts ils
vont évaluer qu'est-ce que ça fait
est-ce qu'on apprend mieux est-ce que ça
change rien est-ce que ça crée des
tensions est-ce que le débat public sera
ainsi éclairé c'est ça une démocratie
adulte et à l'ône de ce qui aura été
évalué on dira ça marche ça marche pas
ça sert à rien et on décidera de le
généraliser ou pas je crois que c'est la
bonne manière d'avancer enfin oui j'ai
dit dès le début le choc des savoirs
c'est avoir des maîtres mieux
formés c'est pourquoi on va complètement
revoir tout cela moi je crois un système
en lien avec notre université mais où on
a au fond des compatriotes qui veulent
enseigner qui dès après le baccalauréat
puissent être formé au métier
d'enseignant je v pas dire tout de suite
qu'on va revenir au vieux système de nos
écoles normal c'était pas si mauvais en
tout là aujourd'hui au fond on demande
des chemins universitaires qui sont
parfois très divers mais on ne forme pas
au métier d'enseigner tout de suite donc
on va repenser la formation et dès ce
trimestre on aura des annonces fortes
avec refonde complète du système de
formation des maîtres on les rémunère
mieux avec le PACT enseignant et c'est
des il y a une une part de la la
rémunération qui a augmenté pour tout le
monde qui est inconditionnelle et qui
est historique on l'avait pas vu depuis
les années 90 et une part qui est liée à
l'adhésion au pacte pour pouvoir faire
des tâches supplémentaires accompagner
les devoirs faits qui permettent de
lutter contre les injustices permettent
de mieux accompagner justement dans
l'orientation et permettre entre autres
d'adhérer au remplacement remplacement
dans notre code je le rappelle c'est
censé être une
obligation durant mon premier quinena on
s'est attaqué au remplacement long j'ai
vous le dire parce que moi j'ai creusé
le sujet depuis 6 ans et demi
on avait nos fameux objets de la vie
quotidienne à des conseils des ministres
réguliers les ministres qui sont là qui
m'accompagnent de longtemps le savent
ont passait en revue ces objets et on a
des résultats formidables parce que on a
plus de 95
% des absences qui sont comblé telles
qu'elles été mesuré c'est les absences
de plus de 15 jours c'est tout ce qu'on
a suivi durant le premier quinena on est
à 95 % je crois en 2022 2023 c'est le
taux de remplacement on a même atteint
certaines années d'avant
c'est au-dessus de 15 jours d'absence
c'est ça qu'on mesurait moi j'arrive en
fin de mon premier mandat je dis
formidable on a quand même un bon
résultat il a 95 % des absences qui sont
comblé on arrive à mettre un prof devant
les élèves le ressenti sur le terrain
n'était pas le
même pourquoi parce qu'on ne faisait pas
remonter au National les absences de
court terme on ne les mesurait même pas
donc on a ouvert le capot et on est allé
regarder le remplacement de court terme
et on s'est aperçu qu'il avait dizaines
de millions d'heures chaque année qui
était perdu où vous n'avez pas un
professeur devant un élève et c'est ça
qui est insupportable pour les parents
donc on a on a réussi à répondre au
problèm d'absence longue des des
professeurs et là on est en train de
s'attaquer au aux absences de courte
durée professeur absent parce qu'il
avait une formation on a complètement
repensé le système et donc là on est en
train de s'organiser on a commencé pour
que les formations qu'on les mettre ce
qui est tout à fait légitime se se fasse
pas sur leur temps d'école et le temps
de travail d'un d'un professeur c'est
pas que le temps devant les élèves il a
du temps de préparation du temps de
correction des copies et il travaillent
beaucoup nos enseignants mais on peut
s'organiser pour que les formations
auxquelles ils ont droit et que nous
encourageons se fassent pas sur le temps
devant les élèves deuxème chose on
utilisait si je puis dire on gaspillait
du temps de professeur pour surveiller
les examens on réorganise ça et puis
troisème chose on doit mieux organiser
au sein des établissements le
remplacement de courte durée vous avez
un professeur qui est malade tel jour
qui a une qui peut pas être là bah il
faut encourager les autres enseignants
qui peuvent être disponibles à reprendre
cette heure et à la faire elle sera
payée en heure supplémentaire ou dans le
cadre du Pacte je rentre dans les
détails ça paraît du bon sens mais c'est
pas ce qui été fait donc c'est une
réorganisation complète le PACT permet
de le faire c'est à ça qu'on s'attaque
on n'est pas 100 % de réussite bien loin
on est passé de 5 % à 15 % à peu près
donc vous voyez qu'on est loin du
résultat c'est pour ça qu'on a raison de
s'y attaquer avec beaucoup de force
c'est de la réorganisation
nos professeurs sont nos meilleurs
alliés sur ce sujet-là et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a décidé de mieux les
payer quand ils adhéraient à cela par
les heures supplémentaires et par le
pacte voilà où on en est exactement et
donc je peux vous dire que avec le
Premier ministre la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale de jeunesse et des
sports on va continuer de s'attaquer
avec force à ce sujet du remplacement
pour que tous les élèves et bien un
professeur devant chaque heœur de cours
qui est
prévu monsieur le Président ici bonsoir
bousalo vous avez annoncé une grande loi
sur l'économie est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire de façon plus précise ce qu'il
y aura à l'intérieur et concernant le
pouvoir d'achat est-ce que vous allez
contraint les entreprises à mieux
rémunérer les les salariés ou est-ce que
vous allez vous souhaitez rester plutôt
dans le domaine de l'incitation merci
sur le deuxème point d'abord il y a ce
que nous pouvons faire nous qui est à
notre main on a du fiscal et du social
et ça il peut y avoir des moments de
dialogue mais c'est des les choix qui
sont à la main du gouvernement la
deuxième chose sur les salaires je suis
plutôt pour que ça continue à se faire
au niveau de l' entreprise c'est comme
ça que ça marche mais nous allons
encourager les branches où il y a encore
des difficultés de rémunération à
accélérer les négociation pour qu'elle
puisse se conformer aux dynamiques des
derniers mois et surtout à donner plus
de dynamique au dialogue social au
niveau de l'entreprise et puis on va
continuer d'avancer dans ce qu'on a
beaucoup fait durant le premier mandat
qui est de de faciliter d'encourager de
simplifier le partage de la valeur
ajoutée de la loi pacte au prime qu'on a
mis en place qui ont bénéficié après 100
millions de travailleurs jusqu'à
l'accord national interprofessionnel de
valeur de partage de la valeur ajoutée
qui a été transposée on a énormément
simplifié le paysage là faut encore
encourager de le faire je ne suis pas
pour que on le fasse de manière
réglementaire législative c'est par le
dialogue social s'il y a besoin de
simplifier des instruments on le fera
parce que sinon on on met à risque si je
puis dire notre compétitivité et surtout
on n'est pas dans une économie
réglementée pour ce qui est d'un temps
de de la simplification c'est le premier
ministre qui reviendra dans son discours
de politique générale et c'est au
ministre de construire cela mais on a
beaucoup de choses très simples à faire
très pratique si
l'administration ne redemande n'avait
pas le droit de demander des documents
qu'elle a demandé dans les 12 derniers
mois ou les deux dernières années on
changerait la vie de beaucoup de
gens et pour les entreprises et pour les
particuliers si la situation de ces
derniers n'avait pas changé si on
bougeit les seuils sur beaucoup de
seuils qu'on a réglementair ou légaux
sur beaucoup de sujets en les passant à
une étape supplémentaire on
simplifierait la vie de beaucoup de gens
si on réduisait drastiquement les délais
d'instruction ou autre il y a des tas de
choses très concrètes qu'on peut faire
c'est très compliqué de simplifier j'en
parle d'expérience mais ce que je dis
c'est qu'il faut remettre de l'audace et
de l'énergie dans le système maintenant
et c'est pas impossible de le faire et
j'ai un très bon exemple pour ça c'est
les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques on nous dit ce qui est
vrai on y reviendra peut-être dans vos
questions le logement est en crise c'est
vrai et une des parties des crises du
logement c'est un un aspect conjoncturel
la montée des taux qui fait que le
logement reposait entre autres dans son
économie sur des tau bas pendant très
longtemps ça monte ça fait qu'il y a une
contrainte de crédit beaucoup de gens
n'accèdent plus au logement les
promoteurs sont son pression mais on a
un système qui est un Maqui c'est très
compliqué le foncier est trop cher les
délais sont trop longs tout ça crée du
coût pour nous tous quand on veut
acquérir un logement ou quand on loue
dans un des endroits où c'est le plus
compliqué et le plus long de construire
en France la région parisienne parce
qu'il y a les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques on a pris une loi
d'urgence il y a 5 ans et
demi les logements vont sortir de terre
pour les Jeux Olympiques la loi on l'a
prise fin 2017 début 2018 on a construit
avec plusieurs communes de saine saintis
un énorme programme de bureaux et de
logement il verra le jour à l'heure pour
les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques c'est possible et donc on
va faire aussi des grosses
simplifications des grosses opération
d'intérêt national on va réduire les
choses simplement faut réduire les
délais faut contraindre les procédures
faut éviter les recours multiples et à
tous les étages qui ont toujours été
fait pour des bonnes raisons qui sont
sédimenté avec le temps mais qui fait
que on a tous confrontés à ça dans notre
vie
quotidienne très souvent ça paraît
impossible de faire et au fond les gens
se demandent plus est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce qui est pas interdit plutôt
que au fond est-ce que je peux vraiment
faire et avancer faut y aller voilà
c'est tous ces axesl les seuils les
délais les simplifications les
procédures uniques et ça va toucher nos
agriculteurs nos no artisans nos
commerçants nos entrepreneurs et nos
élus bonsoir monsieur le Président vous
avez évoqué dans le propos liminaire le
problème des déserts médicaux et vous
avez insisté sur tout ce que vous avez
mis en place pour arriver à y mettre fin
mais il y a une chose dont vous avez pas
parlé vous n'avez pas dit si vous étiez
favorable ou pas à des contraintes pour
l'installation des médecins dans les les
déserts médicaux vous qui vous voulez
sortir des codes et des cases est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous allez
mettre en place alors le problème il est
simple je je redonne le cadre pour nous
tous on a aujourd'hui un peu moins de
100000 médecins
généralistes on en a perdu 6000 en 10 an
c'est ça la réalité
et malgré le fait qu'en 2018 j'ai décidé
de reouvrir le numérus closus et donc de
créer plus de places on met 10 ans à
former des médecins et on a environ 25
30 % de nos médecins généralistes qui
ont plus de 60 ans c'est pas compliqué
on a un problème et à côté de ça on a
une population qui vieillit qui a de
plus en plus de maladie chronique c'est
ça le problème il est assez simple il
aurait dû être anticipé il y a 15 20 30
ans donc on doit créer plus de postes et
donc et ça ça va se faire à travers le
temps mais là pour nous les 5 à 7 ans
qui viennent le seul moyen c'est
d'organiser différemment les choses
alors est-ce que la contrainte c'est la
bonne
solution ma réponse est non je vous
parle je suis d'une famille de médecins
je suis le seul mauvais élève de ma
famille qui n''est pas fait
ça quel est le problème aussi qu'on a
pourquoi on n pas assez d'offre de soin
parce que les médecins qui font plus de
10 ans d'études ils vous disent à juste
titre quand ils finissent vous me poser
des contraintes pour la convention pas
la convention en fait j'ai contribué à
l'effort national j'ai fait tourner
l'hôpital comme externe et comme interne
ce qui est vrai dans notre système vous
allez pas me dire que je vais
m'installer làou là parce que qu'est-ce
qui va se passer je vous le signe ils
quitteront et l'un des problèmes qu'on a
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est qu'à cause
les habitudes ont changé là aussi les
meurs se changent beaucoup des médecins
qu'on a formé arrêteent leur activité de
médecine ils vont vers le secteur privé
c'està-dire dans l'entreprise dans des
laboratoires ils changent d'activité
quand ils sont à deux parfois il y en a
un qui se met en activité partielle ils
veulent pas travailler comme leurs
aînés ve plus être le médecin de
campagne ou le médecin de ville qui
prend des rendez-vous à longueur de
temps qui est réveillable la nuit et
donc il faut qu'on qu'on s'adapte au
changement d'époque et donc c'est une
solution qui paraît plus simple mais je
n'y crois pas compte tenu de aujourd'hui
la manière dont les étudiants sont
formés et dont l'équilibre même de notre
hôpital tient si on voulait faire ça
faudrait complètement changer le système
des externes des internes et autres par
contre je suis sûr d'une chose on a une
révolution de l'organisation à faire je
crois que ça c'est beaucoup plus
audacieux que de les obliger à aller là
aussi où je crois peu l'obligation
d'installation c'est que il y a
quasiment plus d'endroits où il y a pas
de désert
médical et quand on dit quand on pense
qu'il y a des Nirvanas surdotés c'est
vrai dans certaines zones très urbaines
très rich où l'éliotropisme joue dans
certaines spécialités médecin
généraliste c'est plus tellement vrai
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire faut
libérer du temps de médecin un aller
vers une rémunération plus intelligente
sans doute en fait au patient plutôt
qu'à l'acte ce qui permettra de mieux
intégrer la prévention aujourd'hui vous
êtes pas incité à faire de la prévention
du Monon travail de prévention vous êtes
plutôt inciter à faire le maximum d'ACT
de faire beaucoup plus travailler
ensemble la ville et l'hôpital comme on
l'a fait en période covid trois délégués
des actes on l'a fait pendant le covid
on a fait ensemble des petites
révolutions d'abord on a développé la
téléconsultation ça permet de libérer du
temps de médecin et d'aller face au
déserts médicaux permettre que des
vaccinations des renouvellements
d'ordonnances dans le cadre d'un réseau
de soin organisé soit fait par votre
pharmacien ou votre pharmacienne de
référence par l'infirmier ou
l'infirmière de déléguer des
actes à des paramédicaux qui permettent
de libérer du temps et de prendre plus
de
patients permettre aussi de mieux
organiser les choses dans ces maisons de
santé qui entre professionnels médicaux
paramédicaux permet de mieux organiser
le travail et puis on a un vrai problème
sur ce qu'on appelle le soin non
programmé c'est ce qui fait que nos
urgences sont engorgées là faut mieux
organiser ce ces accès aux soins
là-dessus qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a
déjà doublé en 6 ans le nombre de
maisons de santé on a près de 70 % de
notre population qui est couverte par la
régulation téléphonique médicale et la
réponse aux aides d'urgenence ces fameux
SAS donc on a beaucoup progressé faut
aller au bout de cela faut aller au bout
de ce qu'on a commencé à faire on y est
quasiment on est à 95 % mais que les
patients en afffection longue durée les
plus âgés et un médecin de référence et
il faut démultiplier cette logique de
terrain et c'est ça ce
qu'onit la solution elle est sur le
terrain je l'ai vu avec plusieurs
d'entre vousz-moi dans un même
département quand vous avez des gens qui
savent coopérer entre l'hôpital la ville
les paramédicaux qui font en fait ce que
je suis en train de dire ou qui l'ont
déjà développé il y a pas de désert là
où vous avez des mondes qui ne se
parlent pas où il y a pas eu assez de on
n pas assez prévu le changement vous
avez un désert qui s'est créé et donc
c'est pourquoi je crois à ces conseils
de la refondation territorialisé en
santé on a dans notre pays 1200 bassins
de vie pas très joli comme terme
qu'est-ce que c'est un bassin de vie ça
correspond à peu près à nos
intercommunalités mais c'est une réalité
physique sensible dans chacun d'entrex
faut une une feuille de route de santé
qui va inclure l'hôpital la clinique le
médecin de ville le paramédical et
cetera ça on va créer des postes on les
aide on va les accompagner avec plus
d'assistants médicaux on a déjà déployé
4600 donc voyez c'est une stratégie
d'ensemble au plus près du terrain et au
fond la philosophie de cette stratégie
c'est quoi on doit libérer du temps
médical en enlevant du temps
administratif et du temps médical mal
utilisé pour nos médecin et on doit
faire mieux travailler tout le monde
ensemble et puis on doit si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi débureaucratiser notre
santé parce que très longtemps pour
mieux maîtriser les coûts on a créé des
administrations fortes au National et en
région il y a des gens qui font un
travail formidable mais il faut plutôt
qu'on mette ces services en soutien des
équipes de santé sur ses bassins de vie
pour les accompagner à trouver des
solutions c'est faisable je crois plus à
ça qu'à la contrainte après là aussi si
dans certains endroits on veut
expérimenter ou autre je veux bien mais
on a besoin que nos soignants soient
surtout mobilisés qu'ils y trouvent leur
compte et donc cette stratégie elle
marche que si on engage les médecins les
infirmiers les aides médicaux les
auxiliaires de vie parce que c'est
médical médicos-social les kinés les les
pharmaciens et et les aidessignants et
j'en passe
voilà monsieur le Président de la
République Neil à l trousse BFM TV vous
venez d'évoquer les urgences engorgées
est-ce que cont tenu des difficultés
qu'a connu l'hôpital encore cet hiver
vous renoncez à votre promesse de
désengorger les urgences d'ici la fin de
l'année et un secteur aussi prioritaire
que la santé peut-il se permettre 5
ministres en 2 ans alors d'abord je
pense que surtout un secteur comme la
santé exiger un investissement
historique ce que nous avons fait avec
le segéur historique jamais dans notre
histoire on a autant réinvesti sur les
salaires c'est dire nos soignants à
l'hôpital ont eu une augmentation de
salaire mensuel de 200 à 480 € par mois
jamais ça n'avait existé dans notre
histoire par mois et c'est du salaire
pas des primes qui sont pas prises en
compte et un peu plus de 19 milliards
d'euros d'investissement pour rénover
nos hôpitaux bon donc c'est ça dont
avait besoin de notre santé on l'a fait
maintenant faut le déployer c'est un
énorme travail d'organisation qui est
mené un peu partout en France avec une
mobilisation de nos équipes
hospitalières administratives et
médicales exemplaires et je les en
remercie donc oui on va tenir l'objectif
bien sûr et et on le tient comment avec
la stratégie que je viens d'évoquer pour
votre collègue on a déjà développé pour
70 % de notre population ce qu'on
appelle les SAS c'est-à-dire ce
dispositif pour le soins non programmé
c'était zéro il y a 2 ans il y a 3 ans
cétait zéro c'està dire qu'en fait il y
a 3 ans comme on avait mis fin c'était
il y a une quinzaine d'années à
l'obligation de garde vous vous souvenez
de ce système qui était quand même pas
mal où il y avait l'obligation pour les
médecins sur un territoire de
s'organiser la nuit et les weekend on a
mis fin à ça au début des années 2000
bah le système c'est c'était plus
organisé et c'est ça qui a renvoyé toute
la pression à l'hôpital c'est le fait
que vous n'aviez plus de réponse pour ce
qu'on appelle le soin non programmé
c'estàd au fond vous aviez le choix
entre prendre rendez-vous chez votre
médecin si vous en aviez un ou aller
directement aux urgences bah là on a
recréé un système en coopérant avec
justement les médecins sur le
terrain qui permet d'avoir un numéro de
téléphonie médicale qui permet une
demande d' médical d'urgence pour les
soins bon programmés et qui permet
d'organiser le système entre les
infirmiers les infirmières et les
médecins sur un même territoire mais en
les rémunérant mieux et en leur donnant
un accompagnement administratif on en
est à 70 % on sera on va essayer d'aller
à 100 % des C durant cette année
2024 si on fait ça on désengorge
beaucoup les urgences parce qu'on a une
vraie réponse et puis à côté de ça il
faut qu'on continue de mieux
responsabiliser celles et ceux qui ont
recours de manière indu aux urgences et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on est en
train de regarder avec les hôpitaux
quand vous avez des gens qui même pour
des petits bobos après deux trois fois
continuent d'aller directement aux
urgences bah il faut pouvoir les
responsabiliser c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un reste à charge parce que sinon ça va
pas c'est ça le système
responsabilisation organisation du
système de soins et donc d'un système
qui évite les urgences en ville donc oui
on tiendra l'objectif parce qu'on a
réinvesti aussi massivement sur notre
hôpital maintenant ce qu'on va continuer
de faire durant cette année c'est
d'aider et surtout dans les grandes
villes où la vie est chère à mieux
recruter les paramédicaux parce que
malgré ces augmentations de salaire une
des difficultés qu'on voit dans les
grand ville où c'est très cher de se
loger bah c'est que beaucoup pour
beaucoup d'infirmiers d'infirmières pour
beaucoup d'aide soignant ça reste très
cher d'habiter près de l'hôpital et donc
là on veut engager un travail et
d'ailleurs nos directeurs et directrices
d'hôpitaux le font hein avec les
communes qui consiste à à essayer
d'avoir des solutions de logement pour
ces derniers et leurs famill et
permettre de réengager parce que si on a
un problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
manque beaucoup encore quand on dit les
lits sont fermés c'est parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à recruter malgré ses
augmentations de salaire et dans les
grandes villes c'est beaucoup les
paramédicaux voilà et les ministres j'ai
répondu les ministres c'est la vie
politique et donc ce qui compte c'est
que le cap ne change pas il a pas changé
d'un yota la feuille de route n'a pas
changé l'investissement est là je peux
vous dire mieux vaut ce que je suis en
train de vous décrire qu'un seul
ministre sans investissement et sans
cap bonsoir monsieur le Président Jérémi
Trottin pour RMC une question toujours
sur la les consultations vous évoquez
tout à l'heure ce sujet en indiquant
qu'il fallait peut-être réfléchir
davantage aux patients qu' il y a aussi
un débat qui traîne depuis la fin de
l'été celui sur les franchises médicales
et de doublement notamment à la fois sur
les consultations mais aussi sur les
boîtes de médicaments aujourd'hui chaque
Français lorsqu'il achète une boîte de
médicament payer une franchise de 50
centimes le débat existe allez-vous le
doubler passer cette franchise à 1 €
cela permettrait je crois de de d'un
certain nombre d'économie 800 millions
d'euros de recettes en plus pour les
caises de la sécurité sociale est-ce que
vous pouvez vous priver d'une telle
recette et deuxième question peut-être
cette fois toujours sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat j'ai pas très bien
compris si les Français allaient voir
leur électricité augmenter de 10 % ou
pas tout à l'heure quand vous avez
répondu à la question de mon collègue de
TF1 parce qu'il l'a pas formulé comme ça
mais je peux vous dire que je me
substiurai pas au gouvernement pour
faire pour faire les annonces précises
mais ce que je disais c'est que
l'électricité le prix va revenir dans la
norme mais surtout il restera quel que
soit ce que le gouvernement annonce dans
les prochains
jours substantiellement inférieur à ce
qui est payé en Allemagne en Espagne en
Italie ça faut le regarder aussi et donc
là où ça aurait dû augmenter de plus de
100 % l'année dernière ça a dû augmenter
de 25 % l'électricité et on va continuer
d'avoir un prix deélectricité nettement
inférieur à nos voisins sur votre
premier
point nous sommes un pays qui soigne
bien qui ne prévient pas assez et donc
votre question me permet d'abord
d'insister sur un sujet qu'on n pas
assez évoqué même si on parle de santé
je m'en réjouis depuis tout à l'heure
c'est que dans la stratégie de santé que
la ministre aura à conduire auprès du
Premier ministre et qu'elle connaî est
bien parce que elle l'a porté aussi dans
sa ville dans son agglomération et puis
dans ses compétences
intérieures on doit beaucoup mieux
prévenir aujourd'hui on va développer
les diagnostics de santé pour les
enfants les adolescents et les adultes
on a massivement
développé la vaccination et on va
continuer par exemple pour le papiom
virirus et d'autres et donc on doit
beaucoup mieux
prévenir ce qui veut dire aussi qu'on
doit conjurer une forme de fatalité
français qui est qu'on consomme trop de
médecine
en même temps qu'on a une des médecines
les plus socialisées du monde
c'est-à-dire où c'est pas le
consommateur qui la paye mais c'est
toujours pareil il y a pas d'argent
magique quand c'est pas le consommateur
qui la paye c'est le contribuable qui la
paye et donc au moment où de manière
sérieuse je vois ce que nos compatriotes
peuvent dépenser pour les forfaits de
téléphonie la vie quotidienne se dire
qu'on va passer de 50 centimes à 1 €
pour un paquet de pour un paquet pardon
pour un
médicament boîte de médicament j'ai pas
sentiment qu'on fait un crime
terrible je pense que ça responsabilise
et que c'est une bonne mesure il faut
responsabiliser sur la consommation par
contre ce qu'il faut garder c'est un
élément de justice c'est que pour nos
compatriotes qui ont des affections de
longue durée c'està-dire des maladie qui
supposent des prescriptions régulières
eux faut continuer de les protéger et
eux ils sont protégés parce qu'on a mis
un plafond c'est qu'ils sont pas plus de
50 € par an ça faut le garder donc on va
faire quelque chose de juste je crois
c'est-à-dire qu'on responsabilise la
médecine le soin les médicaments ça ne
coûte pas rien on prend déjà beaucoup en
charge quasiment tout et donc oui moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose de
passer de 50 centimes à 1 € par boîte de
médicament franchement ça ne me choque
pas quand je vois ce que coûte beaucoup
d'autres éléments de la vie quotidienne
qui sont moins essentiels que le
médicament quand il est prescrit ou
quand il est important et à côté de ça
on va continuer de protéger ceux qui ont
un besoin de consommation régulière
parce qu'ils ont des affections de
longue durée et ils continueront à avoir
cette protection parce qu'ils auront un
plafond de 50 € par an pour se reste à
charge parce qu'il faut responsabiliser
c'est une bonne
chose Monsieur le président Olivier B
RTL je voudrais revenir un instant sur
les questions qui concernent la la
jeunesse et en particulier les questions
pour les enfants vous avez dit nous
déterminerons le bon usage de nos écrans
pour les enfants question simple est-ce
que vous voulez empêcher les enfants
d'accéder à des écrans mais surtout
comment quels sont les les leviers
publics pour cela comment réguler est-ce
que vous comptez sur les opérateurs ou
sur les les fabricants de de téléphone
pour cela et puis quelle tranche d'âge
visez-vous des plus jeunes jusqu'aux
adolescents jusqu'à quel âge merci pour
ces précisions bon c'est une question
qui est essentielle quiconque a des
enfants ou des
adolescents ne ne peut pas
l'éluder ces dernières années on a tous
ensemble beaucoup avancé sur le sujet
avant il y avait quasiment pas de
régulation d'abord je constate un fait
c'est que tout le monde voit que les
enfants et les ados passent du temps sur
les écrans les usages changent c'est
l'écran c'est souvent le téléphone le
sien pour un adolescent quand ses
parents le lui en achète sinon c'est
celui de des parents eux-mêmes mais ça
commence très jeune et je regarde les
chiffres qui sont donnés par les
scientifiques les sociologues les les
cliniciens on a des enfants de 2 ans et
beaucoup qui passe parfois plusieurs
heures par jour devant un écran on a et
c'est à peu près établi des enfants qui
avant 6 ans en exposition
régulière et on a ensuite beaucoup de
nos adolescents et nos jeunes qui ont
accès au savoir à l'information à
l'actualité uniquement par les
écrans tout ça et pour le coup pour
avoir réunir assembler passer du temps
écouter les meilleurs experts c'est pas
un avis politique c'est
d'abord j'aurais demandé un consensus
scientifique ça a un impact passer du
temps devant un écran ça a un impact sur
le développement affectif sensoriel
cognitif d'un
enfant passer du temps dans un écran et
accéder à l'information très jeune sans
avoir des repères sans savoir comment
hiérarchiser l'information la classifier
avoir des bases ça donne un rapport à la
vérité à la
contrevérité qui est une vraie un vrai
sujet pour nos démocraties ça revient
d'ailleurs à ce que je disais sur le bon
ordre la manière d'apprendre l'histoire
l'ru civque et autr et donc c'est un
continent cognitif affectif de
construction du savoir qui est très
important pour l'équilibre de nos
enfants et nos adolescents et qui est
très important aussi pour la solidité de
nos démocrati parce que si on a des
adolescents et des futurs citoyens dont
le rapport à la vérité a été mal bâti en
tout cas construit sur des réseaux
sociaux la différence entre la vérité la
contrevérité était pas clair bonjour la
génération des
complotistes et même pour la génération
d'avant on n'a pas totalement réussi à
le conjurer on en a tous fait
l'expérience alors on a commencé on a
bien vu que tout ça et en plus de ça les
écrans évidemment exposent aussi à des
phénomènes de société qui font souffrir
nos jeunes et nos ados on en a parlé
pour le harcèlement scolaire et le
iharcèlement qui Contin continu en ligne
on a commencé à faire où on en a parlé
pour euh l'exposition euh à la
pornographie et euh euh l'usage de ces
le mauvais usage de des contenus
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ces dernières
années on a eu une approche d'abord par
les contenus donc on a défini au niveau
européen la majorité à 15 ans on a
commencé à bâtir des textes on a
sanctionné mis une responsabilité et
l'Europe est aux avant-postes sur ce
sujet les autres continents ne font pas
ça mais on a mis une responsabilité des
diffuseurs de contenu on a accru
justement la protection de nos enfants
et cetera et cetera on a interdit je
vous le rappelle le portable au collège
c'était un de mes engagements de 2017 on
a mis en place grâce à nos
parlementaires un contrôle parental sur
les téléphones en demandant justement
aux opérateurs et aux constructeurs de
téléphone de mettre en place des
forfaits des téléphones qui ne
permettent pas d'avoir accès à certains
services à supposer que les parents
achètent bien un téléphone pour leur
adolescents et leur prêent pas le leur
il y a pas de système parfait là ce que
j'ai voulu avec cette commission qui est
installé et qui rendra ses travaux fin
mars c'est d'abord établir un consensus
scientifique c'est-à-dire qu'on éclaire
le débat public qu'est-ce que la science
nous dit sur les impacts sur nos enfants
et nos adolescents des écrans de que de
manière scientifique les meilleurs
experts nous disent est-ce qu'il y a des
règles de base est-ce qu'il y a
peut-être vont-ils nous dire avant tel
âge donc moi je peux pas vous répondre
aujourd'hui je vous le dis en toute
humilité mais je veux que les meilleurs
scientifiques il y a à la fois des
épidémiologistes des cliniciens des
sociologues on a pris toutes les
disciplines puisse nous dire avant tel
âge ça n'est pas raisonnable de mettre
un écran devant un enfant entre tel âge
et tel âge c'est pour tel usage avec un
maximum de tendeur par jour il faut
accompagner les familles on a laissé
beaucoup de familles sans mode
d'emploi c'est ça la réalité et on a
tous dit c'est bien de développer les
écrans dès le primaire pour accéder au
savoir mais on n pas mis de limite et
donc il faut un qu'on a un consensus
scientifique de que les scientifiques
commencent à nous donneremp et qu'on
éclaire un débat public qui viendra
ensuite et donc il y aura peut-être des
interdictions il y aura peut-être des
restrictions il y aura peut-être aussi
des restrictions sur les contenus et il
y aura je l'espère un bon usage de
l'utilisation des écrans pour toutes les
raisons que je viens
d'évoquer bonsoir monsieur le président
Louis alter du Figaro il y a 6 mois de
violentes émeutes ont éclaté dans le
pays et ont beaucoup marqué les Français
à l'époque vous n'avez pas apporté de
réponse immédiate vous avez dit vouloir
prendre le temps de comprendre les
ressorts profonds de ce qui s'est passé
nous sommes 6 mois après alors quelle
lecture faites-vous de ces événements
est-ce que comme la droite vous faites
un lien avec l'immigration ou en tout
cas avec un échec de l'intégration et
est-ce que vous pensez que les mesures
que vous venez d'annoncer sur la
jeunesse vont suffire à éviter que ça ne
se reproduise
est-ce que vous comptez apporter des
réponses plus spécifiques je pense par
exemple au service national universel à
une éventuelle généralisation c'estàdire
une obligation pour toute une tranche
d'âge je vous remercie merci beaucoup
d'évoquer cette question vous avez
raison d'y revenir j'essaie de qualifier
les émeutes qu'on a eu l'été dernier
d'abord jeis dire que ces émeutes elles
ont eu en face d'ell une réponse
implacable de l'état des forces de
sécurité intérieure les nuits et de la
justice c'est un record
d'interpellation
condamnation donc la réponse a été
implacable et sans qu'on ait besoin de
déclarer quelqu état d'urgence ou autre
il y a pas de molesse maintenant j'essa
de voir ce qu'il y parce qu'on a voulu
tout de suite dire c'est un problème
d'immigration un problème de ceci de
cela 500 villes ont connu ces émeut la
moitié éta des villes avec des quartiers
politiques de la ville la moitié
non donc quelque chose s'est passé qui
était quand même pas totalement dans
notre cartographie habituelle est-ce que
c'est un problème d'immigration comme
j'ai dit je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qui disent qu'il y a pas de problème
d'immigration c'est pour ça que j'ai
assumé qu'on porte une loi c'est un
sujet il faut mieux maîtriser nos
frontières lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine est-ce que c'est la réalité
ce qu'on a vu sur le terrain non c'était
des jeunes de nationalité française pour
une quasi totalité née en France qui a
un problème d'intégration derrière oui
pas besoin des émeutes pour le savoir
oui et qui va des deux côtés parce qu'on
a encore trop d'assignation à résidence
et parce qu'on n pas été assez rigoureux
sur certains points et ce qu'on mène en
matière de innovation urbaine en matière
d'éducation en matière d'accès à la
culture au sport et en matière justement
aussi d'opportunités économique pour moi
doit y continuer mais c'est plus
compliqué ce qui s'est passé quand j'ai
parlé au maire dans les 500 communes où
il y a eu ce ces émeutes d'abord elles
sont intervenu fin
juin c'était beaucoup de très jeunes qui
étaient dans les rues et c'était des
jeunes c'est une erreur qu'on a
commise qui était souvent sans école
depuis le mois
d'avril réforme du brevet réforme du
baccalauréat l'organisation commune le
système tel qui marche plus de
classe
loisiveté saz les vieux précepts parfois
disent beaucoup c'était des jeunes qui
ont pas la chance d'avoir des familles
qui les emmènent à la mer à la montagne
qui justement ont pas assez accès à la
culture au sport ils
s'ennuyent il y a eu un événement
déclencheur la mort d'un jeune je ne
parlerai pas de ce qui est en cours et
dans c'était dans le cadre d'une
opération policière on s'en souvient
tous des jeunes Noë et l'enquête est en
cours donc je ne veux pas en dire plus
là-dessus mais ça a étéit l'élément
déclencheur il y avait
ça des jeunes sans activité très jeunes
et ensuite les écrans ont eu un rôle
très important qu'on avait jamais vu
c'est-à-dire en quelques minutes on
voyait des centaines d'actions se
déployer les rendez-vous donnés sur tel
ou tel je ferai pas de stigmatisation
réseau social par l'écran et il y a eu
une forme de mimétisme qui a conduit à
un embrasement totalement déraisonné
et ça a été une forme d'émeute
totalement nouvelle qu'on a vécu des
jeunes très jeunes qui allaient pas à
l'école qui étaient tous derrière leurs
écrans qui utilisaient les écrans pour
se rassembler et qui en quelque sorte se
lançaiit des défis par écran et qui
était cette génération un peu que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure donc vous voyez
bien que la réponse
elle peut pas être univoque c'est pour
ça que j'ai pas voulu céder à
l'injonction du moment est-ce que la
réponse c'est l'immigration c'est la la
lutte contre l'immigration non il faut
lu apporter mais c'est pas une réponse
aux émeutes est-ce que la réponse
c'était plus de policiers non on a
recréé on avait recréé déjà et dans ces
villes elles avaient toutes plus de
policiers que 2 ans avant toutes est-ce
que la réponse cétait plus
d'investissement politique de la ville
ce que me disait disait de l'autre côté
c'est pas vrai on avait plus de
programme de l'Agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine dans toutes ces
villes il y a jamais eu autant de Gru
dans ces villes jamais j'ai plus que
doublé le budget de l'anrue durant le
premier mandat il est passé de 5 à 12
milliards d'engagements donc les
réponses faciles de gauche et de droite
classique que j'ai j'ai vu selon les
orientations des après tout faux réponse
plus compliquée et donc la réponse c'est
de se dire un on doit réengager avec les
familles c'est ce que je disais je v pas
ici rentrer dans le détail être trop
long accompagner les familles pour les
aider ce qu'on a commencé avec les les 1
premier jours mais on a besoin
d'accompagner certaines familles 60 % de
ces jeunes venaient de famille
monoparental ça c'est un continent caché
on a commencé à y répondre dans le
premier quinena avec les Z parce que
beaucoup de ces mamans seuls 95 % sont
des mamans souvent on leur payit pas la
pension on a apporté des réponses par
nos réformes mais on voit bien
quand une famille monoparentale élève un
jeune deux jeunes trois adolescents
c'est très dur et donc on doit les aider
et les responsabiliser ensuite on a un
sujet sur l'accompagnement des jeunes
qui commencent à
décrocher avoir une réponse plus adaptée
dans le système scolaire mais aussi
avoir une réponse je dirais prépénale
puis pénale qui est plus claire ça fait
partie des choses qu'on est en train de
préparer on a l'accès au sport et à la
culture essentiel pour ces jeunes on a
réorganiser déjà ça c'est une réponse à
ces émeutes le temps scolaire ils iront
tous jusqu'en juillet il y aura plus de
temps scolaire qui est perdu en mai et
en juin et ça c'est essentiel de le
tenir les écrans la réponse arrive et
donc c'est un
ensemble c'est un problème beaucoup plus
compliqué dans ce contexte là oui le
service national universel fait partie
de la c'est pourquoi j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir dans les prochaines semaines
mais nous irons vers la généralisation
du service national universel en
seconde il est cohérent avec ce que je
viens de vous
décrire bonsoir monsieur le Président
Laurence Ferrari C news Europe 1 Paris
Match vous nous avez gratifié d'un
certain nombre de mesures de détails
cette ance qui nous intéresse c'est la
vision que vous avez pour notre pays
pour les 3 ans à venir la fin de notre
mandat à nos yeux ce qui est important
euh c'est sans doute l'éducation
nationale qui concentre tous les enjeux
toutes les fractures de notre société
nous avons l'éducation nationale la plus
chère au monde au classement PISA vous
le savez nous ne brillons pas notamment
en math aux capesses de math nous avons
du mal à recruter il y a plus de que
postees que de candidats vous voulez
qu'il chante la Marseillaise
pratiquement un jeune sur deux ne sait
pas situer la Révolution française ne
connaît pas la Choa ne sait pas ce qui
s'est passé le jour de la rafle du
veldive 48 % des professeurs disent se
censurer lorsqu ils enseignent
l'histoire dans leur classe un sur deux
à peur en classe peur de la violence des
élèves des parents et des terroristes je
pense ce soir à Samuel pati et Dominique
Bernard vous voulez restaurer l'autorité
la France doit rester la France bien sûr
comment faire de ces jeunes des citoyens
éclairés donnez-moi cinq mesures
concrètes pour restaurer cette autorité
soutenir les parents c'est bien les
responsabiliser c'est mieux aussi et
puis il y a 17 % des parents qui ont
fait le choix du privé c'est fort
honorable après tout est-ce que la
guerre école privée école publique n'a
pas été relancé par votre Ministre de
l'Éducation nationale merci pour votre
réponse et j'ai le sentiment de donner
une vision et des mesures concrètes je
crois que vous venez vous-même de poser
une question et de donner votre vision
et ceci étant dit ceci étant dit les
mesures concrètes je vous les ai donné
il y a pas d'école qui tiennent s'il y a
pas des professeur bien
formé refonde de la formation des
enseignants des mars on a des concours
on sait qu'ils ne sont pas tous pourvus
parce que le système aujourd'hui il est
pas adapté on a des professeurs
remarquables remarquables et je veux pas
qu'on aille vers la stigmatisation de de
nos enseignants loin de là on doit mieux
les payer ce qu'on a commencé de faire
on va continuer le pacte on doit mieux
les former la deuxième mesure très
concrète c'est de poursuivre le choc des
savoirs pourquoi les les résultats PISA
sont mauvais et parce que les résultats
PISA sont faits sur des classes qui
n'ont pas été touchés par les réformes
qu'on a conduitite au premier quinquena
donc je veux bien payer pour tout le
monde c'est c'est déjà ce qu'on fait
pour pour la santé et autres c'est ce
qui a pas été prévu par il y a 20 ans
mais ceux qui ont été testés à la
réforme PISA ils ont eu à vivre la
réforme du collège qui avait été
décidé avant
2017 attendons ceux qui ont eu à suivre
et les tests nous montrent que
d'ailleurs on a des élèves qui ont
beaucoup mieux résisté en primaire grâce
au dédoublement et ce qu'on a eu à faire
et les ministre a apporté la réponse
donc moi j'assume vous me parlez de
résultats qui ne sont pas liés aux
réformes qu'on a faite qu'est-ce que
c'est la bonne réponse pour avoir des
élèves bien formés après la réforme de
l'enseignement des professeurs meilleure
rémunération systé finir la
systématisation du dédoublement des
classes pour les grandes sections de
maternelle après ce que nous avons fait
pour CP et CE1 c'est l'évaluation fin
d'année qu'on va progressivement
généraliser à tous les niveaux on l'a
commencé l'année dernière c'est
essentiel parce que c'est ce qui permet
d'éviter le passage d'une classe l'autre
sans avoir sans avoir la totale maîtrise
de ce qui était supposé et c'est
remettre du dédoublement à l'initiative
des professeurs dans les classes
charnières ce qui a été décidé pour le
CM2 et avec un brevet qui a du sens
qu'il faut réviser et qui est une
condition de passage au collège 4è point
qui est indispensable c'est
l'instruction civique et l'instruction
civique qui ne soit pas un ensemble de
connaissances de nature diverses et qui
est enseigné de manière inégale sur le
territoire avec leure obligatoire dès la
5e où on apprend les textes fondamentaux
où on apprend si elle n'a pas été
maîtrisée la Marseillaise mais je
souhaite qu'elle soit enseignée dès le
primaire je l'ai déjà dit et où on
apprend aussi les grands textes qui font
notre histoire ce sont des mesures très
concrètes et j'en ai doné notes dans mon
propos introductif donc oui il faut
continuer d'avancer on a depuis
2017 commencé à rebattir l'école on
s'est attaqué là au collège il y a toute
la réforme aussi de l'orientation et on
s'attaque aussi au lycée professionnel
dont on parle peu mais qui touche un/ers
de nos lycéens qui est indispensable et
sur lequel aussi on est en train de
conduire une vraie petite révolution des
savoirs
moi je suis un enfant des deux écoles
comme disent les grands
auteurs j'ai été à la laïque et à
l'école privée sous contrat j ai vu des
professeurs engagés à qui je dois
beaucoup donc je pense qu'il y a pas de
conflit entre les deux écoles à avoir
que la la France la République est forte
de tous ces systèmes ce qu'il faut c'est
engager tout le monde dans les mêmes
exigences et donc il faut que partout on
puisse avoir d'abord on juge pas les
gens sur leur choix individuel je pense
que le choix de l'école où on met ses
enfants c'est un choix privé on n pas
juger les gens à leur faire des procès
là-dessus et ensuite on doit tout faire
pour qu'on ait une école publique qui
soit au meilleur standard et qui soit
forte une école privée sous contrat qui
soit la plus forte possible et qui
respecte parfaitement les règles de la
République et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
a besoin d'une école privée sous contrat
qui s'engage au côté de l'école publique
pour ouvrir des classulis pour
accompagner les enfants en difficultés
pour avoir des sec pas et cetera et
cetera c'est ça le bon système voilà
donc les polémiques du moment ne doivent
pas nous faire quitter l'axe qui est le
nôtre la réussite de nos enfants et une
école forte c'est un des fondements de
la
République bonsoir monsieur le Président
Justine guitousion pour reporter vous
avez évoquer l'avenir des générations
futures depuis que vous avez créé le
Haut Conseil pour le climat en 2019 tous
les rapports annuel ont montré que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ne
bais ne baissaient pas suffisamment vite
euh donc comment comptez-vous atteindre
les objectifs climatiques européens
2030- 2050 vous avez évoqué ce soir le
leasing la rénovation des bâtiments
c'est des annonces que vous aviez déjà
faites il y a 6 mois voire il y a 1 an
donc globalement quel nouvelle politique
écologique vous pouvez nous annoncer
concrètement ce soir sachant que Gabriel
Atal n'a pas n'a quasiment pas encore
évoquer la planification écologique que
saufreur de ma part Christophe Béchu
n'est pas là ce soir et et qu'il n'y a
plus de ministère de la transition
énergétique quelle nouvelle politique
écologique vous pouvez nous annoncer ce
soir d'abord je je plaide l'indulgence
pour le Premier ministre qui n'a pas pu
évoquer tous les sujets et même celui-ci
qui continue d'être dans son
titre et qui aura l'occasion d'y revenir
dans les prochains jours sa déclaration
de politique générale quant au ministre
précisément parce qu'il est en charge et
qu'il ne vous a pas échappé qu'on a
beaucoup de territoires qui sont touchés
je pense à nos compatriotes de la
Réunion nos compatriotes du pcal il est
mobilisé sur le terrain il avait aussi
des obligations
parlementaires je vais être clair parce
que je là aussi c'est comme ce que je
disais pour la santé moi je crois au Cap
aux mesures claires et après à leur mise
en œuvre je vais pas vous annoncer
aujourd'hui un nouveau cap écologique
parce que je pense qu'on a pris des
décisions historiques et qu'elles sont
les bonnes j'ai pris un
engagement d'abord qui était de faire
une nation plus forte plus industrielle
et décarbonée vous avez cité les
rapports du Haut Conseil pour le climat
soyons collectivement honnête il nous a
dit qu'ontait onait pas assez vite pour
les années à venir mais il a reconnu les
résultats ils sont d'ailleurs publiques
des années passé durant mon quinquen
précédent on est revenu sur la
trajectoire des accords de Paris et nous
avons doublé les réductions d'émission
de gaz à effet de serre doublé
c'est-à-dire qu'alors même qu'on a
recréé 2 millions d'emplois qu'on a
rouvert 300 usines en net qu'on a
commencé à réindustrialiser le pays on a
été deux fois plus vite sur la baisse
des émissions comme quoi ce qui nous
explique qu'il faudrait fermer telle ou
telle activité pour respecter la
trajectoire climat pas vrai ce que nous
a dit le Conseil climat il nous a dit
pour tenir votre engagement dans les
années qui viennent faut aller 2,5 fois
plus vite c'est tout à fait vrai ben je
constate que les chiffres qui sont à ma
disposition pour l'année qui vient de
s'écouler sont dans cette ligne faut
passer de 2 % à 5 % par an on a été de 2
% par an entre 2018 et 2022 on est à 4,6
% sur
2023 donc ce qu'on a fait pour
l'acroître est en train de fonctionner
là stratégie c'est décrite à Marseille
c'est quoi un Premier ministre qui
pilote la planification écologique et
énergétique c'est toujours le cas son
dans ses attributions on a créé pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de notre
République une administration qui lui
est attaché pour cela un secrétariat
général pourquoi parce que c'est
interministériel les efforts se font
dans tous les secteurs ensuite on a
travaillé pendant un an à une
planification là aussi inédit et on a
défini les efforts à faire et les
actions concrètes dans chaque
secteur maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train de faire on la territorialise
et donc dans chaque région on a mis en
place une COP justement de cette
planification et on est en train de
bâtir des projets avec chaque commune
intercommunalité métropole département
et région pour pouvoir déployer les
bonnes actions et donc il y a pas une
solution miracle il y a pas une annonce
fracassante il y a les dizaines de
milliards d'euros qu'on investit chaque
année pour accompagner cette transition
pour qu'elle soit juste et des
stratégies locales qu'on va développer
c'est qui nos fameux
service métropolitain de transport
collectif pour permettre de moins
recourir à la voiture individuelle et
avoir des transport hydrogène ou
électrique et on est en train de les
déployer on a eu la carte elle a été
annoncée c'est accompagné et on a des
records d'adhésion au véhicule hybride
ou électrique c'est le changement de
véhicule il faut le faire avec le bonus
écologique qui a beaucoup augmenté
maintenant le leasing qui commence à se
déployer c'est on sait en effet la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments il
faut continuer de simplifier la prime
qui existe mais là on y met beaucoup
d'argent
et on va continuer de le faire et puis
ensuite c'est secteur par secteur et
l'un des secteurs où on a beaucoup
investi l'année dernière c'est aussi
celui de l'industrie parce qu'on a
identifié que sur 50 sites industriels
si on faisait l'effort on faisait
quasiment la moitié de ce qu'on doit
faire sur l'ensemble de notre industrie
et donc on a mis on a accéléré les
effortfits pour décarboner nos
cimenteries nos ports nos assiries et
cetera et on signe des contrats avec nos
industriels et ces sites pour permettre
justement de continuer d'avoir des
emplois et de moins émettre c'est une
stratégie d'ensemble donc là aujourd'hui
le temps il est plus au annonces il est
à faire sur le terrain à évaluer mois
par mois et donc la priorité dans les
prochains mois sur la planification
écologique et ben c'est de déployer le
plan qui est le nôtre sur le terrain à
côté de ça j'avais à bellefort annoncé
une stratégie énergétique et làdessus on
a une force la France est un des pays
d'Europe qui a l'énergie la plus
décarbonée grâce au nucléaire j'ai
annoncé et là aussi en créant les
conditions d'un d'un consensus
scientifique puis politique tout le
monde l'a oublié il y a 6 ans personne
était d'accord sur le nucléaire
rappelez-vous les débats qu'on avait
j'ai demandé un rapport aux meilleurs
experts et cetera j'ai été à belellefort
entouré de forces politiques qui
s'opposaient sur ce sujet na guerre on a
annoncé une nouvelle stratégie on
redéploie du nucléaire et on redéploie
du renouvelable et là aussi on est au
travaux pratiqu j'ai annoncé les Sit des
si nouveaux réacteurs les travaux les
investissements et tout le travail
commence à EDF à l'été
j'annoncerai les grands axes pour les h
prochains et c'est de la mise en œuvre
et on l'a fait pareil sur le
renouvelable avec nos stratégies pour
déployer leséolien en mer et cetera et
cetera c'est de la mise en œuvre mais
les résultats des six dernières années
sont bons les résultats des derniers
mois montre que on a doublé le taux
d'effort on a une stratégie une
organisation
faut de l'efficacité des résultats et
maintenant la territorialiser c'està
dire travailler avec nos
élus bonsoir monsieur le Président
Julien Lécuyer de la voie du Nord je
vais vous citer un chiffre 98,5 % c'est
c'est le pourcentage de la surface de
Calais qui pourrait être submergé par la
mer dans les dizaines d'années à venir
quelques dizaines d'années à venir 82 %
de la surface de duncarc aussi alors
question simple c'est que vaudra la
stratégie de
réindustrialisation si les gigafactory
ont les pieds dans l'eau que vaudra la
politique de de décarbonation si
harceleur mythal est noyé sous les sous
les EAU on a des milliers de nos
habitants du du pcalis qui sont
actuellement touchés par les les
intempéries que leur dites-vous est-ce
que vous leur dites comme le votre
ministre de la transition écologique
qu'il faudra peut-être à terme déménager
merci alors d'abord je veux I
redire à nos compatriotes dans le pas
decalé qui vivent depuis maintenant des
mois une situation terrible notre
soutien j'ai été auprès d'eux il y a
quelques semaines ministre de
l'intérieur comme le ministre de la
transition ils sont allés à plusieurs
reprises le Premier ministre il a fait
son premier déplacement il reviendra à
la fin du
mois je vais leur dire notre soutien
complet entier mais c'est épuisant ce
qu'ils vivent parce qu'ils ont vu la
montée des eaux les inondations l'eau
qui ne descend pas puis les
précipitations à nouveau et donc c'est
épuisant pour les ner et ils vivent dans
dans des maisons qui ont parfois un m
d'eau parfois ils ont tout perdu et donc
un on va continuer à intensifier nos
efforts pour pomper et pour évacuer
cette eau de évidemment on sera à leur
côté pour restaurer au plus vite et là
aussi avec de la simplification et un
pilotage sur le terrain avec la Région
le Département et et les maires au plus
près et puis on sera à leur côté aussi
pour indemniser et mettre la pression
sur les assurances et accompagner les
particuliers comme les commerçants et
les entrepreneurs et les
agriculteurs on sera là mais le problème
que vous posez est une réalité je
l'évoqué de manière rapide dans mon
propos introductif c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'adaptation et c'est tout à
fait vrai que quels que soi les efforts
qu'on fait pour baisser nos émissions
pour changer nos manières de produire de
consommer et cetera et nous mettre en
conformité avec la stratégie de Paris
nous aurons à vivre les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique il est déjà là et
donc on doit s'adapter qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire dire qu'on va
devoir changer nos villes nos paysages
nos régions pour faire face à des
événements climatiques auquels elle
n'était pas habitué ça veut dire que
dans beaucoup de nos villes on va devoir
faire face aux fortes chaleur qui vont
plus être simplement un ou deux jours
par an c'est les îlos de chaleur con
crée c'est de la végétalisation des
villes c'est une organisation différente
ça veut dire que on va progressivement
adapter nos villes nos paysages et là
faut le faire avec le beau et le
résistant si je puis dire c'est ça cette
stratégie d'adaptation qu'on va bâtir il
y a aucune fatalité et je le dis très
clairement à nos compatriotes des haute
France on continuera à vivre à dunkererc
à Cala on continuera à vivre dans
l'odomarois et on pourra vivre être
heureux au marais comme dans le
montreois qui met aussi cher et qui
souffre aussi beaucoup comment en
adaptant il y aura peut-être des
endroits où on devra créer des
interdictions mais surtout on doit
repenser aussi ce qu'on avait
oublié ce qui d'ailleurs travaill ou
vivent dans le Mara à saint-homer ou
ailleurs me l'ont rappelez quand moi j'y
suis allé
avant l'évacuation vers la mer se
faisait beaucoup plus simplement les
watering fonctionnaient mieux on
avait on curait plus simplement les
cours d'eau et on avait un accès à la
mer qui était qui allait beaucoup plus
vite qui va plus de mèes CUB parce que
le port était plus adapté et le temps à
travers le temps il y a certains
investissements qui n'ont pas été faits
nos règles se complexifiant le coût de
certaines opérations augmentent et là où
on le faisait avec les les collègues où
c'était simple et pas cher de le faire
on a créé de Tell norme qu'on le fait
plus c'est ça ce qui s'est passé
progressivement c'est pour ça qu'on a
d'ailleurs confié au maire de saint-omè
une mission pour s'inspirer des
meilleures pratiques européennes et
regarder comment on va faciliter
l'écoulement de l'eau vers la mer donc
il y a des réponses l'adaptation il y a
des réponses et parfois il y a des
réponses vous savez de bon sens que les
gens qui vivent sur ces territoires
connaissent bien mieux que beaucoup je
rentre dans le détail très concret c'est
la vie des gens alleer dans l'odomarois
que j' voé dans le calisi dans le derqua
les gens ils savent très bien ce qu'il
faut faire pour les plus anciens ou ceux
qui étaient les travaux à faire sur le
port les investissement à faire sur
certaines digues Comment curer certains
rues ou ailleurs comment améliorer le
système des wateritinges ou les pompes
et cetera c'est ce qu'on va faire mais
plus largement on va avoir une
adaptation de nos paysages de nos villes
pour faire face à tout cela on aura une
adaptation aussi dans le grand Ouest qui
vit déjà le décalage du trait de côte en
région nouvellequitaine vous avez déjà
aujourd'hui des gens qui aujourd'hui en
effet ont leur leur maison parfois leur
entreprise qui est bousculée par le
recul du trait de côte adaptation donc
on sera là pour accompagner c'est un
investissement de la nation c'est un
changement de beaucoup de nos habitudes
mais on sera là et je veux avoir une
approche optimiste
elle est pas naïve c'est un
investissement qu'on a déjà commencé à
faire on va l'accélérer mais par du bon
sens la simplification de certaines
normes l'innovation qu'on va déployer
sur le terrain grâce à nos paysagistes
grâce à de l'innovation industrielle
grâce à certains investissements on
adaptera nos territoires en France
hexagonale comme ultramarine à
l'évolution des
risques bonsoir monsieur le Président
Benjamin duamel pour pour BFM TV en 2017
le soir de votre élection vous disiez
vouloir je cite tout faire pour qu'il
n'y ait plus aucune raison de voter pour
les extrêmes et pourtant la liste menée
par Jordan Bardella est en tête de tous
les sondages pour les élections
européenne Marine Le Pen et Jordan
Bardella s'imaginent carrément déjà se
partageant les rôles l'une à votre place
à l'Élysée l'autre à Matignon quelle
part de responsabilité prenez-vous dans
cette progression n'est-ce pas un aveu
d'échec quant à 2027 ne craignez-vous
pas de voir votre héritage politique
totalement entaché si dans 3 ans et demi
vous laissez les clés de l'Élysée à
Marine Le Pen
d'abord les ambitions que vous prêtez
aux responsables politiques évoqués sont
pas une nouveauté
il m'a semblé que lors des deux
dernières campagnes présidentielles
intéressés se voyent au même endroit me
félicite d'avoir pu empêcher cette
opération et je ferai tout pour le
continuer parce que je pense que c'est
bon pour le pays ensuite je regarde
autour de nous dans toutes les
démocraties européenne y compris chez
nos voisins allemands où on pensait
impossible le retour de l'extrême droite
elle est là donc je pense qu'il faut pas
le voir simplement avec nos yeux
franco-français quelque chose se
passe moi je pense qu'il faut pour
éviter le retour des extrêmes en
particulier de l'extrême droite
s'attaquer à ce qui fait voter pour eux
la première chose c'était le chômage de
masse c'était une SP spécificité
française nous étionsans à coup sûr la
plus la grande économie qui n'avait pas
réussi à endiguer celui-ci on est en
train de le faire et on va continuer la
désindustrialisation on le voyait dans
nos territoires de l'Est comme du Nord
avait beaucoup nourr le Rassemblement
National Front national nager on est en
train d'y répondre on améliore
d'ailleurs les choses dans ces
territoirees
est-ce que c'est suffisant
non deuxème élément
l'immigration lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine c'est je pense
une des réponses au rassemblement
national c'est pourquoi j'assume
totalement la politique au niveau
européen et français qu'on a mené pas de
naïveté mais le faire dans le cadre de
notre République nos
principes ce que je défends mais il faut
s'attaquer à ça qui dans certaines
régions nourrit puis la troisème chose
qui je pense les nourrit c'est une forme
de sentiment de
dépossession beaucoup de nos
compatriotes se disent au fond le pays
marche plus on a tout essayé on les a
pas essayé et ma crainte et ce contre
quoi je me bat parce que je suis pas là
pour craindre vous me
direz c'est que tout le monde s'habitue
à ça et plus personne ne dit que le
rassemblement national comme toutes les
extrêmes droites en Europe c'est surtout
et avant tout le pays de
l'appauvrissement collectif c'est le
pays c'est pays c'est le partie de
partie du mensonge et ça le continue de
l'être c'est c'est le parti qui a le
programme qui l'a complètement piqué à
l'extrême gauche c'est parti qui
continue à vous expliquer que la
retraite à 60 ans est possible sans vous
expliquer comment la financer parti qui
vous explique qu'il faut augmenter le
SMIC sans vous expliquer comment ça
désindustrialisera pas le pays c'est le
parti qui continue de vous expliquer des
choses impossibles sur le plan
économique et social pour
affaiblir si on s'attaque pas pied à
pied à l'incohérence de leur programme
les gens se disent disent des trucs
faciles l'opposition c'est beaucoup plus
facile que le gouvernement
donc aller au réel sur ce qu' propose et
ça c'est notre responsabilité collective
pas que la mienne seu mais tant qu'on
continuera avoir un discours politique
qui parfois est
déréalisé populaire de faire une réforme
des retit l'assurance chôage mais
continueer voir les gens trve c'est
formidable une réponse politique de le
dire on va continuer de vous aider onite
à 60 ans tout va bien passer 62 ans
maintenant la deè chose c'est parti du
transformisme c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 6
ans et demi éit pour sortir de l'Europe
et de l'euro et maintenant il est pour y
rester mais pour ne plus en respecter
les traités comme l'extrême gauche même
programme c'est le frexit caché c'est
l'appauvrissement de la France aussi
c'est des gens qui vous disent je suis
plus trop sûr de vouloir sortir de
l'euro et de l'Europe comme n guerre
mais enfin nous on respectera pas les
traités avec nous rassurez-vous mais
c'est quoi vous pensez que vous
connaissez vous descopropriétés où on
continue à vous payer l'eau et le gaz
mais vous respectez rien c'est ça leur
programme faut le dire faut se battre et
dans un monde en bascule comme je viens
de l'évoquer face à la Chine au
États-Unis d'Amérique vous pensez qu'
une France toute seule dans une Europe
affaiblie c'est une bonne chose c'est ça
le programme de rassemblement national
mais si tout le monde s'habitue en
disant ils sont devenus sympathiques en
fait ils disent plus des choses qui nous
heurtent parce qu'on sait plus trop ce
qu'ils disent moi je vois le débat
public c'est plus trop ce qu'ils disent
enfin ils sont contre ce que fait le
gouvernement ça l'air
sympa
là à ce moment-là on rentre dans un une
forme de zone de danger qu'on voit dans
tous les pays européens parce qu'on ne
se bat plus P à pied sur ce qui est la
réalité nos principes c'est pour ça que
moi
j'assume de continuer à présider au réel
avec un certain sens de l'idéal et dire
quand les gens ont un problème on essaie
de le résoudre au concret au réel qu'on
essaie de tendre le coup au mensonge
qu'on a besoin en effet d'une France
plus forte et plus juste mais qui
s'appuie sur des réalités d'une
politique économique qui a des résultats
parce qu'elle a un sens et une cohérence
que ne propose pas le rassemblement
national d'une politique écologique qui
a un sens et une cohérence parce qu'elle
est compatible avec la création d'emploi
d'une politique d'ordre républicain
juste et ferme et qui respecte not traté
et notre Constitution c'est tout
l'inverse du rassemblement national donc
on va continuer de se battre mais je
vois partout en Europe celui-ci qui
monte par une forme de fascination du
désastre mais par un affaiblissement du
débat collectif parce qu'on oublie tous
de revenir au réel et à la réalité leurs
arguments et là on va avoir un vrai
débat
européen je suis pas heureux de les voir
en tête des sondages parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup fait pour qu'on soit plus fort
nous Français en Europe depuis 5 ans et
que notre Europe a beaucoup avancé mais
rassurez-vous l'Europe du rassemblement
national c'est pas celle qui vous
permettra d'avoir les vaccins or je le
rappelle pendant la crise covid on a eu
des vaccins dans notre pays parce qu'il
y avait l'Europe on a pu faire un plan
de relance parce qu'il y avait l'Europe
on peut aujourd'hui peser face à la ch
aux États-Unis d'Amérique parce qu'il y
a l'Europe parce qu'il y a une europeope
qui porte nos valeurs où on sa'est
poussé nos projets et notre ambition
mais parce qu'elle est là c'est
l'inverse de ce que porte le
rassemblement national et au fond
rassemblement national est devenu le
parti de la colère
facile Dieu on n'a pas tout essayé ça
paraît
sympathique ne nous habituons pas
agissons faisons bousculons les choses
et les habitudes pour montrer qu'en
effet ce bloc central qui rassemble les
démocrates les républicains les
écologistes qui croient dans l'Europe
peut agir et changer les choses et le
quotidien des gens ayons parfois
l'honnêteté de dire quand ça marche la
lucidité de dire quand ça marche pas et
avançons c'est ça pour moi la bonne
réponse je me battrai jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure je me suis toujours battu
comme ça pas avec des leçons de morale
en regardant le pays tel qu'il est en
essayant de convaincre avec des
arguments des actions et du réel c'est
ça le meilleur
moyen d'éviter les extrêmes et j'y crois
si vous laiss la place mais jeis pas de
politique fiction j'en ai jamais fait
j'en ai jamais fait en campagne je pas
en faire ici savez j'ai compris qu'il
avit beaucoup de gens qui s'énervai sur
2027 enfin j'ai quand même compris aussi
qu'il me restait 3 ans et demi à
présider
et fort des 6 ans et demi que je viens
de vivre il se passe beaucoup de choses
en 3 ans et demi beaucoup de
choses monsieur le Président de la
République bonsoir Olivier baumon du
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France la
question de Benjamin duamel me laisse à
penser que nous venons de basculer dans
la partie plus politique de cette soirée
euh j'aimerais revenir du coup sur la
nomination de votre nouveau gouvernement
nous avons eu quelques surprises tout
d'abord celle de Gabriel Attal nommée
comme premier ministre et puis le retour
d'une figure sarkoziste Rach dadati qui
avait appartenu au gouvernement il y a
une dizaine d'années plusieurs questions
me viennent en tête tout d'abord
pourquoi le choix de de cette
personnalité à ce ministère là deuxième
chose qu'est-ce qui a changé entre 2017
et aujourd'hui en 2017 François baerou
qui avait été mis en examen avait dû
quitter le gouvernement rachti est
aujourd'hui mise en examen elle vient
d'être nommée au gouvernement et enfin
dernière question le sujet de Paris on
laisse à penser qu'il y aurait eu un
deal entre elle et vous concernant les
élections municipales en 2027 dans la
capitale merci de nous apporter quelques
éclaircissements merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'abord je vais i red dire les
choses très
clairement François baayrou a pris la
décision de démissionner je ne lui ai
pas demandé en 2017 il était garde des
sauts j'ai eu ensuite plusieurs
ministres durant mon premier mandat qui
ont été mis en examen et euh en effet
ministre de la Culture l' dans une
affaire dont je n'ai pas à connaître et
au fond je me suis appuyé sur un
changement des règles simple et aussi en
regardant l'évolution de notre vie
politique et judiciaire depuis 10
maintenant dans notre pays il n'y a plus
d'instruction individuelle sur les
dossiers il y avait une vieille
jurisprudence qui exista dans notre pays
qui fait qu'en effet quand un ministre
éta mis en examen il devait quitter la
table du Conseil parce qu'il avait un de
ses collègues qui pouvait donner une
instruction individuelle au
parquet c'est interdit maintenant il n'y
en a plus qui
plus tous les membres du parquet que
j'ai eu à nommer depuis que je suis
président comme le faisait d'ailleurs
mon
prédécesseur l' été conformément au avis
du
CSM donc oui ce faisant il y a pas de
règle qui fait qu'un ministre mise en
examen devrait quitter parce que sinon
en quelque sorte je reconnaîtrai moins
un responsable politique la présempption
d'innocence qu'à d'autrre il se trouve
que d'ailleurs j'ai pu avoir des
ministres mis en examen qui ensuite ont
été innocentés je m'en félicite pour eux
ce qui montre plutôt que c'est assez
juste donc la justice va faire son
travail avec sérénité à son rythme mais
je considère qu'il y a pas de changement
de règle il y a juste là aussi une forme
de bon sens pour le rest
j'ai proposé avec le Premier ministre à
madame Rachida Dati de devenir ministre
de la Culture parce que son énergie son
talent sa liberté parce qu'elle ne se
réduit pas à une appartenance
politique je crois seront util à la
culture à ouvrir des portes et à
permettre au fond de mettre fin je le
disais c'est pour moi un de mes grands
objectifs à cette France du s'est pas
fait pour
moi faut lutter contre
celle-ci nous n'avons pas parlé de Paris
vous aurez du mal à me croire quand je
vous dis ça mais c'est
vrai la seule chose que je veux pour
Paris c'est qu'un électeur puisse avoir
les mêmes droits et compter autant à
Paris qu'à à men à Besançon ou ailleurs
et donc que le gouvernement et le
Parlement puissent décider d'une réforme
en profondeur de la loi Paris
lion-mseille pour revenir au droit
ça je pense que c'est la bonne chose
c'est la seule chose qui me concerne
pour Paris le reste je sais qu'elle
mettra son talent son énergie et tout le
reste au service de la culture de ceux
qui la servent et de ceux qui veulent
aussi y avoir
droit monsieur le Président ah ici
Rachel gara Valcarcel pour 20 minutes
vous nous avez parlé de l'ordre avec
l'uniforme à l'école une politique
contre la drogue alors que certains
disent que la prohibition ne ne
fonctionne pas vous nous avez parlé de
politique nataliste de cérémonies de
remise des diplômes est-ce que le
gouvernement le plus jeune avec le
président le plus jeune ne vont pas
mener une politique anachronique voir si
vous me permettez un peu vieux jeux en
quoi ces vieux
jeux cérémonie de remise des diplômes
uniformes est-ce que ce sont pas des
vieux débats je vois tous nos jeunes qui
regardent les séries télévisées où il y
a ces remise de diplôme il trouvent ça
super je vois qu'on retrouve des rites
quand la République perd ses
rites d'autres rites sont inventés moi
je crois pas du tout que le symbolique
soit vieux jeu je crois pas du je vais
vous
dire je je l'expliquer tout à l'heure en
disant ce qui a fait notre pays c'est
l'ordre et le progrès je crois qu'il y a
pas de progrès sans ordre et pour le
coup là on est vieux jeux s'il y a que
l'ordre et pas le progrès je crois à une
autorité juste et une émancipation nos
sociétés sont devenues un peu
liquide et donc faut redonner des
repères des repères par par les savoirs
qu'on transmet par l'histoire qu'on
transmet par les valeurs qu'on transmet
pourut donner des rendez-vous des Caps
de passage la fin du primaire le brevet
des collèges le baccalauréat les
diplomations c'est pas vieux jeu du tout
croyez-moi parce que si on passe dans la
vie comme ça comme entre des courants
tout le monde est perdu et moi je trouve
que beaucoup de gens sont perdus en vrai
et ça rend pas les gens
heureux et tout ça pour moi n'est pas du
tout l'ennemi de l'audace
créatrice là aussi je crois pardon de le
Red dire comme ça parce qu'on m'en a
beaucoup targué à en même temps c'est
pas une
ambiguïé je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est une double
radicalité moi je crois au patrimoine ça
peut vous sembler vieux jeu et à la
création et parfois on peut marier l'un
et l'autre et donc la politique que je
vous ai décrite c'est vrai elle remet
parfois de l'ordre républicain une forme
d'autorité parce que je pense qu'on en a
besoin elle remet de l'éducation au cœur
et l'éducation c'est tout à la fois la
transmission de savoir
d'un héritage de et c'est aussi la
confiance qu'on vous donne qui va
ensuite vous permettre de créer et de
vous de vous en émanciper de vous
comporter
librement mais je crois que ce faisant
c'est c'est ça vraiment qui vous permet
d'avoir aussi l'esprit
critique l'absence de règles la liberté
absolue c'est pas la véritable liberté
il n'y a de liberté que si des
contraintes existent il n'y a de liberté
c'est des limites à celle-ci
existe il n a de véritable émancipation
que si un ordre existe je crois par
ailleurs que les réformes que je porte
sont aussi celles d'une société de
progrès ce qu'on a fait avec les lois
bioéthiques la PMA pour tout au premier
quinquena ce qu'on va faire avec la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ou avec
la fin de Villa sont des lois de progrès
qui montrent que c'est une société qui
change qu'on accompagne mais je crois
très profondément
que le progrès va aussi avec une forme
d'ordre républi
et si l'ordre n'est pas républicain le
risque que nous courons c'est parce que
nos compatriotes chercheront des repères
c'est que cet ordre devienne
réactionnaire regardez ce qui se passe
dans beaucoup de pays en Europe en
particulier face à des sociétés qui
doutent vous avez des dirigeants qui
transforment leur histoire qui disent
pas ce que je dis sur l'instruction
civique ou l'histoire qui la
réinvente qui ont une histoire glorieuse
moi je suis pour enseigner l'histoire
toute entière de la République aliste ce
serait vieux jeu si je vous disais je
vais réécrire l'histoire j'espère que je
me fais comprendre c'est c'est ça et
donc je pense oui qu'il faut qu'il faut
les deux en même temps résolument et
complètement et que c'est comme ça qu'on
pourra créer je le crois une jeunesse
mais aussi une
nation qui se connaît
elle-même qui se respecte qui sait d'où
elle vient et qui aura une vraie
ambition pour où elle va et avec des
espaces de contestation des libertés
individuelles des voix de progrès des
débats comme nous aimons en avoir sur
tous les sujets possibles
voilà monsieur le
Président bonjour Claire gaâtinois du
journal Le Monde monsieur le Président
vous défendez la justice sociale et la
lutte contre l'assignation à résidence
mais depuis l'adoption du projet de loi
immigration certains enfants d'immigrés
non européens seront précarisés puisque
leurs parents devront attendre un pour
toucher certaines prestations sociales
contrairement au français sur la base du
principe de la préférence nationale que
défend aussi l'extrême droite comment
tout la soutient quelle est la cohérence
de cette action merci d'abord je me
garderais bien de dire comme vous venez
de le faire que ça existe la loi a étaé
votée elle est soumise au Conseil
constitutionnel et j'aurai ensuite à
promulguer un texte qui sera corriger de
ces censures éventuelles aujourd'hui ce
que vous décrivez n'est pas ensuite je
me garderai bien aussi de faire des
raccourcis avec le rassemblement
national sur ce que en reprenant ces
termees vous appelez la préférence
nationale mais l'accès à des prestations
dans notre pays il est déjà conditionné
à des
durées il est déjà conditionné à des
durées aujourd'hui il faut 5 ans pour
toucher le RSA ou la prime
d'activité et il y a beaucoup d'autres
prestations contributives ou non
contributiv où il y a des délais faut
que tout ça se fasse dans les règles
est-ce que c'était un de la majorité du
gouvernement la réponse est non est-ce
que c'était poussé par des oppositions
la réponse est oui est-ce que ça a été
mis dans la balance d'un compromis qu'il
fallait dans une majorité relative pour
avancer oui est-ce que je pense qu'il
fallait avoir un accord sur ce texte oui
on va attendre d'abord qu'il soit soumis
au contrôle constitutionnel on en
parlera après mais ce que vous dites est
faux dans les termes aujourd'hui dans
notre pays il y a des
délais de résidence parfois de travail
pour avoir accès à des prestations il
compris au quotidien et est-ce que c'est
injuste ma réponse non c'est pas
toujours aberrent parce que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir une démocratie avec un
modèle social aussi généreux que le
nôtre qui ne conditionne pas à certaines
règles l'accès aux prestations parce que
sinon vous n'aurez plus de consensus
social parce que sinon les gens vous
diront pour certaines prestations ben
moi je suis citoyen français je respecte
toutes les règles parfois moi j'ai
travaillé je les finances et donc
quionque rendre sur le sol il a accès ça
marche pas reconnaîtraz avec moi
donc là aussi il faut savoir faire les
choses de manière très méthodique loin
des passions ce que défend le
rassemblement national c'est pas ça il
défend la déscolarisation des enfants
plutôt l'école le non accès à l'école de
manière systématique pour les enfants de
personnees en situation irrégulière on
le fait pas on continue de scolariser
les enfants et c'est une fierté de la
République il défend des contraintes en
matière de logement on na jamais au
moment où je vous parle oui je défends
la justice sociale je vais vous dire il
fait froid en ce moment
l'hébergement
d'urgence on est passé à 200000 places
aujourd'hui quand j'ai été élu on était
à 93000 places si c'est pas de la
justice 60 % de cet effort il est fait
pour des familles et des femmes et des
hommes qui sont en attente de
régularisation ou en situation
irrégulière donc on va continuer de se
battre mais on va le faire avec des
règles et Front national comme je
préfère continuer à l'appeler il propose
quoi la férence sur des emplois à des
Français et des règles plus simples pour
licencier des étrangers est-ce que c'est
ce qu'on fait non donc si on confond
tout après on me les banalise après on
dit tout est un tout tout se vaut non
oui je revendique de lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine sur notre
territoire c'est une nécessité oui je
revendique de pouvoir démler les réseaux
de passeurs oui je revendique de pouvoir
simplifier les règles pour qu'on puisse
plus vite instruire les dossiers
protéger ceux qui ont être là parce
qu'ils sont chercheurs et étudiants
combattants pour la liberté mais aussi
pouvoir reconduire vers leur pays ceux
qui sont rentrés par des voies illégales
et qui n'ont pas resté sur notre sol ça
c'est pas être du rassemblement national
parce que si vous laissez ça au
rassemblement national je peux vous dire
là vous lui paverez la
route bonsoir monsieur le Président
Adrien becck France Info on a assez peu
finalement parler de de démocratie des
sujets de renouveau démocratiqu ce soir
il y a toujours ce sujet qui revient de
la démocratie directe et depuis votre
arrivée au pouvoir depuis 2017 vous
n'avez pas utilisé l'outil
constitutionnel du référendum vous
l'avez souvent évoqué encore au l'été
dernier chez nos confrères du point vous
aviez dit je compte bien l'utiliser on
est toujours sans nouvelle de de cette
question de de référendum donc
finalement alors que cela fera 20 ans
l'année prochaine qu'aucun référendum
n'a été pratiqué en France est-ce que
vous allez faire un référendum ou est-ce
que vous avez c'est ce que suggéreront
certains peur peut-être de de cette
démocratie directe et par ailleurs
est-ce qu'il vous serait possible ou
est-ce que vous
jugeriez possible et pertinent de faire
un référendum avec peut-être plusieurs
questions c'est ce que certains évoquent
je vous remercie merci pour votre
question vous avez raison j'évoqué
rapidement au début que les institutions
ne seraient pas traitées mais le
renouveau de la vie démocratique est
importante on a beaucoup
innové un grand débat qui n'avait pas
précédent des conventions citoyennes qui
ont permis une loi climat et maintenant
la préparation de la loi pour la fin de
vie une réforme du Conseil économique
social environnemental qui l'a
complètement transformé en a fait
d'ailleurs la chambre de ces conventions
citoyennes et d'une forme de
consultation nouvelle on a beaucoup
modernisé à cet égard notre démocratie
et on a eu un débat dans le format dit
de Saint- j'ai rassembler les forces
politiques sur la base d'une proposition
qui était faite d'élargir le champ du
référendum j'ai tôt vu à la consultation
des forces politiques qui avaient pas de
consensus pour faire cheminer cette
proposition et l'ouvrir à des questions
sociétales comme je l'avais moi-même
proposé en 2019 la question c'est
maintenant l'usage du référendum tel
qu'il est prévu par notre Constitution
dans le champ de l'article 11 oui je le
ferai j'ai pas d'annonce aujourd'hui sur
le sujet sinon je l'aurais faite mais je
pense que c'est une bonne chose et
j'aurais même souhaité pour tout vous
dire l'ouvrir aux questions sociétales
mais le consensus n'est pas là pour le
faire monsieur le Président Francesco
fonti pour l'agence France presse vous
avez fait de l'école la mè des batailles
et vous avez encore annoncé plusieurs
mesures ce soir et plusieurs chantiers
peuvent-ils être menés à bien par la
nouvelle ministre de l'Éducation Amélie
oua Castera qui est affaiblie d'entrée
de jeu par une intense polémique à
laquelle il a été fait référence et
a-t-elle votre confiance pour continuer
dans ses fonctions merci merci pour
votre question oui
d'abord la ministre a fait un choix pour
ses
enfants ce sont des choix individuels
personnel je le disais il faut les
respecter et je trouve que c'est bien et
je pense que tous nos compatriotes
d'ailleurs iront dans ce sens et et je
pense que ça fait partie de la vie
intime familiale que beaucoup d'ailleurs
qui sont indignes parfois le font pour
leurs propres enfants
eux-mêmes et j'ai pas rentré là-dedans
moi je le respecte et je l'ai dit moi
j'ai été dans les deux écoles je
relisais d'ailleurs un texte de Jean
jores qui avait eu à subir en 1901 une
polémique absolument terrible parce
qu'il avait fait faire la communion à sa
fille et il avait avec beaucoup
d'humilité dit je pas mieux qu'un autre
ces débats qui sont ceux de chaque
citoyen individuel et personnel ensuite
la ministre a eu un propos public qui a
été maladroit elle s'en est excusé elle
a bien fait je vais vous dire j'ai
plutôt de l'indulgence parce qu'il m'est
arrivé d'avoir des propos au tout début
de mes responsabilités politiques qui
avaient blessé tout particulièrement des
femmes dans une entreprise du Grand
Ouest et quand on blesse surtout sans
s'en rendre compte on a raison de
s'excuser moi je pense que il y a pas
d'école qui tiennent si on n pas tous
nos enseignants avec nous il faut un
travail remarquable et j'ai l'occasion
de le dire il travaillent d'arrachepied
pour préparer leurs cours corriger leur
copies et devant les élèves continuer
d'innover et donc la ministre réussira à
sa tâche avec les enseignants après elle
a soulevé un sujet qui est un sujet
véritable votre collègue l'a rappelé et
ce sera une des priorités qu'elle aura
conduite à conduire dans le droitfil de
ce que le premier ministre avait encore
à faire il y a quelques
semaines
bonsoir monsieur le président Frédéric
Aziza de Radio J que pouvez-vous nous
dire de l'opération d'acheminement des
médicaments vers les otages du ramas euh
quel a été votre rôle et celui de de la
France et puis avez-vous des nouvelles
des trois otages français enfin vous
avez annoncé qu'un hommage national
serait rendu aux 41 victimes françaises
des massacres du ramas du 7 octobre
êtes-vous en mesure de nous en préciser
la date et aussi la forme que pourrait
prendre cet
hommage merci pour votre question vous
avez d'abord raison de rappeler que la
France a perdu 41 de ses enfants dans
les attaque terroriste du 7 octobre
dernier ce qui fait de ces
attaques l'acte terroriste le plus
meurtrier
depis le 7 février prochain
au monument pour les victimes du
terrorisme jardin des Invalides je
rendrai hommage à ces victimes au côté
de leurs proches de leur famille et de
tous ceux qui voudront nous y rejoindre
ce sera 4 mois jour pour jour après
l'attaque
terroriste nous avons libéré quatre
otages nous avons encore trois otages
qui sont détenus et nous nous battons
pied à
pied avec les autorités israéliennes
avec le Qatar qui a un rôle décisif en
la matière
avec aussi plusieurs autres collègues
pour les libérer je ne veux ici faire
aucune annonce parce que ces matières
sont toujours délicates et je pense
aussi aux familles
mais nous nous battons nous ne lâcherons
rien et j'espère que les prochains jours
prochaines semaines nous
permettront d'obtenir leur libération en
tout cas nous voulons tous les ramener
chez
nous ensuite cette attaque terroriste a
déclenché action d'Israël et des
bombardements sent trêv depuis
maintenant plus de 100
jours en particulier sur la bande de
Gaza sur ce sujet peut-être reviendraije
si d'autres questions il sont posées la
France a une une approche qui depuis le
début a été de condamner de manière
intraitable l'attaque terroriste d'avoir
au fond une réponse qui est la paix et
la sécurité pour tous lutter contre le
terrorisme l'approche humanitaire ce qui
nous a conduit à des aides humanitaires
et à une demande de de cesser le feu et
la solution politique des deux états
pour ce qui est de l'humanitaire qui est
votre question nous avons mené une
action résolue et je dois le dire
inédite pour un pays
occidental depuis le début d'abord en
déployant des militaires et tout des
moyens militaires et tout
particulièrement le Dixmude qui restera
jusqu'à la fin du mois et qui a déjà
permis de soigner plus de 1000 patients
enfants adultes avec un dévouement
extraordinaire des médecins qui sont
présents qui se sont relayés sur
celui-ci une coopération exemplaire avec
l'Égypte nous avons plus de 1000 tonnes
de fretes de soutien d'aide y compris de
médicaments qui ont été
livrés et nous avons en effet ces
dernières semaine mis en place des
opérations très délicates pour livrer de
l'aide dans la bande de Gaza même le 3
janvier dernier nous avons avec les
Jordaniens mené une opération pour
larguer justement des rations
alimentaires sur la bande de Gaza et
nous sommes en train d'agir nous avons
commencé à agir avec le Qatar pour en
effet délivrer des médicaments dans la
bande de Gaza et nous continuerons de le
faire avec tous les partenaires de la
région qui nous aide pour cette action
humanitaire qui a beaucoup mobilisé à la
fois nos militaires nos diplomates et
sur lesquell nous travaillons aussi avec
beaucoup d'associations et d'ONG qui
sont absolument exemplaires dans cette
action avaD jamidi magazine l bonsoir
monsieur le Président une dernière
question si vous le permettez pour clore
la séquence de de politique intérieure
vous avez implicitement évoqué le rôle
des femmes dans le cadre du réarmement
démographique que vous appelez de vos
vœux depuis 2017 l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes fait partie des
grandes causes de votre quinquena c'est
un axe fort de votre politique
d'ailleurs la parité est atteinte dans
le gouvernement de votre premier
ministre mais pourquoi n'y a-t-il aucune
femme à la tête d'un d'un ministère
régalien deuxième question la révolution
Mitou a permis d'aider à une prise de
conscience contre les attitudes
prédatrices de certains hommes une
révolution initiée par les médias qui
sont fait ni pour se substituer à la
justice mais pour dénoncer des
desagissements
répréhensibles ces attitudes odieuses
comme celle mise à jour par les images
de nos confrères de complément d'enquête
sur Gérard de par Dieu est-ce que vous
comprenez monsieur le Président les mois
provoqués par vos propos sur la fierté
que vous inspire une telle personnalité
est-ce que la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes reste une priorité
de votre mandat merci beaucoup merci de
m'offrir là
l'opportunité de clarifier ce sujet
essentiel bon d'abord le gouvernement
est paritaire vous l'avez dit et il sera
complété ensite et continuera d'être
paritaire et il y a eu depuis le début
de mes responsabilités des moments où il
y avait plus de
femme qui était dans le carré régalien
d'autrre moment où c'était à des
fonctions qui sont clé quand j'ai
martelé que la santé l'école et
l'enseignement supérieur étaient au cœur
de mes priorités comme politique
publique je constate que vous avez une
femme ministre de la Santé du travail et
des solidarités une femme ministre de
l'éducation nationale et des Jos une
femme ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche voilà et
c'est aussi une forme de nouveau
régalien je
l'assume donc n'y voyez pas là malice ou
retrait bien au contraire il y a eu
beaucoup de polémiques ces dernières
semaines ça ne m'a pas échappé je me
permettrai toutefois de
dire que je me souviens d'octobre
2016 c'était la conclusion de ce qu'on
avait appelé la grande marche j'étais
alors pas encore candidat simplement
ministre
démissionnaire c'était le début d'une
longue série de commentaires politiques
où l'on me disait que je n'avais pas de
programme ça a duré très
longtemps et faisant le contre-rendu de
cette grande marche je disais la
première préoccupation ce sont les
violences faites aux femmes en
particulier dans les transports j'ai pas
attendu Mitou et j'ai eu le regard
sceptique de beaucoup de gens et
beaucoup de commentateurs
aujourd'hui disant c'est vraiment un
drôle lui c'est ça sa
priorité les archives sont là pour le
montrer allez aussi les chercher
celle-là donc moi j'assume de pas avoir
attendu Mitou pour dire l'égalité femmes
hommes et les violences faites aux
femmes c'est un problème inadmissible et
parfois un continent caché et j'assume
en effet depuis 6 ans et demi d'avoir
agi avec beaucoup de force et je vais
vous dire je n'ai aucun regret d'avoir
défendu la présomption d'innocence pour
une personnalité publique un artiste en
l'espèce comme je l'ai fait pour des
responsables politiques si j'ai un
regret à ce moment-là c'est de ne pas
avoir assez dit combien la parole des
femmes qui sont victimes de ces
violences est importante et combien ce
combat est essentiel pour moi et nous
continuerons l'action mais on a agi on a
multiplié comme jamais les crédits aux
association qui qui se développe sur le
terrain on a multiplié par 2 et demi les
ordonnances de protection on a développé
plus de 1000 bracelets qui sont offerts
et qui protègent chaque jour des femmes
on a facilité le moyen de dénoncer les
conjoints ou mari
violent on a formé tous nos policiers
nos gendarmes qui étaient en école au
total 140000 X sont formés pour prendre
les plaintes ce qui était pas du tout le
cas avant on a développé ces téléphones
grave danger qui sont si importants les
places d'hébergement sont passés de 5000
à 10000 de 5000 à 10000 le 3919 si
important pour toutes les femmes qui
sont victimes de ces violence a eu des
moyens accrus comme jamais et passé 7
jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24 et
encore et encore je pourrait
continuer depuis le premier jour et même
avant comme je le rappelais le sujet des
violences faites aux femmes femme
est une priorité nous continuerons de
nous battre contre ce phénomène de
société il y a eu des tas de milieux où
en effet l'omerta a prévalu et je me
félicite que la parole se libère et je
souhaite qu'elle puisse se libérer au
maximum mais je pense que notre rôle
c'est de permettre son cadre c'est que
la justice puisse faire son travail
c'est qu'on protège les femmes qui sont
menacé mais que là aussi on ne le fasse
pas en oubliant les principes
constitutionnels qui sont les nôtres
dans la présomption
d'innocence monsieur le Président
bonsoir Ulis Gosset de BFM TV vous nous
avez dit au début de votre conférence de
presse la France est menacée et vous
avez confié à vos ministres lors de la
première réunion du Conseil la mission
de tout faire pour éviter l'effacement
de la France alors quelle est la
principale menace pour la France
aujourd'hui dans le monde est-ce que
c'est un risque de guerre est-ce que
c'est un risque de guerre en Europe si
Poutine allait plus loin que l'Ukraine
par exemple est-ce que c'est un risque
de guerre au Proche Orient est-ce qu'il
y a effectivement un risque d'effacement
de la France et comment y faire face et
puis un exemple concret Trump pourrait
revenir à la Maison Blanche est-ce que
c'est une menace est-ce que Donald Trump
est une menace pour l'Europe la France
l'Alliance atlantique pour la stabilité
du monde et est-ce que vous vous y
préparez et comment merci d'abord je
crois pas du tout qu'il y a un risque
d'effacement pour notre pays pas
utiliser ce terme pour eu les ministres
et je je correspond pas à la réalité je
suis pas dans le pessimisme la réalité
c'est que nous avons un monde qui est
déréglé et ça il faut le constater il se
dérègle pourquoi d'abord parce qu'il y a
une tension cino-américaine qui est
structurante et donc nous avons un
risque d'être bousculé nous européens
c'est pourquoi je veux une Europe plus
forte parce que c'est pas la France
seule qui pourra résister à cette
tension il faut une Europe plus
souveraine c'est-à-dire qui assume
d'avoir un allié les États-Unis
d'Amérique mais qui ne veut pas en
dépendre et donc nous nous devons être
en quelque sorte le troisème pôle de
stabilité qui aura à vivre avec
peut-être des tensions qui vont monter
mais ne pas être déstabilisé par elle et
rester dans des équilibres du monde
c'est toujours la voie sur laquelle j'ai
inscrit la France qui correspond
d'ailleurs à son histoire diplomatique
parler à tout le monde avoir des alliés
chercher des alliances être une
puissance qui construit des équilibres
et des solution nouvell et qui en
particulier évite cette grande division
du Nord face au sud qui serait terrible
mais cette tension est structurante la
deuxième chose c'est que vous avez des
membres du Conseil de sécurité qui ont
décidé de ne plus respecter la Charte
des Nations Unies la Russie et ça c'est
un fait nouveau des 10 dernières années
il a commencé en février 2014 ça change
tout et ça fait dysfonctionner l'ordre
international que nous connaissions et
donc nous devons rebâtir des règles àhoc
c'est ce que la France d'ailleurs
cherche à faire avec le partenariat
justement et le le pacte de Paris pour
les peuples et la planète c'est-à-dire
trouver des réponses sur ces grands
biens communs avec avec les pays du Sud
bousculer les lignes pour éviter
justement cette grande
division pour ça il faut une diplomatie
forte qui parle à tout le monde qui
refuse l'alignement
systématique il faut une économie forte
française et européenne qui ne dépend
pas financièrement technologiquement
académiquement sur telle ou telle
solution ni de la Chine ni des
États-Unis il faut une armée forte et un
modèle complet armée qu'on renforce sur
le plan des capacités qui innve et qui
robuste c'est notre cas et avec les deux
lois de programmation militaire qui
onont doublé le budget de nos armées ce
sera conforté et il faut une Europe
forte qui refuse la logique de
bloc et qui peut nous permettre en
quelque sorte de faire face à des
déséquilibres nouveaux le plus grand
risque à mes yeux et la guerre
d'agression russe en
Ukraine nous ne pouvons pas laisser la
Russie gagner et nous ne devons pas le
faire car alors la sécurité même de
l'Europe et de tout le voisinage russe
serait remise en cause laisser la Russie
gagner c'est au fond accepter que les
règles de l'ordre
international tel que nous les avons
définis peuvent ne plus être
respectés pour nos amis baltes polonais
roumains c'est une vie impossible je
n'oublie pas la Moldavie et aussi les
pays du
et donc nous devons tout faire c'est le
principal sujet à mes yeux de
mobilisation et sur lequel le risque est
là
ensuite les électeurs américains auront
à se décider en fin d'année j'ai
toujours eu la même philosophie je
prends les dirigeentss que les peuples
me
donnent et j'engage au service de la
France et de ses intérêts le dialogue
avec quiconque j'ai eu à le faire avec
le président Trump pendant tout son
mandat durant mon premier
quinquena nous avons eu des résultats
nous avons pu faire ensemble des choses
importantes l'opération Hamilton le 13
avril 2018 qui a fait respecter notre
ligne rouge face au président
Poutine des opérations concrètes un
réengagement sur plusieurs sujets nous
avons eu des
échecs le
climat certaines
taxations mais plus largement je pense
qu'il ne faut pas s'intéresser aux
personnes il faut avoir la lucidité de
voir que les États-Unis d'Amérique sont
un grand allié dont nous célébrerons le
courage en particulier lors des
débarquements de Normandie en juin
prochain il partage nos valeurs mais
c'est une démocratie qui traverse aussi
une
crise dont la priorité première est
elle-même et dont la deuxième priorité
est la question chinoise et donc nous
devons tous européens être lucides sur
cela c'est aussi pour ça que je veux une
Europe plus forte qui sache se protéger
elle-même et qui ne dépende pas des
autres
c'est ça comme c'est la manière dont je
prépare l'élection
américaine quel que soit son
résultat
merci bonsoir monsieur le Président
sophieconomist vendredi dernier à Kiev
le Royaume-Uni a signé un avec l'Ukraine
un accord bilatéral de garantie de
sécurité conformément aux engagement
pris lors du sommet G7 Vilnius où on est
la France sur ce sujet et comment est-ce
que la France va contribuer dans dans
lesmédiat un
sursaut en matière d'aide militaire et
stratégique à l'Ukraine face à
l'agression russe merci merci beaucoup
nous travaillons très étroitement avec
tous nos partenaires européens et en
particulier nos partenaires britanniques
nous sommes en train de finaliser un
accord de ce type qui sera signé dans
les prochaine
semaine bilatéral permettant en effet
des éléments de
garantie nous allons procéder à des
livraisons nouvelles une quarantaine de
missilees scalp et plusieurs centaines
de bombes attendu par nos amis
Ukrainiens nous avons aussi développé
des productions dans ce casadre de
l'économie de guerre qui vont permettre
de fournir beaucoup plus de matériel à
nos partenaires Ukrainiens en
particulier des Césars qui sont attendu
et nécessaire et donc nous allons au
fond continuer d'aider l'Ukraine dans
ses
besoins de
formation pour tenir sur le front et
pour défendre son ciel avec les
livraisons que j'aiévoqué avec les
accords que nous finaliserons j'irai
moi-même en février en
Ukraine j'annoncerai la finalisation de
ces textes les livraisons de munition
que j'évoque là seront commencé et à
chaque fois que nous nous annonçons nous
faisons quasiment en temps réel comme
vous le savez
et nous aurons très clairement nous
Français et nous Européens à prendre des
décisions nouvelles dans les semaines et
les mois qui
viennent précisément pour ne pas laisser
la Russie
gagner bonjour monsieur le Président
Simon Lebaron pour France interre la
situation humanitaire et catastrophique
à Gaza des dizaines de milliers de morts
c'est difficile de savoir combien
exactement 25000 à peu près selon le
ministère de la Santé du Hamas est-ce
que vous estimez en faire assez pour
éviter cette situation humanitaire qui
est déjà
catastrophique d'abord vous avez raison
merci de me permettre de revenir sur sur
ce sujet ayant évoquer l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas contre Israël toutes
les vies se valent et nous sommes
bouleversés par aujourd'hui les vies qui
sont touchées à Gaza et qui sont en
quelque sorte la conséquence de cette
attaque terroriste du Hamas et la
responsabilité est immense de ce groupe
terroriste qui a déclenché cette
riposte je l'ai dit nous menons des
opérations
humanitair
multiples avec nos militaires avec nos
diplomates avec nos largages frit
médicaments vivre en périphérie et sur
la bande de Gaza mais la priorité est
cesser le feu j'ai quasiment chaque
semaine le Premier ministre netaniahou
en ligne nous réitérons cela avec
d'ailleurs plusieurs puissance de la
région les États-Unis d'Amérique l'ont
également fait et nous soutiennent dans
cette approche c'est une priorité
pourquoi parce que après plus de 100
jours ce sont maintenant des opérations
ciblées qui doivent être conduites et il
faut
concilier la défense d'Israël et la
poursuite des terroristes avec la
préservation du droit
humanitaire et je le dis parce que c'est
c'est aussi l'intérêt l'intérêt sur le
plan de la sécurité à long terme
d'Israël et que poursuivre aujourd'hui
les opérations telles qu'elles sont
conduite c'est prendre un risque compris
dans la durée comptetenue de ce que cela
fait nêre dans toute la région pour la
sécurité d'Israël même donc nous allons
poursuivre les initiatives diplomatiques
résolution discussions pour appeler à un
cesser le feu et je vais Mo poursuivre
le contact bilatéral pour essayer de
l'obtenir de manière très concrète c'est
ça maintenant la priorité car on sait
c'est ce qui permettra d'aller au
contact des populations de les protéger
et tout ça est lié à quoi à une
stratégie odieuse qui la stratégie du
pire celle utilisée par le Hamas qui met
ses réserves d'armes et ses centres de
décision sous les écoles caché dans les
hôpitaux qui utilise comme bouclier une
partie de la population civile mais au
point au moment où nous en sommes et la
France dit cela depuis plusieurs
semaines nous devons cesser ces attaques
qui sont par troupe indifférencié et
nous devons protéger les populations
civiles c'est un devoir humanitaire
parce qu'il peut pas y avoir de
standards et que toutes les vies se
valent donc on va poursuivre le travail
et je peux pas vous dire qu'on est
réussi aujourd'hui et que je m'en
considère comme satisfait je vois avec
la même douleur que vous les scènes que
nous voyons et je sais aussi ce que cela
produit dans chez beaucoup de nos
compatriotes et dans beaucoup de pays de
la région et je le disais nous nous
battons pour lutter contre les
terroriste nous nous battons pour le
cesser le feu et pour la réponse
humanitaire et nous nous battons pour
qu'il y ait une vraie réponse de dans la
durée à l'aspiration légitime du peuple
palestinien pour avoir un état parce que
c'est ça qui apportera la sécurité et la
stabilité dans la
durée et je ne voudrais pas que ce qui
est en train de se passer compromette la
possibilité d'une solution
politique euh bonsoir monsieur le
Président de la République husin knber
la chaîne Alarabia la France continuue
de passer des messages à toutes les
parties concernées par la la résolution
est 1701 euh la situation est très
tendue entre le Liban et Israël à la
frontière euh est-ce que ces partis à
qui vous passez ces messages ont été
réceptives et est-ce que l'embrasement
régional est toujours évitable d'après
vous avec tout ce qui se passe en mer
Rouge
merci merci à vous vous avez évoqué la
mer Rouge la France est active elle est
d'ailleurs depuis les premiers jours et
elle est historiquement toutes ces
dernières années pour
œuvrer à la liberté de circulation
maritime en mer rouge comme dans les
axes principaux essentiels au au
commerce
mondial à ce titre nous avons une
approche comme vous le savez qui est
défensive et nous assumons le cadre de
cette action pour ce qui est des
résolutions du Conseil de sécurité et au
fond de la frontière avec le Liban qui
est le fond de votre question nous avons
une très grande vigilance depuis le
début pour éviter que l'embrasement ne
soit régional que le hzbollah ne se
joigne les conflit et ne menace la
sécurité d'Israël et surtout que le
conflit ne s'étende au Liban la France
est attachée à la paix à la stabilité au
Liban et donc en effet nous avons depuis
le début passé des messages directs et
indirect à l'ensemble des forces
politiques
libanaises à l'ensemble des forces
militaires
compris
terroriste et nous avons tout fait pour
éviter
l'escalade nous avons fait plusieurs
propositions ces dernières semaines en
lien avec les États-Unis d'Amérique aux
Israéliens pour justement essayer
d'avancer sur ce sujet notre volonté est
en effet que les résolution soit
strictement respecté qu'en
particulier les frappes qui ont eu lieu
encore ces dernières semaines soit cessé
que les incursions quiil a pu avoir
soient interrompu mais que des deux
côtés la résolution soit respectée et
c'est indispensable comme vous le savez
la France est aussi engagée dans le
cadre de la finule et ce depuis
maintenant des décennies et donc nous
sommes vigilants aussi avec les Nations
unies pour que le mandat soit tenu que
les moyens soient engagés et que les
équilibres soient maintenu nous
surveillons avec beaucoup de vigilance
la situation et au fond notre message à
toutes les parties est d'éviter tout
escalade elles ne sont l'intérêt de
personne monsieur monsieur le Président
nous arrivons au terme de cet échange
nous allons devoir clore cette
conférence de presse dernière question
allez là j'ai pas
réussi je veux bien prendre une dernière
question puisqu'on m'a dit qu'il fallait
après rendre l'antenne comme on dit
bonsoir monsieur le Président c'est la
bouriillou pour TF1 LCI en quelques mots
en quelques mots vous avez beaucoup
parlé de réarmement mais pas encore de
réarmement militaire la loi de
programmation militaire nous pro nous
prémunit-elle pardon de toutes les
menaces la France n'aurait-elle pas
intérêt aujourd'hui à investir dans la
lutte contre les outils normalement
notamment pardon en mer Rouge est-ce
qu'ils sont une menace aujourd'hui pour
nous merci d'avance la France a décidé
de ne pas se joindre à une coalition qui
a cherché enfin qui a conduit des
frappes préventive contre les outils sur
leur sol pourquoi précisément parce que
nous avons une posture qui cherche à
éviter tout escalade mais nous sommes
présents pour préserver la liberté de
navigation et d'ailleurs nous avons
interrompu missiles et drones qui
allaient
frapper des navires norvégiens et donc
nous agissons pour protéger nos propres
équipements et les équipements de nos
alliés donc nous agissons mais le cadre
c'est pas un sujet militaire c'est un
sujet diplomatique et pourquoi nous le
faisons parce que nous sommes vigilants
et attentifs aux équilibres de la la
région et au fait qu'il ne doit pas y
avoir d'escalade
ensuite je peux vous confirmer que vous
avez une armée dont vous pouvez être
fier nous avons un modèle d'armée
complet qui n'a pas subi les
affaiblissements que plusieurs autres
armées européennes avaient pu faire
avait pu avoir et que nous avons surtout
renforcé très fortement je le disais par
une première loi de programmation
militaire qui a permis de consolider
beaucoup de chos et à hauteur d'homme
comme je l'ai dit pour avoir
davantageengagés les FID avoir des
familles qui sont mieux accompagné donc
les femmes et les hommes qui sont
d'abord la force de nos armées leurs
commandement mais également préserver
notre dissuasion nucléaire qui est une
force de l'armée française et avoir
aussi un réengagement dans toutes nos
capacités en volume comme en innovation
et c'est ce que nous allons poursuivre
avec cette deè cette deuxè loi de
programmation militaire qui a fait
l'objet d'un travail inédit conduit par
nos armées sous l'autorité du ministre
et du chef d'état-major des armées
qui a permis d'abord de voir quels
étaient les nouveaux risques qui a
consolidé notre modèle d'armée
historique d'aller plus vite sur les
capacités dont nous avions besoin de
consolider encore une fois notre
nucléaire mais aussi d'aller sur les
risques
cyber exoatmosphérique et donc le
spatial et maritime qui sont les grands
risques stratégiques du 21e siècle et
que les conflits que nous sommes en
train d'avoir ne doivent pas nous faire
oublier donc je pense pouvoir vous dire
en conscience que nous sommes équipés
nous sommes armés et nous le serons
encore davantage demain mais que nous
n'avons pas de faiblesse à cet égard et
que qui plus est ce qui fait le modèle
de la France y compris dans les
décisions d'engagement qui sont les
nôtres est une force car nous savons
engager vite quand la situation devient
difficile nous l'avons encore montré
quelle est l'armée qui s'est engagée en
quelques jours comme nous l'avons fait
en déployant nos forces en Roumanie
quelques jours à peine après le début de
la guerre en 2022 en Ukraine c'est une
une force maintenant nous devons la
compléter en développant une défense
européenne davantage de programmes
communs davantage d'investissement
standardiser nos grands programmes
industriels européens et en ayant une
culture
militaire plus intime avec nos
partenaires c'est tout le sens de
l'initiative européenne d'intervention
que j'avais lancé à la Sorbonne dans
laquelle vous avez maintenant une
dizaine d'États européens et où nous
avons agi par laquelle nous avons agi
ensemble en Afrique et ailleurs et ce
que nous allons continuer de faire
donc oui nous français européens nous
sommes solides nous serons encore plus
deain et nous serons vigilants à pousser
nos alliés et nos partenaires européens
à le faire et à l'être voilà mesdames et
messieurs merci pour vos questions vos
attentions m'a dit qu'il fallait que
j'essaie de tenir en 2 he écart et donc
j'espère avoir pu répondre aux questions
qui se posaient mais je vous rassure
vous me reverrez bientôt pour répondre
aux autres merci à tous et toutes et
encore tous mes
vœux pas une petite pH voilà pour cette
conférence de presse du Président de la
République que vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur les chaînes parlementaires on
est toujours avec Miriam awawa re
bonsoir myiam un grand plaisir de
présenter cette soirée bienvenue à à
toutes celles et ceux qui nous
rejoignent à l'instant 2h20 de
conférence de presse un peu plus de 25
minutes de propos liminire et beaucoup
de thématiques abordé on va y revenir
largement avec nos invités j'accueille
Valérie Boyer bonsoir bienvenue merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes sénatrice les républicains des
bouches du rô pierre Caseneuve bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi député
renaissance des hautes scènes et
porte-parool du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée deux parlementaires mais
aussi deux expertes sur ce plateau
bonsoir Anne Charlen Bezina ravie de
vous accueillir vous êtes
constitutionnaliste et Émilie pardon
zapatski zapalski qui est resté avec
nous vous êtes communicante et
fondatrice de l'agence Émilie conseil
une question ce soir assiste-ton au
moins dans la sémantique à une forme de
tournant conservateur d'Emmanuel Macron
je pense à la question du bon sens à la
tenue unique à la responsabilisation des
parents à la régulation des écrans à
l'ordre est-ce un peu vieux jeu pour
commencer vous entendre avant avant de
débattre le chef de
l'État moi je crois pas du tout que le
symbolique soit vieux jeu je crois pas
du je vais vous dire
je je l'expliquais tout à l'heure en
disant ce qui a fait notre pays c'est
l'ordre et le progrès je crois qu'il y a
pas de progrès sans ordre et pour le
coup là on est vieux jeux s'il y a que
l'ordre et pas le progrès je crois à une
autorité juste et une émancipation nos
sociétés sont devenu un peu
liquides et donc faut redonner des
repères des repères par les savoirs
qu'on transmet par l'histoire qu'on
transmet par les valeurs qu'on transmet
faut donner des rendez-vous des Caps de
passage
la fin du primaire le brevet des
collèges le baccalauréat les
diplomations c'est pas vieux jeu du tout
croyez-moi parce que si on passe dans la
vie comme ça comme entre des courants
tout le monde est perdu et moi je trouve
que beaucoup de gens sont perdus en vrai
et ça rend pas les gens heureux bah
c'est pour ça que Val est-ce que vous
vous êtes reconnu vous avez reconnu
certains aspects du programme de de
votre parti l dans dans certaines des
annonces du président République ah que
serais-je sans
toi je dirais que franchement sans leslr
pas de loi immigration pas de ministre
et pas de slogan c'est quand même
incroyable de parler de régénération et
d'assister à un recyclage d'idées des
autres sans pour autant les mettre en
œuvre moi je me rappelle du slogan pour
que la France reste la France où
effectivement les LR
c'étaitéonie tout à fait était voué au
gémonie ça a été aussi le slogan d'éic
siotti où on nous avait traité tous les
noms d'oiseaux euh bon je trouve ça un
petit peu curieux euh qu'on n pas en
fait Emmanuel Macron aime beaucoup
emprunter à ses adversaires politiques
alors je sais qu'on assiste à une séance
de
punition parce que la la loi immigration
ne s'est pas déroulé comme il l'avait
souhaité pourtant nous nous avons été
parfaitement euh j'allais dire
prévisible hein c'est un texte sur
lequel on av travaillé depuis plus un an
qui est plus d'un an qui est attendu par
euh tous les Français plus de 70 % des
Français euh et donc nous avons mis en
œuvre ce que nous avions dit et nous
avons tenu à faire en sorte que le texte
sur lequel nous nous étions engagés
puisse être voté donc il vous pique vos
ministres et maintenant même vos slogans
qu'est-ce qui va vous restid les
ministres ben écoutez je pense qu'il
nous reste la force de proposition
d'initiative et surtout la cohérence et
la constance ce qui n'est peut-être pas
le cas du prés président de la
République parce que j'ai pas vu
beaucoup d'idées nouvelles et pour pour
pour parler si vous permettez pour
parler par exemple si on voulait
vraiment concrètement avancer sur ces
sujets majeurs que sont qui qui est
l'immigration avec un sujet qui est
attendu par tous les Français hein enfin
plus de 70 % des Français dans tous les
sondages qui est un sujet qui fracture
quand même la la vie politique française
et bien je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
n'a pas entendu ce soir l'annonce d'un
référendum malgré la question qui lui a
été posé parce que il est vraiment
nécessaire d'aller beaucoup plus lo mais
il ne donnait pas la date mais enfin une
modification de la consti une
modification de la Constitution c'est
possible pour l'IVG c'est pas possible
pour l'immigration pour qualifier cette
conférence de PR vraiment bien 2h et
qu5 j'aurais bien aimé avoir une idée
nouvelle j'aurais bien aimé avoir
quelque chose de concret et et pas du
recyclage c'est plutôt la régénération
du recyclage on encore tro quart d'heure
devant nous vous aurez le temps de de de
détailler évidemment votre votre analyse
pierre casenu quand même cette on a
vraiment souhaité avec myiam commencer
par ce cette réaction de du chef de
l'État sur il a été très offensif quand
on lui a dit c'est vieux jeux tout ce
que vous nous
proposez l' ressenti vous ouis moi mon
sentiment c'est que tous ceux qui
pensaient que le Président de la
République allait attendre la fin de son
second cquen en se croisant les bras ils
ont dû recracher leur purée devant la
télé parce qu'on a eu ici un président
combatif innovant qui a
des chco la Marise pour tous c'est non
parce que d'un coup et bien sûr on a eu
deux piliers il les a redit je pense
qu'on a été aujourd'hui il l'a redit à
plusieurs reprises dans en même temps
qu'il a assumé une France plus forte
effectivement c'est les sujets que vous
avez commencé à détailler sur le
réarmement civique pour que la France
reste la France ça m'a fait penser moins
à l'utilisation c'est à l'utilisation de
d'autres slogans politiques quand il a
dit novis Val plus que leur profil
pendant la campagne présidentielle il
triangule OLR ete mais qui cette
partieelà de la France plus juste et
donc on est encore une fois dans cet
équilibre dans cette double radicalité
et qui je pense est extrêmement
importante il en a parlé encore une fois
sur l'égalité des chances sur la lutte
contre le déterminisme social sur les ce
qu'il va faire pour réengager les
négociations salari reprend marseillaise
uniforme on est un peu loin de la
startup nation des des débuts d'Emmanuel
Macron qu bien contire par encore une il
faut pas vous avez attaqué justement sur
ce point là effectivement c'est là où il
y a les annonces les plus les plus
fortes sur les plus innovantes entre
guillemets sur ce qu'il a dit sur la
généralisation du usnu sur la
Marseillaise sur les heures
d'instruction civique dès la 5e mais il
a aussi été revenu entre guillemets au
au au au macronisme disrupteur des
années 2016-27 avec une loi travail acte
2 avec un nouveau plan sur la croissance
un choc de simplification qu'il a
annoncé donc moi je l'ai trouvé au
contraire très équilibré à la fois dans
un maronisme originel en même temps
perdure ce soir pour vous mais plus que
jamais le dépassement plus que jamais
dans le dépassement pas seulement enfin
on a aussi deux deux experts et on a
envie d'avoir leur analyse peut-être
générale pour commencer Anne Charlen
beszina je démarre avec vous qu'est-ce
qui vous frappe alors il y a eu 2h20 de
de de prise de parole beaucoup de
thématiques la la sensation générale que
vous retirez de cette conférence de
presse un président qui est quand même
content de lui on a plusieurs fois eu
des retours à on a commencé on a déjà
fait et cetera et ça c'est quand même
dans le champ lexical de ce qu'on lui
avait pas mal le reproché et j'ai le
sentiment que il a pas forcément entendu
cette critique qu'il restait des choses
à faire alors même si hein il a enchaîné
là-dessus mais on a on a un petit peu ça
ensuite ce que je retiens aussi c'est
cette défense du de du en même temps qui
est resté assez intéressante où
justement il a essayé de dire si je
défends une chose et son contraire c'est
notamment parce que c'est ça mon ADN et
moi ce que je retiens
comme mot clé c'est vraiment l'opinion
c'est-à-dire que c'est un président qui
est sensible à l'opinion l'opinion va
plus à droite demande du régalien a
besoin de plus d'autorité il demande
plus d'autorité en 2007 il est en 2017
il est plutôt startupper et je crois que
c'est vraiment ça qui peut faire qu'on
lui repr de col vertébr sociologie
électorale qui a changé entre
201 c'est ce qu'il dit ici c'està-dire
je leur demandé autorité efficacité
parce que c'est ce qui est demandé par
l'opinion donc au fond on voit qu'il
suit profondément ce il y a un mot qu'il
a beaucoup prononcé c'est le mot audace
aussi AACE
efficacité qui va pas forcément avec ses
mots après parce que finalement il a
plus fait des bilans en disant bah en
gros ça va marcher donc il faut
continuer il faut un peu de patience
parce que on va on va avoir des
résultats moi ce qui m'a choqué bah
c'est laamue laamue elle est terminée ça
y est c'est à droite toute hein on a eu
on a eu les premiers signaux déjà avec
la loi retraite la loi immigration avec
le romaniimement là c'est laamue totale
qui est àchevé il me semble à droite
avec ce que vous dites l'ordre et
l'autorité c'est assez malin parce que
moi je crois pas qu'il justifie le en
même temps il justifie cette position
beaucoup plus droitière euh avec l'ordre
et la liberté il l'exlique avec une
espèce de de voilà de de de côté très
malin en disant bah on peut avoir la
liberté que s'il y a de l'ordre donc il
justifie cette cette cette autorité vers
laquelle il va beaucoup plus qu'en 2017
parce qu'on est plus du tout dans le
même projet parce que c'est que comme ça
qu'on va avoir la liberté là où je l'ai
trouvé bon c'est sur cette explication
je trouvé très bon vis-à-vis du
rassemblement national mais ça c'était
un peu attendu parce que il avait il
avait attaqué la bataille là-dessus par
contre il a quand même avoué un échec
c'est l'échec bah d en même temps de
2017 c'est-à-dire le progrès de pouvoir
faire en sorte que n'importe quel enfant
quel que soit son milieu social quel que
soit son origine il peut progresser dans
la société que ce fameux ascenseur
social français qui est bloqué il a
accepté de dire qu'il y avait un échec
il a pas tellement répondu sur comment
faire pour réellement alors que c'était
la promesse vraiment initiale du du
macronisme en 2017 c'était le point
central du macronisme il a il a avoué
cet échec mais après moi ce qui m'a
choqué vraiment c'est une espèce
d'explication sur tous les
dysfonctionnements qu'il a révélé lui
même et qui ont été révélés par les
questions en disant mais attendez on a
tout fait on fait tout il suffit
d'attendre parce que ça va marcher et ça
je trouve que c'est une répon
principalement la réponse sur le la la
transformation la transition écique non
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de choses
sur lesquelles il y avait cette réponse
et c'est un peu court pour des gens qui
ressentent d'ailleurs il a parlé de
ressenti pas ass de chose qui c'est vrai
on a senti un déséquilibre entre d'un
côté l'importance de l'ordre ce fameux
bon sens les vieux précepts au fond dont
il se revendique et et et moins en tout
cas ça ça pesait moins de l'autre côté
sur l'égalité des chances l'émancipation
ce qui a fait l'ADN de 2017 lutter
contre les déterminismes sociaux nous
n'avons pas radicalement changé les
choses je cite le chef de l'État vous le
reconnaissez alors sur cette partieel et
pour ça que je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec le propos je pense qu'au
contraire il a fait quelques pas de côté
évidemment qu'il y a des éléments de
bilan qu'il faut mettre en avant quand
on crée 2 millions d'emplois quand on
met 10000 gendarmes et policiers de plus
dans nos rues quand quand on met 2000
quand on crée 2700 maison Fran service
partout en France il faut être aussi en
mesure de le dire tout n'est pas parfait
il l'a redit il a fait des pas de côté
notamment je pense en en avouant
finalement bah ne pas être allé jusqu'au
bout de cette logique sur la lutte
contre le déterminisme il se donne aussi
sa feuille de route pour les 3 ans et
demi qui restent et l'effort qu'il veut
faire moi je suis pas d'accord avec ce
procès en déséquilibre et par ailleurs
euh les à
droite dans le cas même dans le casting
du nouveau gouvernement il a 8 minutes
sur 14 qui vici même sur l'uniforme je
veux dire c'est pas forc je on considère
ça nous en France avec nos yeux français
comme quelque chose de quelque chose de
droite c'est pourtant présent dans des
dizaines de pays anglo-saxons c'est
aussi un moyen
d'homogénéiser les enfin les les
différen la généralisation c'est une
expérimentation ou c'est une
expérientation je pense que la méthode
du président est la bonne euh moi j'ai
un avis à titre très personnel je trouve
que c'est une très bonne chose
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre une
certaine forme de harcèlement scolaire
aussi
appartenance un collectif je suis à
titre très personnel favorable la
méthode qui employé la bonne on va faire
une expérimentation avec des experts qui
vont le juger et on
verensite on retrouver sur place vous
dites je vous entendais là pendant
queer é en TR de parleruni ça fait 10
ans qu'on réclame vous devriez être
satisa écout je suis mesure où c'est pas
un l'heure et puis il y a vous avez
remarqué que dès que cette possibilité a
été enfin offerte parce qu'on là aussi
on était vous augémonie dès qu'on le
proposait euh beaucoup de de
départements ou de régions se sont porté
volontaires pour qui est une tenue
uniforme et surtout que cette tenue soit
fabriquée en France parce que les deux
vont avec hein il faut être quand même
dans la logique de la
réindustrialisation il est temps d'y
venir ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point je voudrais vous dire un
truc très concret et je pense que tous
les parents qui nous écoutent se
reconnaîtront à un moment donné on a
parlé de de de de du portable des
réseaux sociaux et C des écr place et le
président de la République a dit j'ai
fait interdire le portable au collège ah
oui mais théoriquement parce que en
pratique il y a pas de casier pour
laisser son portable et si un professeur
veut lutter contre le portable il y a de
telles addictions il y a de tels
comportements avec le portable
aujourd'hui qu'il est menacé que les
parents viennent et cetera donc les mots
sont sont dit mais le concret n'y est
pas quand on parle par exemple de
l'exposition aux écrans ça fait des
années moi je fais partie de ces
parlementaires qui réclam que dans le
carnet de santé il y ait des
informations là-dessus et qu'on soit
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus cohérent qu'
a une charte par an enfant à l'école
mais qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour le
faire il y a plus de médecine scolaire à
l'école vous pensez queion il dit
j'attends un consensus scientifique et
en fonction de ce
consensus RPé au Sénat au Sénat nous
avons eu une mission d'information sur
TikTok par exemple et nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur cette question le
consensus scientifique il existe c'est
dit par tout le toutes les personnes
soit qui ont des enfants soit qui qui
ou par les les professionnels les
psychiatres les psy et cetera donc ces
questionsl on les connaît faisons les
choses concrètement ça fait des années
qu'on réclame pas besoin d'attendre on
va on va
rejoindre BES d'attendre effectivement
allons plus vite Tam tranui vous êtes
avec nous et je je voulais quand même
qu' donne la parole assez vite parce que
la soirée est longue pour vous et on
voudrait vous libérer pour nous dire
comment ça s'est passé dans quel état
d'esprit vous avez trouvé le président
et qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé vous dans
dans ces 2h20 de conférence de
presse et ben ce qui m'a frappé dans un
premier temps et bien c'est que Emmanuel
Macron a tenu son temps 2h20 vous l'avez
dit c'est ce qui nous était annoncé et
c'est bien ce qui est arrivé
contrairement à ce qui arrive d'habitude
lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron et bien a
l'habitude de dépasser son temps il en
résul une certaine sensation de
frustration he du côté des journalistes
on a eu la plupart du temps des
questions relativement courte et puis de
long développement de la part du
président de la République une dimension
très programmatique au départ avec et
bien cette façon de vouloir réarmer d'un
point de vue civique d'un point de vue
économique la France et qui était un
véritable exposé de ce qu'il voulait
faire sur la suite du quinena et puis on
a eu effectivement et ben une longue
séquence consacré aux questions rebond
sur ce sujet allant de la santé à
l'éducation nationale et et bien
finalement très peu de questions qui ont
été consacrées véritablement à la partie
plus politique plus polémique seulement
et bien de réponse sur les deux
polémiques obligatoires du moment pour
Emmanuel Macron sur l'affaire de pardieu
ou encore bien sûr aujourd'hui sur
l'affaire oué à casterra je vous le
disais finalement et bien de cela est
ressorti l'impression d'un exercice très
cadré pour la plupart des journalistes
présents un petit peu frustré jusqu'à
même un journaliste qui s'est écrié au
moment où arrivé la dernière question
mais ce n'est pas normal comment est-il
possible qu'on ne puisse pas poser plus
de questions voilà donc pour et bien la
sensation qui est sortie de cette
conférence de presse de 2h d'Emmanuel
Macron merci beaucoup Tam tranui en
duplexe de la cour de l'Élysée alors il
y a eu beaucoup de thèmes aborder on a
commencé à en parler le premier des
thèmes peut-être la première des des
batailles de ce Macron relancé avec
cette conférence de presse c'est l'école
avec on en a parlé la tenue unique mais
pas seulement
écoutez je souhaite que le théâtre
devienne un passage obligé au collège
dès la rentrée
prochaine parce que cela donne confiance
cela apprend l'oralité le contact au
grand texte et parce que la France est
aussi une histoire un patrimoine qui se
transmet et qui unit histoire de l'art
retrouvera sa place à la rentrée
prochaine au collège et au
lycée la tenue unique qui a donné lieu à
tant de débats ces derniers mois dans
notre pays et qui efface les inégalités
entre les familles en même temps qu'elle
crée les conditions du respect sera
expérimenté dès cette année dans une
centaine
d'établissements tous
volontaires cette expérimentation sera
évaluée méthodiquement et sur la base
des résultats s'ils sont concluants nous
la généraliserons en
2026 nous instituerons dans chaque
collège et dans chaque lycée dès la fin
de cette année une cérémonie de remise
des diplômes rit républicain d'unité de
fierté et de
reconnaissance la famille et l'école au
fond pour faire des républicains en même
temps que pour transmettre des
savoirs Valérie Boyer transmettre des
savoirs refonder l'instruction civique
pass obligé le théâtre désormais au
collège ou encore l'histoire de l'art
vous applaudissez ah oui D deains et
mais d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je
demanderais à Madame oua casterras
qu'allait-elle faire dans cette galère
en se rendant à Canosa aujourd'hui pour
relancer la guerre scolaire je note que
ça fait une semaine que le nouveau
gouvernement a été décidé par Emmanuel
Macron et que en une semaine on a la
guerre scolaire entre le public et le
privé qui est lancé et on a la guerre
entre le public et le privé dans l'hosp
à l'hôpital et entre la médecine de
ville et la médecine hospitalière c'est
quand même euh alors on va
revenir c'est quand même sur le ben sur
le fond bien on ne peut être que
d'accord avec les mots mais les actes
qu'est-ce qu'on attend ça fait plus de 7
ans que 6 ans que Emmanuel Macron est
président de la République ça fait si on
rajoute les 5 ans sous Hollande ça fait
beaucoup plus de temps qu'il est qu'il
est aux affaires euh moi je je comprends
pas pourquoi on revient sur on a eu
Macron 1 et là on a Macron 2 qui est
totalement différent du premier vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure effectivement
il s'adapte à l'opinion mais un
président de la République il doit
montrer un cap euh alors le cap de
l'efficacité de ce qui marche voilà des
résultats ça n'est pas suffisant pour
vous tout à l'heure je vous citais
l'exemple du téléphone portable voilà
quelque chose de concret euh
alors le cap pour l'école c'est quoi le
cap pour l'écoleécole et on a la
polémique pendant une semaine je pense
que le cap pour l'école il est il est
très clair il y a à la fois cette
dimension réarmement civique je pense
qu'il a encore réemployé ce terme et
c'est ce qui se passe sur
l'expérimentation sur la tenue unique
c'est ce qui va se passer sur cette
heure d'éducation civique obligatoire à
partir de la 5e sur le théâtre sur
l'histoire de l'art je pense que ça
c'est quand les professeurs ne font pas
et donc ça c'est mon premier point et
mon deuxième point c'est de dire
continuer cet immense chantier sur les
école sur le recrutement sur la
revalorisation il y a une revalorisation
historique de nos professeurs à c'être
rentré ave ça ne suffit
pas présent mais parce que on a hérité
comme beaucoup beaucoup de ce qu'on a
pas fait jusque- là ou de ce qu'on
aurait dû faire mais vous étiez au
pouvoir avec avec Nicolas Sarkozi vous
avez vous supprimé des policiers bon
nous on en a rajouté vous avez supprimé
des PO on avait des résultats chers
collègu on avait faut arrêter avec cette
ancienne parce
résé diff interrompu je dis c'est très
facile de dire on fait on fait on fait
il devrait il devrait il devrait nous on
est dans l'action sur ce sujet-l les
résultats ça tout ne fonctionne pas du
jour au lendemain il y a des choses qui
prennent du temps l'attractivité du
métier de l'école il va continuer à être
extrêmement extrêmement extrêmement
crucial dans les années à venir il a
réannoncer là dès le mois de mars une
modification sur la formation des
enseignants dès la sortie du bac donc là
aussi on va avoir des annonces qui vont
être probablement qui vont arriver très
vite sur le sujet voilà pour justement
recruter ces enseignants qui nous
manquent c'est ce Pact là d'attractivité
très fort et c'est ce Pact là qu'on a
fait aussi sur bah accompagner sur les
études dirigées sur continuer sur le
dédoublement des classes il y a aussi
cette parti là égalité ch parce que
l'école c'est la merde de toutes les B
service public école hôpital on sait
très bien que ces deux services publics
essentiels sont en crise aujourd'hui
dans notre pays il a aussi parl des
fonctionnaires qu'il veut rémunérer au
au mérite pensez-vous qu'il a
suffisamment été convaincant précis
donnant à ces ministres des feuilles de
route suffisamment claires pour donner
un peu d'espoir sur ces services publics
là aux Français en tout cas il s'est
appliqué à essayer de parler
concrètement ça on peut on peut noter ça
parce que c'est assez rare chez Emmanuel
Macron qui est plutôt abstrait plutôt
conceptuel là il a voulu s'attacher à
une vitesse quand même assez rapide à
tous les dans la prè dans son propos
liire dans lescoup
que
comm au MO faisant le diagnostic de ce
qui ne va toujours pas malgré les 6 ans
et
demi lui au pouvoir pu en terme de
communication pardon n interrompre mais
il fallait dans la première demi-heure
tant qu'il y avait beaucoup de Français
qui étaient devant leur télévision
répondre sur des questions de vie
quotidienne le plus possible le reproche
qu'on peut lui faire et je prendrai
l'exemple du théâtre ou de l'histoire de
l'art c'est de rajouter des choses qui
sont très attrayantes on se dit bon ben
c'est super de pouvoir faire de
l'istoire de l'art collège au lycée mais
du point de vue des élèves comme du
point de vue des profs il me semble que
là c'est décalé par rapport à la réalité
du terrain parce que déjà bon il y a
beaucoup d'heures on voit que c'est
c'est quand même compliqué les les
agendas les emplois du temps des des des
jeunes et c'est compliqué du côté des
professeurs parce que comme vous l'avez
dit le point central sur lequel il a
donné quelques éléments mais pas encore
il me semble suffisamment par rapport à
l'ampleur du problème c'est la pénurie
de professeur c'est le manque
d'attractivité et ça il y répond pas
vraiment on rajoute des choses àéchantes
pour éviter de voir et cétait un peu
ceait fa Gabri AC des choses moséchantes
mais avit plus au français sur la l'unie
il avait déjà commencé à faire miroiter
des choses pour cacher un peu la
forêtans la par au
autdedans pard pardon làdedans il a
évidemment la
polémique
ministre qui a effectivement entaché
c'est un peu comme un boulet au au pied
de de gabrielal pour lancer son nouveau
gouvernement on se demandait si Emmanuel
Macron allait soutenir sa ministre
comment avec quels mots les voilà la
ministre a eu un propos public qui a été
maladroit elle s'en est excusé elle a
bien fait je vais vous dire j'ai plutôt
de l'indulgence parce qu'il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des propos au tout début de mes
responsabilités politiques qui avaient
blessé tout particulièrement des femmes
dans une entreprise du Grand Ouest et et
quand on blesse surtout sans s'en rendre
compte on a raison de s'excuser moi je
pense que il y a pas d'école qui
tiennent si on n pas tous nos
enseignants avec nous il faut un travail
remarquable et j'ai l'occasion de le
dire il travail d'arrachepied pour
préparer leurs cours corriger leurs
copies et devant les élèves continuer
d'innover et donc la ministre réussira à
sa tâche avec les
enseignants la ministre réussira à sa
tâche avec les enseignants c'est un peu
la méthode Coué quand même char Bina
comment vous vous recevez ça en même
temps c'était certainement pas le lieu
pour pour
enfoncer la nouvelle ministre de
l'éducation nationale on éta Pr de toute
façon qu'elle allait se maintenir 4
jours à un ministère ça serait quand
même le record de la 5e République et
puis euh le propos est malin
c'est-à-dire que il y a à la fois un
soutien et une reconnaissance on n'est
pas justement sur
les erreurs de communication qu'il a
avoué d'ailleurs de l'affaire Gérard de
pardieu où il essaie d'être un petit peu
dans le en même temps et là c'était
vraiment la bonne posture on on voit
quand même aussi que il y a un tropisme
du président de la République à soutenir
ses équipes quit à profiter du prochain
remanement pour faire m on voit
avecivier et la réforme des retraites
qui ne fait pas partie du nouveau
casting mais bon encore une fois ce
soutien il pouvait aussi être appelé par
le fait que c'est tôt c'est quand même
particulièrement violent de la part des
oppositions de réclamer une démission
pour si peu même si sous la 5èe
République ça c'est quand même déjà qui
enseigné on se on se remet d'une entrée
aussi catastrophique ou pas avec le corp
enseignant avec qui on doit négocier je
je crois que les erurs jamais été à ce
point en conflit avec vos étudiants
quand même P qu'on ma pardonné des
erreurs d'entrée à partir du moment où
le où le pardon est sincère ici il faut
faire attention à ce que la
communication prenne pas le dessus
surtout et c'est vrai que on a le
sentiment qu'elle a été très briefée sur
les déplacements qu'elle doit faire au
risque peut-être de dans dans trop
d'excuses c'est peut-être aussi
surligner beaucoup le problème je pense
que il y a un petit peu de de de de de
trop dans cette communication voilà
encore une fois une erreur d'entrée on
peut la pardonner à partir du moment où
il il y a de l'insincérité on continue
ce parcours mais voilà jugeonsla en
comme on dit en droit surpèce et sur
place attend on va avancer je suis sûr
que vous reconnaîtrez peut-être une
maladresse comme le chef de l'État et
pas une faute mais quand même
l'éducation la jeunesse le sport et les
Joos mission impossible non mission
cohérente déjà parce qu'on forme un tout
là aussi je trouve cohérent sur bah
effectivement l'avenir quel quel destin
ont construit pour les générations
futures et moi je suis très attaché au
sport et au sport à l'école je trouve
que c'est deux mesures dont on parle peu
mais qui sont pour moi extrêmement
importantes la demiheure quotidienne
obligatoire et les 2 heures de sport
qu'on a mis chaque semaine pour les
collégiens ce sont des choses absolument
formidables on rentre dans une année
olympique ça va être un événement
extraordinaire pour Paris pour toute la
France c'est c'est la grande cause
nationale le sport pour tous ça
évidemment le sport a un impact sur la
santé ça a un impact mais sur le
développement civique aussi parce que
dans le sport il y a l'esprit d'équipe
il y a la camaraderie il y a le respect
de l'arbitre il y a tout de chose moi je
suis rugby man j'ai la chance aussi
d'être capitaine du 15 parlementaires
donc on peut tout
faire
bien faire c'est la question oui on peut
tout bien faire encore une fois si on a
on est équipé pour si on a des équipes
pour et je trouve que je suis certain
qu'améliouda casterra en aura encore une
fois le président lui a renouvelé sa
confiance c'est une personnalité d'une
très grande intelligence qui connaît ces
dossiers sur le bout des doigts avec la
majorité comme avec les oppositions sur
le sujet des GO elle a montré toute sa
technicité toute sa maîtrise des
dossiers je suis c'est un atout énorme
pour l'éducation nationale encore une
fois et il a aussi et je redis ça aussi
parce que c'est important le Premier
ministre qui était ministre de
l'Éducation jusqu'alors l'a dit il
emporte la cause de l'école avec lui à
matin ça veut dire va
Faou mais parce que l'éducation est une
priorité du président du du Premier
ministre avec une ministre une
extrêmement forte sur le suj c'est
génial pour l'éducation nationale ils
vont pas être abandonné bien au
contraire tout le monde se mobilise ça
devient la grande cause une petite
question de méthode puisqu'on a deux
élus un député une sénatrice sur la
feuille de route des réformes on a parlé
de de quelques annonces une une grande
loi économique est-ce que c'est une
réforme structurelle une réforme
d'ampleur un congé parental ou un congé
naissance vous vous avez vu des textes
de loi ce soir ou ou du décret du
réglementaire contournerit le Parlement
on a vu un peu des deux ça je pense que
ça sera surtout au Premier ministre
quand il fera cette déclaration de
politique générale de détailler de
manière précise euh la manière dont il
entend mener les politiques qui a dégagé
ça passe ou ça casse à
l'Assemblée encore une fois on va
trouver on va s'efforcer à chercher des
majorités des consensus que ça soit avec
évidemment avec No No nos collègues
sénateurs je sais pas que les chiffres
ont encore été redonnés par il Bron pivé
ce matin elle avait la réception de de
l'ensemble des parlementaires sur le
nombre de commission max paritaire qui
avait été conclusive lors de de l'année
qui vient de s'écouler moi je crois à ce
travail parlementaire je crois en ce
dialogue il va falloir
ch je vous interromp puis qu'on a
Mathilde panneau qui est en en direct on
va l'écouter pendant quelques minutes la
présidente du groupe elle fille à
l'Assemblée d que je dès que je lu pose
la première
[Musique]
question au micro de Marco Pomier de LCP
Madame de
Merteuil Mathilde Panau bonsoir vous
avez entendu Emmanuel Macron 2h20 de
conférences de presse de nombreuses
questions abordé l'école des questions
plus politiques et internationales
qu'avez-vous pensé de la conférence de
presse d'Emmanuel Macron alors moi j'ai
écouté cette conférence de presse
effectivement de 2h20 extrêmement longue
je l'ai écouté depuis de campement ici à
sol ferino sur lequel depuis le 25
décembre une trentaine de familles sans
abri sont là pour demander une mesure
immédiate de ce gouvernement qui
s'appelle la réquisition je rappelle que
quasiment tous les jours dans notre pays
on découvre un corps gelé de gens qui
sont morts non pas de la rue mais de
l'inaction du gouvernement sur la
question de l'hébergement d'urgence de
la réquisition qui est une mesure
d'urgence extrêmement facile à prendre
immédiatement et de la politique qui à
la fois propage la misère et crée du mal
mal logement et du sansabrisme dans ce
pays donc d'ici depuis ce campement où
nous avons entendu Emmanuel Macron il
apparaît non seulement complètement
déconnecté des besoins des gens mais
aussi extrêmement méprisant je suis par
exemple choquée que Emmanuel Macron nait
pas dit un seul mot pour les personnes
qui sont mortes à la rue dans ce pays
depuis le début de l'année des 620
personnes qui sont mortes l'année
dernière selon les collectifs des morts
de la rue donc chiffre largement
probablement sous-estimés avec des gens
qui meurent dans l'indifférence dans la
7e puiss économique au monde donc si je
le fais depuis ce campement c'est parce
que nous voulions alerter le
gouvernement
sur des centaines de milliers de
personnes 330000 personnes dans ce pays
multiplié chiffre multiplié par 2 depuis
10 ans chiffre multiplié par 3 depuis 20
ans qui se retrouve aujourd'hui sans
toit c'est-à-dire un droit fondamental
et qui se retrouve au prise à un froid
immense que vous ressentez vous-même en
ce moment avec et c'est ce qui est écrit
derrière la mort qui arrive parfois donc
voilà on a une déconnexion terrible d'un
président de la République et d'un
pouvoir qui aujourd'hui ne répond plus
aux besoins fondamentaux des gens que ça
soit sur la question de la santé de
l'éducation du logement et juste de quoi
avoir de quoi avoir pour vivre dignement
donc je trouve ça extrra donc voilà pour
cette cette prise de parole de de
Mathilde
panneau où elle profite finalement de de
des micros pour poser une vraie question
pierre caseneu qui a pas été abordée par
le le chef de
h ce soir en même temps il pouvit pas
parler de de tout est-ce qu'il y a une
carence de de l'État en la matière je
tiens à rappeler que notre majorité a
fait un effort et a créer un nombre
d'hébergements d'urgence historique le
président a pas parlé de tous les sujets
bien évidemment il a pas été d'ailleurs
interrogé spécifiquement sur cette
question derrière c'est tout l'enjeu moi
j'entends autour de la solidarité je
pense que le Président il a aussi
l'accusation au début de l'émission j'ai
accusation avec des Guillet que il a été
trop sur sa jambe droite entre
guillemets moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié
beaucoup écouté beaucoup entendu ce
qu'il dit sur la France plus juste sur
justement on en a parlé sur l'égalité
des chances mais aussi sur notre
capacité à redonner du pouvoir d'achat
aux Français on les a énormément protégé
pendant cette période d'inflation je
tiens à leured dire ici on est le pays
qui a le plus protégé qui a maintenu son
inflation le plus bas de toute l'Europe
on a avec les bouclli tarifairire avec
tout un tas de sujets protéger les
Français la gauche de la majorité à qui
il s'adressait aussi ce soir cette les
Français sa priorité bien évidemment
mais on est quand même après un débat
assez chaotique sur le projet de loi
immigration une aile gauche qui est
tenté par ce se composer de façon un peu
plus autonome elle est rassurée ce soir
je pense en tout cas moi j'ai trouvé le
président extrêmement clair sur des app
des marqueurs un peu sociaux ou des
marqueurs même sociétaux que ça soit sur
évidemment le moi je pense notamment au
congé ce nouveau congé de naissance éit
là aussi une annonce je trouve très
forte président la répuque qu'estce
qu'il faut comprendre de ce nouveau
congé naissance pour à la fois les on
avait pas le texte avant et seul proncer
fait foi donc je l'ai découvert en même
temps que vous c'était une piste qui
avait déjà été évoquée par la ministre
Aurore berger donc l'idée aujourd'hui on
a ce fameux congé parentalité qui était
très long et très mal payé que les gens
ne prenaient pas jusque le président a
acté c'est ou peu en tout cas il était
le recours était assez peu le président
l' redit on avait peu recours à ce congé
parentalité un parce qu'il était très
long et deux parce qu'il était peu
rémunéré et donc ce que veut faire le
Président c'est rationaliser euh ce euh
ce ce ce congél en le raccourcissant sur
une période de 6 mois qui veut être pris
évidemment et par euh le le père et par
la mère euh et d'avoir euh là sur ces
sur ces 6 mois-là une rémunération juste
qui fait que on peut prendre ce temps-là
et donc ça je trouve que c'est aussi un
marqueur très fort sur notre capacité à
à euh
euh aborder notre vie notre vie
familiale de manière un peu différente
notre temps libre de manière aussi un
peu différente et j'ai trouvé que là il
y avait aussi un marqueur ça a été mis
évidemment dans une politique de
natalité je pense que c'est très
important c'est un sujet qu'on avait peu
abordé depuis l'heure et donc je trouve
ça très bien qu'il le fasse mais je
trouve qu'il y a aussi un côté nouvelle
société des perspectives très
intéressantes surz Valé vousez vous
devez nous quitter dans dans dans moins
de 10 minutes hein on est bien d'accord
jeais vous parz de
r sur la famille c'est vrai qu'on n pas
de ministre de la Famille mais j'imagine
qu'après la conférence de avec après le
discours de politique général du Premier
ministre qui interviendra après la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel là
on est quand même dans le dans la
Constitution c'est quand même quelque
chose de d'incroyable article 20 article
40 mais bon peu importe euh nous aurons
sûrement beaucoup de secrétaires d'État
pour l'instant on a rien sur la famille
et j'avoue que la famille c'est un peu
l'impensée de la macronie puisque
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas revenu sur ce
qu'avait fait François Hollande euh à
savoir la la le la la fin de
l'universalité des allocation familiale
mais modifier le congé parental c'est un
petit peu court euh pour une politique
familiale moi je note qu' aujourd'hui il
y a une violence qui est faite aux
femmes dont on ne parle pas c'est celle
de choisir entre travailler et avoir des
enfants il n'est pas normal que notre
société soit si peu accueillante pour
les femmes qui travaillent aujourd'hui
donc c'est pas la réforme c'est
important le congé le congé parental
mais il n'y a pas que ça il faut revenir
sur le ccient familial il faut revenir
sur l'immobilier
l'immobili excusez-moi c'est absolument
fondamental moi je prêche pour qu'on ait
une politique familial pour que les
femmes puissent choisir or aujourd'hui
elles n'ont plus ce choix elles ne sont
pas accompagnées parce que on a supprimé
beaucoup de beaucoup d'aide il n'y a pas
non plus un accueil dans les entreprises
et les jeunes femmes aujourd'hui elles
le disent beaucoup elle se prive d'avoir
un ou deux enfants de plus et ça c'est
une question qui n pierre cas très vite
ensuite Émilie vous oublie pas sociale
le meilleur moyen de lutter contre la
pauvreté la meilleure réponse à ass
inégalité sociale c'est le travail je
pense que le président là aussi a remis
dans ses grands axes quand il a annoncé
aller plus loin sur le un acte 2 de la
réforme du marché du travail sur ce
qu'il a fait sur la formation et à
travers ça aussi plus jeune sur l'école
là on est au cœur pour moi de la
politique sociale tel que le président
la pense c'està-dire remettre la valeur
travail au
centre j'avou que j'ai pas tout compris
sur le conjet de naissance c'est que ça
ça demande quand même un peu des
explications de texte j'ai pas tout
compris non plus sur le plan
l'infertilité aussi hein parce que j'ai
compris que c'était une des solutions
pour éviter le le le la démographie
baissante puisqu'on sait qu'on fait de
moins en moins d'enfants sur le social
j'ai pas trouvé qu'il y avait énormément
j'ai trouvé quand même quelque chose qui
était plutôt de l'ordre de une prise de
conscience quand il a parl des émeutes
il a été questionné sur les émeutes de
juillet dernier il a parlé notamment des
causes ou en tout cas des profils de
famille c'était souvent des familles
monoparental et on sait très bien que
c'est une question sociale très
importante et il y en a une
aé il y en a une Marine Le Pen qui s'est
déjà emparé de cette question parce que
je sais pas si vous souvenez mais
pendant la campagne 2022 elle avait
proposé d'augmenter les allocations pour
les familles monoparentales parce
qu'elle a compris que c'était un levier
important pour s'adresser aussi aux
classes moyennees et je pense que juste
sur le sujet bah il a touché juste sur
le diagnostic mais il a pas de donné
plus avec vous on peut évoquer une une
grande absente les institutions alors a
dit hein je ne parlerai pas de réforme
institutionnelle il l'a écarté dès le
départ et en même temps à la question
sur le référendum il a laissé entendre
que c'était dans ces projets ça
viendrait mais pas tout de suite alors
précisément sur la réforme des
institutions j'ai pas trouvé qu'il été à
ce point-là absent non plus parce que
dans dans tout son discours on a quand
même entendu parler de simplification
normative de simplification fiscale de
simplification et ce mot simplification
doit alerter à mon sens parce que la
simplification c'est du domaine
réglementaire et donc ça signifie qu'il
a très envie d'essayer de courtcircuiter
un peu le débat parlementaire et il faut
s'en inquiéter je pense qu'il faut s'en
inquiéter parce que les Français dans
les sondages d'opinion sont quand même
assez friants de enfin ont un appétit à
rechercher ce que cette majorité
relative peut apporter au consensus ou
au dissensus d'ailleurs dans la
démocratie mais c'est sain qu'il y ait
l'un et l'autre donc attention quand
même à entendre beaucoup trop parler de
ça je rajoute que sur les institutions
sur le référendum il a dit qu'il
l'utilisera quand même
même si l'effet de teasing sur nous dire
pas de sujet ni pas de calendrier me
laisse un peu song juste avant que vous
partiez Rach ministre de la
cultureah c'est le choix du président de
la République mais je pense que
là-dessus on a tout dit et ça fait une
semaine qu'on en parle aujourd'hui je
pense que l'essentiel c'est quand même
un affblissement pour LR un autre un
plus disons que c'est un coup sur LR
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure sans LR que ferait président il
pas parlé de Paris a-t-il absolument
assuré avec rachidti après cette nom
tion pas de deal sur les municipales à
Paris B on verra en tout cas il veut
changer le mode de scrutin c'est pas
innocent merci Valérie
Boyer et à très bientôt puisqu'on parle
de rachidti je vous propose d'entendre
le président finalement défendre son
choix une une nouvelle ministre chargé
essentiellement de diffuser la culture
le plus largement pour possible la
culture pour tous j'ai proposé avec le
Premier ministre à Madame rachidevenir
ministre de la Culture parce que son
énergie son talent sa liberté parce
qu'elle ne se réduit pas à une
appartenance
politique je crois sont utiles à la
culture à ouvrir des portes et à
permettre au fond de mettre fin je le
disais c'est pour moi un de mes grands
objectifs à cette France du c'est pas
fait pour
moi faut lutter contre
celle-ci n n'avons pas parlé de Paris
vous aurez du mal à me croire quand je
vous dis ça mais c'est
vrai la seule chose que je veux pour
Paris c'est qu'un électeur puisse avoir
les mêmes droits et compter autant à
Paris qu'à à mien à Besançon ou ailleurs
et donc que le gouvernement et le
Parlement puissent décider d'une réforme
en profondeur de la loi Paris
lionmseille pour revenir au droit commun
ça je pense que c'est la bonne chose
c'est la seule chose qui me concerne
pour Paris le reste je sais qu'elle
mettra son talent son énergie et tout le
reste au service de la culture de ceux
qui la servent et de ceux qui veulent
aussi y avoir droit et puis un argument
que le Président de la République a
peut-être oublié volontairement oublié
c'est qu'elle va aussi bien être utile
pendant la campagne des européennes le
le le côté combattante de Rachid adati
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'elle
est là elle a énormément de qualités
çaen fait partie et donc évidemment ça
sera un atout elle est là avec une
mission claire sur le fond la culture
pour tous on en parlait repris pris a
priori de de de Jack Lang on parlait
justement de l'appropriation des
Slog dans ce dépassement mission très
clair déjà moi j'aimerais rendre hommage
aussi à l'action de la ministre de la
Culture im abdoumak qui a fait
énormément de choses aussi pour le
secteur avec notamment le passeculture
avec tous les projets de de création
aussi qu'elle a mis en place rachidti
maintenant a ce challenge de faire
diffuser cette culture partout en France
sur tous les territoires mais la
nomination de Rachid hadti c'est
la continuité de ce dépassement c'est la
continuité de cette rupture d'être
toujours en rupture de toujours
surprendre de jamais rester sur les
acquis c'est l'audace toujours de
l'audace rien que de l'udace et puis
surtout c'est la stratégie
d'affaiblissement de de l il y a plus
Valérie Boyer pour en parler mais char
je voudrais bien vous entrendre
là-dessus parce que là on est on est
dans un je sais pas c'est c'est on
déshabille pièce pièce de vêtement par
pièce de vêtement le le parti des
républicains alors on avait eu affaire
quand même à des parties plus coalisé
avant les déc tion d'Emmanuel Macron que
les LR puisque déjà on savait que on
avait une fibre au Sénat qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale on sait que des sousfamilles
se dégage déjà que des primaires ont
quand même beaucoup abîmé le parti donc
c'est un parti qui historiquement
d'ailleurs on parlait des droites en
France tellement c'est c'est difficile
de s'identifier dans cette famille là
néanmoins oui je pense que le coup porté
OLR est très mal vécu de l'intérieur
alors cette personnalité qui Rachida
Dati va-t-elle encore affaiblir le
groupe je n'en suis pas certain parce
est disruptive par nature elle elle est
pas vraiment identifiée nécessairement
comme un un Barron on va dire de de CLR
mais clairement ça prouve que le
Président de la République entend
s'ouvrir au champ des républicains et
encore une fois la majorité les relative
lui laisse peu de choix c'est c'est
assez logique que ce soit avec ce group
politique de la droite sur ce
compromis arraché par leslr sur
l'immigration sont réduits à néant
aujourd'hui pour vous la la marche
politique va va va être très complexe à
l'Assemblée nationale dans les dans les
dans les mois
àir je suis pas sûr en effet que
l'entrée au gouvernement de personnalité
LR aide le dialogue avec les LR ni que
les futures européennes soient une clé
de la réussite de la Macron isapski
c'est vrai qu'on on se pose la question
depuis se remanement les nouveaux 14
ministres enfin les les entrants est-ce
que c'est un coup de communication
d'incarnation pour que les les Français
enfin entendent leur leurs ministres
leurs représentant ou un véritable
changement d'orientation politique il a
dit le cap est là il n'a pas changé d'
Yota c'est un gouvernement casting
c'était la réponse à la question quatre
ministres de la Santé en si la ligne ne
change pas si le cap n'a pas changé on
est dans le casting c'est ça ah moi je
pense qu'on est quand même non on est
plus que dans le casting le casting il
fait de l'effet parce qu'en effet avoir
récupéré quand même Rachid adti c'est
une prise de guerre mais c'est génial
parce que c'est une personnalité quand
même qui est explosive he qui qui sait
débattre en effet
pour la culture je pense que c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'elle saura
défendre les choses ses origines aussi
c'était le coup qu'avait joué aussi
Sarkozi issu de la société civile ses
origines il il y a pas mal d'atout en
plus si avoir jamais d'ambiguité
vis-à-vis du rassemblement national
exactement elle est très claire très
politique aussi très maline elle va pas
faire des erreurs de communication de
débutant de rture mais mais moi je pense
moi je pense que c'est le casting c'est
le fond on l'a entendu quand même
aujourd'hui dis c'est la dernière c'est
le dernier le dernier truc pour vraiment
faire la complètement à droite je suis
désolé mais ça se sent quand même ter du
rassemblement national ça sera notre
dernier thème mais il y a d'abord une
question vrais vous poser pierre parce
que moi l'impression générale que j'ai
eu en écoutant attentivement le le
président de la République il nous a
promis quand même ce réarmement il nous
a promis même il a parlé d'un
gouvernement révolutionnaire au moment
de sa nomination et en fait à
pratiquement à chaque thématique
pratiquement à chaque réponse il faisait
d'abord référence à ce qui a été fait
depuis 7 ans et il mettait en avant la
continuité donc bon je comprends pas
bien comment on peut être dans la
continuité et être révolutionnaire alors
fois je l'avez dit au début c'est
nécessaire d'avoir des éléments de bilan
parle pas d'une feuille blanche on a 6
ans et demi de de mandat derrière lui a
6 ans et demi de mandat derrière lui et
d'action donc il parle pas d'une feille
blanche il y a certains Surget sur
lequel il veut poursuivre et changer
radicalement
de comme on dit je pense notamment à
l'école ou ce qu'il a annoncé tout ce
qu'on a pu discuter sur les
enseignements civies sur le SNU tout ça
là on a un changement de braqué qui est
très fort on est en rupture par rapport
à ce qui fait il a des sujets sur
lequels il veut retrouver un esprit de
disruption qu'il avait en 2007 je parle
notamment sur le sujet de l'économie sur
finalement la loi travail acte 2 sur la
croissance sur taper les normes mais
révolu ou les révolutionnaire c'est
naccepter aucun tabou c'est de
n'accepter
aucun aucune réalité comme étant de
toute façon dé facto ce qui doit se
passer et justement se mettre soi-même
en rupture changer nous-même nos
habitudes ce qu'il a annoncé sur la
rémunération des fonctionnaires personne
ne le pensait possible une rémunération
au mérite plus qu'une rémunération sur
l'ancienneté c'est un changement de
paradigme qui est gigantesque ça pass à
l'Assemblée avec la droite pensez on
verra on en est pas là quel est le
vecteur législatif qui sera utilisé on
en est pas onb c'est révolutionnaire et
c'est ça qu'on l'un des derniers thème
sans doute le plus politique aborderé le
chef de l'État c'est celui du
rassemblement national parti du mensonge
et de la colère facile écoutez c'est le
pays c'est le pays c'est le parti de
l'appauvrissement collectif c'est le
parti du mensonge et ça le continue de
l'être c'est le parti qui a le programme
qui l' a complètement piqué à l'extrême
gauche c'est parti qui continue à vous
expliquer que la retraite à 60 ans est
possible sans vous expliquer comment la
financer parti qui vous explique qu'il
faut augmenter le SMIC sans vous
expliquer comment ça désindustrialisera
pas le pays c'est le parti qui continue
de vous expliquer des choses impossibles
sur le plan économique et social pour
affaiblir si on s'attaque pas pied à
pied à l'incohérence de leur programme
les gens se disent disent des trucs
faciles l'opposition c'est beaucoup plus
facile que le gouvernement et au fond
rassemblement national est devenu le
parti de la colère
facile du on n' pas tout essayé ça
paraît
sympathique ne nous habituons
pas
agissons
faisons bousculons les choses et les
habitudes pour montrer qu'en effet ce
bloc central qui rassemble les
démocrates les républicains les
écologistes qui croient dans l'Europe
peut agir et changer les choses et le
quotidien des gens Émilie zapalski c'est
sur le rassemblement national désigné
comme parfois son meilleur ennemi par
certains éditorialistes qu'il a été le
plus convaincant ce soir oui mais c'est
toujours pareil Emmanuel Macron quand il
est en campagne quand il est en bataille
quand il est comme ça conquurrent il est
très bon et c'est vrai il nous a sorti
des punchlines qui étaient vraiment
bonnes le parti de l'appauvrissement le
parti de la colère facile euh il a dit
aussi le parti du transformisme parce
qu'il change tout le temps d' vie on
sait jamais ce qu'il est notamment sur
l'Europe ou euh c'est pas mal sauf que
après il termine en disant il faut agir
agissons bousculons c'est vrai que son
discours n'est pas du tout à la hauteur
de ce positionnement là qui met dans
laamp c'est en répondant aux problèmes
qui nourrissent le Front national le
rassemblement national pardonnez-moi
qu'on lui réponde de la meilleure des
façons euh c'est aussi une lecture de de
de ces annonces de la conférence de
presse ce soir non oui sauf que ça ça
peut être discutable parce que c'est en
effet ce qui s'est passé avec la loi
immigration c'est-à-dire d'aller un
petit peu sur le terrain du
rassemblement national pour éviter qu'il
passe je suis pas sûr que ça ça puisse
satisfaire les gens qui ont voté pour
lui pour faire barrage au rassemblement
national là c'est plus discutable là où
il raison là où il a raison c'est quand
on les confronte à la réalité au fait
réel ça c'est vrai je vous interrom
pardon parce qu'on est avec Kevin
mauvieux député RN de l'UR avec nous en
duplexe parti de la colère fac
partie du transformisme qu'est-ce que
vous répondez au président de la
République répond au par du président de
la République que le transformisme
ills la soire alors on entend rien ce
sont des chos qui arrivve désolé de vous
interrompre on va essayer de régler ça
il nous reste très peu de temps dans
cette émission donc j'espère que ça
pourra se se régl pas de retour pour
l'instant quand on voit la force avec
laquelle le chef de l'État combat le RN
au moins dans dans la sémantique dans
les mots employés plus personne ne peut
douter que son obsession c'est que
Marine Le Pen ne soit pas élu en 2027
elle est l que l'écart avec le pardon
myiam je rajoute un élément et que que
dans moins de 6 mois aux européennes
l'écart ne soit pas aussi important
entre entre Jordane Bardella et le
candidat Renaissance on verra bien ça ne
serait pas uniquement en France qu'on
aurait ce risque là hein de toute façon
les élections européennes sont celles de
la entation de du de la
renationalisation et donc ce sont des
des élections où ce parti a beaucoup de
succès et la prochaine présidentielle on
prédit déjà un match horizon RN donc
évidemment Emmanuel Macron ne veut pas
être le dernier président avant d'avoir
cette vague populiste qui qui qui
s'abatt sur la France néanmoins voilà
c'est le chemin est vraiment pavé de
bonnes intentions et très dangereux
parce que tout est susceptible de faire
monter cette colère aujourd'hui il
semblerait que le micro de K ah on
écoute votre
réaction bonsoir euh j'espère que ça
fonctionne ben écoutez ma réaction à ces
2h15 de de de de on va dire de
conférence de presse deant en réalité
euh c'est qu'on a on a absolument rien
entendu on a entendu de beaux discours
mais aucune annonce concrète et donc je
vous entends effectivement parler des
mots d'Emmanuel Macron sur le
rassemblement national euh j'aurais aimé
qu'il ait un mot sur le pouvoir d'achat
des Français sur la sécurité des
Français mais plus qu'un mot un acte en
réalité ce soir il nous a attaqué parce
qu'il est fébrile vis-à-vis de la
progression du rassemblement national il
voit bien que les mesures et notre
programme sont plébiscités par les
Français que ça colle avec l'attente les
attentes des Français et avec les
besoins du pays aujourd'hui euh
d'ailleurs les quelques mesures qui ont
été annoncées par Emmanuel Macron sont
les mesures reprise au rassemblement
national euh l'idée de faire nation avec
la Marseillaise dans les écoles
primaires c'est euh une idée typique
rassemblement national euh euh l'idée du
de l'uniforme à l'école c'est une
proposition du rassemblement nationale
ça a même été une proposition de loi que
mon collègue Roger chudau a déposé dans
notre niche parlementaire et face à
laquelle toute la majorité a voté contre
donc en réalité le président Macron ne
fait que critiquer le rassemblement
national pour sauver son poste mais il
ne travaille pas pour les Français or
les Français ce qu'ils attendent c'est
qu'ils travaillent pour eux donc le
combat contre le rassemblement national
si vraiment il a envie de le mener et
bien c'est en améliorant le quotidien
des Français qu'aujourd'hui seul Marine
Le Pen et Jordan Bardella proposent
merci Kevin mauvieux une dernière
réaction il nous reste pas une minute on
l' après aujourd'hui Pierre Caseneuve le
discours de politique générale aura lieu
le 30 janvier prochain c'est-à-dire dans
de semaines et non pas mardi prochain ça
veut dire qu'il lui reste des choses à
dire à Gabriel Attal ça n'est pas une
discours de politique générale que nous
avons écouté ce soir non je pense que le
président a donné un cap un cap très
clair c'est son rôle son rôle
institutionnel le Premier ministre a
fait le choix d'avoir un temps un peu
plus long avant sa son discours de
politique générale pour consulter
consulter les différentes forces vies du
pays consultter les diff forces politiqu
du pays probablement euh continuer
poursuivre le remaniement et la
nomination de certains ministres
évidemment qu'il a plein de choses à
dire et de détailler euh l'ensemble des
mesures qui a esquissé ce soir le
président de la République euh mais il
lui a aussi donné un programme clair
avec cette lutte contre le rassemblement
national vous avez dit ne rien leur
laisser euh ça ne pas se laisser
approprier certains sujets moi ce que
j'ai entendu me rend fou fa aussi ne pas
s'approprier les symboles la
Marseillaise ce n'est pas le
rassemblement national personne ne peut
tout le monde le sait c'est impensable
d'entendre ça et donc heureusement que
on peut être fier de son hymne national
et qu'on peut pousser pour l'apprendre à
l'école sans être évidemment membre du
rassemblé national et je finirai juste
terminé merci beaucoup merci à vous non
mais respect les consignes ce sera le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup ci à tous
d' avoir participé même Macon a réussi à
tenir les
2h donc on va nous aussi être ponctuel
merciam Merci à VOUS Thomas c'est un
plaisir c'était un vrai bonheur merci à
toutes les équipes de Public Sénat et de
LCP de nous avoir accompagné dans la
préparation de cette soirée à demain
[Musique]
salut